the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the possibilities are endless at
the singfield cup in St Louis with the
field drawn a single decisive result
would have a dramatic impact on the
standings Wesley so finally got the ball
rolling defeating his opponent for the
first victory of the event ala fua
decided Wesley had the right idea but
Des having chances was forced to settle
for a draw we waited three rounds to get
one but we finally have a win and a
leader round five of amazing chess
coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round five of the sfold cup
it's a beautiful day here in downtown St
Louis rest day is on the horizon and
players going to leave everything on the
board let's go to the studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the sville cup we
have a leader who will join the party
we'll find out right
now
hello and welcome it's day five of the
sinkfield cup and after some intense
battles we now have a soul tournament
leader now with so much at stake will
the players push their limits in pursuit
of Victory we'll find out I'm
International master ianka housea and
it's great pleasure to be alongside
these fantastic Grand Masters yasis San
and Peter spider joy as always a great
pleasure to be with you in studio as
well hello everyone and Welcome to our
coverage of the fifth round of the SFI
Cup today is the day before the rest day
and the finally we did have a
breakthrough yesterday promised a lot of
fireworks as very close to having three
out of those four games being decisive
but only one was and joy do the honors
and tell our viewers the standings
absolutely Yesa and there you can see it
was Wesley so after his victory over
Richard report that moves him to first
place with two and a half points out of
four and then we have a whole group of
people all drawing their games so that
means everything is even between the all
of them and then we see Richard report
there on Ninth Place but just remember
that Yan Kristof dudo has withdrawn and
did so after round two so that means his
games have been avoided and uh the
format for this year SF cup JY well it's
a 10 player round robin and the players
are playing the classical format of 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and then
30 minutes for the rest of the game of
course the players do have that 30C time
bonus increment from move one and no
draw offers allowed which should mean
fighting chass one point for the win
half point for the draw it has been
fighting chess and uh I gave plot away
tell us the schedule
well well today it's round five on the
Saturday November the 25th but bear in
mind tomorrow is a rest day players will
not be playing they'll be re-energizing
recuperating and then they will play one
game per day until Thursday November the
30th and of course there will be
playoffs if necessary thank you JY and
Peter lots of really really good reason
for winning the sing cely and I'll name
three and those three are glory
self-fulfillment and the attention of
the adoring public perect and also what
you will just see on your screen in a
moment here
uh more reasons more reasons prize money
for this tournament prize money for the
grand chest tour and the chance to play
in the candidates in some order and this
these are the very very wellplayed
tournaments the biggest purse I think in
a history of uh chess outside of perhaps
the world championship matches this is
the price fund for uh the singfield cup
uh as you can see a very cool 100 Grand
up top 65 for second 48 for third all
the way down to in our case 13,000
because there will be no 10th Place
finish with young CH of Duda sley uh
withdrawing from the tournament and
there's also an additional purse for the
grand chest tour as a whole first place
seems to be locked up although there are
some permutations still possible but
there is a very hotly contested fight
for second and third still a lot of
money at stake as you can see 175,000 of
addition
price fund there and then of course
there is the last two spots for the
candidates and a lot of players in our
tournament are still very much in
contention and in particular the rating
spot uh the race is very much ongoing as
you can see on your screen ala is still
ahead but with yesterday's Victory uh uh
wesle saw is now within within Striking
Distance one more Victory puts him
probably a top uh that particular list
so all to play for in that all important
fight to become a candidate and then the
candidate tournament obviously gives you
a chance to fight for the world
championship match which apart from
Glory attention of adoring public and
self-fulfillment has a price prize fund
of its own etc etc etc and welcome to
woman Grand Master Anastasia Carlovich
who is uh closer to the action than we
are thank you Peter hello everyone I'm
really near to the plane Hall I'm
waiting for the players to finish their
games and come here for the interviews
we also take care of the social media
accounts of grand chest and St Louis
chess club together with beim to herova
woman Grandmaster so of course Peter
you're absolutely right everybody in the
Chess World um are following this this
event not only because of grch Tour
results or singfield Cup results but but
because of this possibility to get the
the spot in the candidates tournament
wesle saw didn't only win the game
yesterday which was Al also very
impressive for all of us but he also Al
um decrease the gap between him and ala
fuja to Five Points only and I wonder
what was going to happen today because
every game can be decisive uh not only
for singfield cup but also for for the
rating um of of those players so also
funny story happened yesterday with
Anish giri who published this funny
tweet as I was walking out of the
elevator I heard a man who greeted me
earlier tell His companion this is the
COO of chesc so fed with by Anish you
know that this year F on first of April
chesc made him COO of of ches which was
very funny everybody knew that it was
April's joke but it seems like not
everybody knows what's going on but for
sure follow social media and know who is
Anish giri and it's really nice that
people keep recognizing our players in
in in s Louis uh if you missed some
action please don't please come to
granch store website official website
for all events and sful cup as well and
check our round Recaps which are written
by Kosta Kut and beima if you miss some
action you can always find out what was
happening during the day we have also
some moments from the chess games of the
players and of course fifth round is
approaching us the players are gathering
probably right now in the hall and it's
time to get back to the studio to yaser
and joy thank you Anastasia I like this
idea of Anish as a CEO of uh chess.com
that somehow that that fits as we see
there in the World Chess Hall of Fame oi
Raa adjusting all of his pieces
something I like to do get the Zen of
the tournament Hall get myself settled
fill in my score sheet I always like
being early yeah it's good to get psed
up and have a pregame ritual absolutely
uh but do the honors for our audience
tell them what they can expect for this
round five coming up where's the
excitement oh yes so we are spoiled
today because take a look at these
pairings we have Lena Dominguez with the
white pieces facing off against the new
tournament leader Wesley so then Leon
aronian who yesterday had a break well
he's back on the board facing off
against Ali Resa fua and Richard reports
while he suffered his first loss
yesterday today maybe he can bounce back
as he plays Anish giri and there at the
bottom Maxi Vash against Yan nomachi
that one for sure is going to be a
thriller absolutely that game between
NBL and nepo has a habit of actually
deciding the outcome of a first place I
remember famously one of mv's Victories
came in the very last round as he
defeated nepo in AB excellent game and
the player missing an action today
Fabian caran will have two two rest days
in a row because tomorrow is everybody's
rest day and he will play his third
black game in a row so he has a bit of a
funky funky schedule there quite the
challenge uh for Fabius we see mvl at
the board and for mvl as we know from
the grand chess tour he needs certain
things to happen number one he's got to
win first place clear in a way his
situation is the simplest of of them all
he doesn't really need to watch anybody
else whatever happens elsewhere happens
elsewhere but his his task is extremely
extremely straightforward win this
tournament hope fa for some reason has a
meltdown but the the most important
thing is the one thing that he would
want to do anyway so I think I think for
him nothing really changes all that much
and he has a big challenge in NEPA
absolutely they've they've had some
fantastic battles over the years the the
very very long candidates Tournament of
2020 2021 featured some very important
games between the two we're going to
start our coverage with between uh the
players lanir and Wesley lanir as we uh
came into our show uh in round one it
said lanir has played in quite a number
of sinkfield Cup events he's never lost
a single game yeah no he he he has an
undefeated score here at the sinkfield
cup and uh I was just looking at him
right now is he eyeballing
Worley I think he was looking past him
but I'm not sure I guess he was looking
here as to who's our bell
ringer yeah the official bell ringer
okay let's do it the well has been wrong
the players round five underway here as
E2 E4 has been uh Lanier's
long staple opening move and you know I
think of certain players as E4 players
Mickey Adams comes to mind lanir comes
to mind and they really have a very
tight and very clear repertoire uh Peter
uh for
lanir how would you you categorize him
in terms
of prepared prepared players I mean we
were having that discussion about who's
the best prepared players in the world I
think he is very very high on the list
in particular because he wouldn't be in
very many people's conversation when you
discuss the best PR best prepared
players he is sort of slightly off to
the side he's seconded uh Fab famously
yeah and uh but even even without the
seconding work he does occasionally he
is just extremely well booked up works
very diligently on chess and um I've
always admired his chess I think he is
he plays very harmonious very kind of
straightforward simple chess pieces
generally go where they belong and
watching him play when he plays well is
is a joy absolutely well we've seen
earlier in the event Wesley essaying the
Berlin Knight F6
D3 occur D3 Bishop C5 occurred in his
his previous games I'm sure he's going
to stay true to form and Knight F6 after
all he leads the tournament he got the
black past exactly equalize let's go is
a tough KN to crack as well exactly and
uh well yeah here he comes and in fact
these two have played the bin against
each other before so they do have some
history castles no uh D2
D3 today I wanted to say that I feel
that lineer is actually more of a more
of a castle there and after Knight E4 I
think he uh varies between rookie one
and and the endgame
proper interesting interesting to see
what will what will happen today and
when I think about this particular
variation for some reason the games of
Wesley really come to mind because it
seems to me that he in
particular uh has been playing the black
side of these
positions forever I really really well I
think he know he knows exactly what he's
doing there he is extremely solid in
general and this this opening in
particular gives him ample scope to be
solid but no seems like we're getting
we're getting the opening
to the end game yeah the end game today
unless ler wants to go for the somewhat
gamly line starting with A4 or Bishop A4
there's but no yeah no yeah they going
right into didn't seem didn't seem
likely mhm well uh earlier before he
left us uh Duda had played the black
side of the Berlin against
Anish we we thought he might have
blundered upon pwn if he did it turned
out to be brilliant because I'm pretty
sure he hasn't yeah because he got a
very easy draw that was the uh Bishops
of opposite color ending round where
everybody got Bishops of opposite color
except for one uh game well okay Berlin
ending that's a a long story we'll we'll
wait for the players to uh find the
novelty in that one we'll go around the
horn I'm going to go to the game of
leavon aronian versus Ali Raa we do have
a nimso Indian with Knight F3 on move
four and a pause from from Ala because
obviously there is plenty of options
here if you want to continue playing the
nimso you're I think supposed to play C5
here right there's also the option of
course of playing D7 D5 and switching
back to the ragozin I'm sure castles
doesn't lose either
but those two I think are the main two
lines you choosing
from good to know that castles doesn't
lose B6 is also B7 B6 is yeah uh not the
trendy E3 Bishop D2 no uh lines what is
the line uh by the way where they played
the early Bishop G5 what was that called
uh that was I'm not I'm really horrible
with with variation names Boris basy uh
I had a game with sosar gligoric I was
on the black side uh where they play
Bishop G5 the inclusion however of
Bishop G5 I don't think is actually a
very good move I think black
actually more than Equalization the
lening grat that's I had it in mind that
it had a Russian name just didn't but I
imagine that if you did Castle the
move absolutely takes more legitimacy
absolutely this is why B6 Yan absolutely
correctly pointed out B6 is the way not
to play C5 or D5 and maintain some uh
some flexibility uh and queen B3 very
quickly played by by lean here so we're
uh going in slightly off bit directions
of course even this will have been
played at least dozens if not hundreds
of times but it's not the most topical
nimzo uh and
uh offering a chance I guess for Al Resa
to to to play a game of chess the choice
here would be between C5 5 and A5 C5
seems more straightforward right and uh
if if we're talking about this
particular structure you very often you
would have the queen on C2 here instead
of the queen on B3 for instance uh how
does that line go somebody helped me out
well if you don't mind me saying uh
Queen B3 against B7 B6 is actually a
line I pioneered has even got my name
associated with it and you're absolutely
right A7 A5 and C7 C5 are considered the
most challenging and I I've actually had
Blitz Games don't ask me why where they
went where I went A3 they went A4 and I
went Queen C2 and I was like I was so
proud of myself having lured the pawn to
A4 right and the point here of course is
that if you take on B4 you will have to
give up this this queen after Knight C6
and then if Queen B5 my queen is it does
get it does get caught by Rook A5
exactly so then the idea uh in my match
with thean Timon Yan played C5 as you
were about to say and then I play A3
it's very important to include the move
A3 and then you have to make the
determination are you going to take on
C3 you're going to drop back to A5 and
my my game with Yan went uh Bishop A5
Bishop G5 yeah I remember you playing
this and then castling long castling
that's precisely right that's precisely
right I I don't know if Leon's trolling
Me
by CU he has a habit of coming on the
show and saying uh you know I remembered
you know old Yasser once played this you
old he gets in his qu I I would actually
wouldn't put it past him to just just do
this to to
tick I don't think you're irritated I
think you're happy but this is a good
idea right because Ali Resa very young
yes will will he be familiar with the
ideas all the nuances yeah exactly it's
it's a very very uh tricky line and
there's some complicated variations that
you have to navigate if you're not well
prepared uh it's easy and I can kind of
guess by Ali R's uh body language there
that he's been caught a little bit off
guard by Queen B3 does look that way yes
yeah uh let's continue our uh walk
around the tournament Hall our ever
popular uh Joko piano uh with Knight C3
on the board in the game of Rich even
piis Pi yeah I think I think the lines
where the night goes to C3 are uh one of
them is joap Pian and one is pimo and I
keep on mixing up which one is which
this is the quietest one or the other
one pass the test cuz I'm looking at the
database here and it says pimo we're not
worthy we're not hooray for me uh and uh
yeah I I I gave the speech many a time
already but this is a
very I don't need very many things to to
to make me laugh and this being the
absolute invogue way of playing the
Italian is
uhar is actually making me kind of uh uh
giggle because this is very much would
be un Vogue in like the 16th century and
we're now and we're now returning to
this and looking at this very serious
and in fact this is maybe the central
attempt why you 16th century this is my
Scholastics upbringing to say you know I
I aspired the I I did some training at
at Under 12 tournaments and I kid you
know every game started like this and
they were literally just copying each
other and the big Point obviously is
that if you black where to
Castle and if you have a complete
copycat yeah so this would happen but
that's a bit too sophisticated for ah
you it happens happens after castling
first and then after D6 the bishop comes
out and Knight to D5 I have got seen so
many games that finish like that well
the funny part was I don't think you
were on camera when you were saying that
you're surprised that that that this is
in Vogue and you were looking directly
at me when you said the 16th
century like look I was my Scholastic
days not the 16th C
nice but it has actually been revived
absolutely it's it's being it's being
discussed very very seriously at the
absolute top level with the intention of
uh very often white will play Bish B3
quite quite early in in our game here
Anish goes H6 because Bishop G5 is a
serious thing to consider here uh
castles castles happens uh H3 for now
which surprises me a little bit because
very often they play Bish B3 already
here but for now reheard starts with H3
uh black gives
themselves the A7 the A7 Square for the
bishop uh and perhaps in some positions
B5 might be playable but in general I
don't think you want to be extending on
the queen side providing white with a
Target I'm expecting Bishop E3 somewhere
here MH uh and then uh we have already
we definitely have seen some of them in
the rapid and bleit I'm not sure if
we've seen uh one in the classical yet
the point of positions like this would
be that if black is in time to play
Bishop B6 black is more or less
completely fine there are sometimes
minor pressures available to white but
as a general rule of thumb if Black
Lands Bishop B6 here black will be
completely fine but this particular
position after D3 D4 could be a bit
annoying because you completely rule out
Bishop B6 because of the very simple
fork in the center right and uh it
becomes a bit difficult to make moves uh
in in particular if white can preserve
the bishop on this diagonal specifically
here B7 B5 might actually be not such a
bad idea because the bishop can no
longer stay on the uh A2 G8 diagonal
which is a best diagonal for that piece
because after Bishop B3 I think we will
quite happily start chasing it with
Knight A5 at some point uh but if you if
you add two more moves here like you
play Rook E8 I play Maybe
A3 the E for Pawn isn't really hanging
because F7 will be very very vulnerable
if you try taking everything you you run
into Bishop F7 and this is a problem uh
and V just wants to continue developing
perhaps Queen D3 perhaps even Queen D2
and then Rook A1 doubling on the f f
file with Rook F2 and then Rook F1 is
very topical whereas for black you
suddenly find yourself in this strange
situation where it's very unclear where
your next move is coming from if you
cannot challenge this bishop on C4 uh
another thing that black players do
after Bishop E3 quite often is is they
say take my slightly spoiling our
structure in the center is still better
than giving you the semiopen f file so
they just play D6 and tell you you want
to take on C5 be my guest I'm not that
bothered uh about that uh we'll we'll
see what transpires here I'm a bit
curious as to why this is not happening
faster because as I said this is a very
central line these days which people are
discussing a great deal but we heard
sometimes they play Knight D5 maybe he's
choosing between mb3 and 95 very very
nice how do they match up in their G
yeah let's check out the stats and here
they are well in terms of what classical
chess you see giri
Head Start Z to four six draws they
haven't played each other that much yeah
again that's classical chess probably a
lot more in Rapids and Blitz but that is
pretty lopsided I remember at one moment
mnus having perhaps the most lopsided
score against Hikaru of all play players
it was something seriously it was really
awful like 110 with 20 draws doesn't
matter I think it went out to to 15
until lost a game yeah yeah and I I
congratulated Hikaru I said Hikaru you
know that Magnus is the number one
player by 50 rating points goes yeah I
know that said if it wasn't for you he
wouldn't have that 50 rating Point
Gap like and I know that too what else
don't I know tell me more brutal look
I'm a I'm a professional commentator I
you know don't shoot the
messenger uh to uh yeah returning
returning to our pimo uh R actually R
actually went with A4 right mainly I
think keeping the bishop on this
diagonal rather than stopping B5 I don't
think B5 is a massive massive Strat
right and D 692 so this is actually uh
an attempt to drive the position towards
your normal Joko pianos because if you
if you continue kind of quietly and you
get and you get some kind of position
like this it starts looking a little bit
like the main lines of uh yes of our
standard uh Italian where you know you
can you can you can imagine you can
imagine something like this happening
followed by Rook a Bish B6 and the
Knight very often is aimed by play White
plays Rook E1 and then tries doing this
right uh the one important thing and
this is another speech I very much like
to give uh this particular position
differs from from the positions we would
be discuss pass in uh here because here
very often Bishop will go to A7 it will
either get chased to A7 or it will go to
A7
voluntarily whereas here it's still on
C5 which gives black a very very useful
option of playing D5 which is normal but
after B4 it should go to f8 right which
seems a bit strange because on A7 it's
on this very beautiful long diagonal and
on f8 it seemingly does nothing but the
fact that this bishop is on f8 it allows
black a lot more stability on the king
side now White pretty much never has any
initiative on the king side at all
because it just protects the whole the
whole flank and it just does better on a
fade than it does on on A7 and uh I came
to this conclusion I think for the first
time in my life I was playing in the
London candidates and there was this
game I think rajabov played White
against Lon aronian and there was some
kind of a classical Italian where the
bishop was on A7 and then at some point
Leon took two Tempe to play Bishop C5
Bishop f8 mhm and I looked at this and I
thought this is something I've never
seen before and it makes a great deal of
sense I was very impressed and I it kind
of was a core memory for me because it
taught me something about the structure
I thought I have i' I've seen for
forever there was nothing new to be
learned about that particular position
yeah and just uh thinking about the
World Championships uh world
championship match between Magnus and
nepo as Mike Magnus was hugging the
bishop on f8 and many of these Ru L
peasant saying try to break me and nepo
could not in that match by the way
Knight E2 Bishop E6 are you going to go
Knight G3 and the capture on in more
concrete terms apart from Rook E8 which
I'm sure is completely playable there is
also the question can't we just go D5
with D5 9 D5 here and go for this
structure immediately it also frankly
looks completely uh completely safe like
yeah I want to play I want to play Rook
E8 I want to put the bishop on E6 once
again this bishop probably drops back to
f8 because white sometimes has Tempe
against it so just should just belong on
f8 in this Ty of positions I think it's
a very valid option as is playing Bishop
E6 without wasting a Tempo on Rook E8 I
think white takes probably goes in some
order 9 G3 and then C2 C3 and we get the
kind of a structure we discussed on the
shows before where I think black
probably should at some point play 6 A5
to stop fight from expanding on the king
side it's nothing very much I don't
think rard came today uh with the
intention of achieving an opening
Advantage he just wants to get a La
position played and he will get it here
and is White's plan you know just to go
Bishop E3 trade off the dark Square
Bishops and then yeah we play C3 Rook E1
Bishop B3 we trade and then we pretend
at some point that our D4 D4 D3 D4 break
does something or we try to achieve
something on the king side but it's
generally speaking I think the
understanding is it's fine for black but
it's a long game with a lot of
intricacies and uh you can definitely
there's scope for outplaying your
opponent from here okay all right thank
you
definitely and some accurate chest
um see an archangel am I seeing a Joko
piano I think I'm seeing an archangel
and it's not fa at the board uh mvl
versus nepo will uh will'll go to what I
think is going to be a marquee uh game
uh the standard morphe defense uh with
Knight F6 uh Bishop C5 C3 Bishop Bishop
a there was a there was a quirk there
yeah because I wanted to I wanted to
address this first of all this is not a
pure Archangel it's a it's Bishop C5 on
Mo five not instead of the inclusion B5
s yeah the the classical uh uh and I was
honestly I was thought that the
Archangel is specifically this and that
Bishop C5 has all kinds of names you
know meller and also your have did a lot
to to to develop this was Becki
Grandmaster of Times Gone by so I've
been calling it The yif in and I've seen
it called in yti in Publications but
this is easy for you to say yeah uh but
this particular move order is very
interesting because you play Bishop C5
white plays C3 and normally there is a
very binary Choice here you can go
B5 uh which allows white to play D2 D4
uh which is its own you know Suite of
variations or the bishop drops back to
either C2 or B3 if it drops back to B3
we get you trans your your normal uh
your normal main line which can be
arrived at here but in this position C3
is not the main move right you normally
start with A4 so what you've gained if
the bishop drops to B3 is you gave
yourself an option of replying to A4
with Bishop G4 right which otherwise
wouldn't have been available right uh so
Bishop C2 I think is the main move and
there's been for for I think three
decades now a very important discussion
about this position and whether this
holds for black or not right so this is
one choice and the other choice is
something that Magnus played with black
I actually played with black a couple of
times castling and going Bishop A7
without playing D6 without playing B5
mhm uh which once again splits it into
two halves you can go G5 Knight E4 and
there are some positions here which look
at first glance like they're slightly
better for white but they all in
particular there's this end game Queen
D5 you go Bishop C2 Black Goes Knight D7
you drop the queen back and black goes
D5 and takes with with the queen in this
end game at first glance you might think
you know this is this isolated Pawn I
will now finish development and I will
be solidly better for the rest of the
game but if you look at this with
engines they will suggest that there is
a lot of very concrete coun to playay
very often starting with move Bishop F5
uh trading this bishop for this bishop
creating this D3 Square to uh start
aiming jump set and I think the current
understanding is if you know what you're
doing here with black you will equalize
wow uh so this is one way and the other
way is to play Bishop G5 and these
positions are incredibly sharp these
positions uh after let's say H6 Bishop
H4 black very often will be obliged to
play G7 G5 allowing all these sacrifices
it's very easy to go wrong and be
completely busted by Mo 15 and here
there is a lot of very very uh tricky
Theory starting from here what Yan does
though is a kind of a weird combination
of the two he goes to A7 he goes to A7
first of all
maybe Mel just thought okay I'm being
tricked I'm he wants to steal three
minutes of my time when I you know
during which I will be trying to figure
out what the what the differ yeah what
the difference is and then he will
Castle anyway right so mvl plays D4 and
now Yan plays
B5 and mvl after some thought chooses B3
black plays D6 and we are now back to
once again if we compare this to the
classical archangels yeah we we have
this position in which but there's one
difference because if you go if you go
VI this move order Bishop pretty much
always goes to B6 not a because on A7 it
provides additional slight problems for
black uh but on the other
hand why generally doesn't place you3
in4 so quickly because now when the
bishop comes to G4 this entire Center
comes under intense pressure and you
have to have a a tactical justification
for doing this so I'm I'm very
interested in this I think uh Yan
judging by the clock situation Yan
clearly won the opening Skirmish here
because I think he dragged mvl out of
the positions mvl would be very
comfortable knowing what he's doing of
course white is still like white is
never in trouble but he will have to
play on his own he will have to try and
figure out what the difference is uh
with Bishop on A7 being on A7 and not on
B6 and so on so yeah and let's check out
the lifetime but it's a very interesting
position and uh we'll see how Maxim
copes with that uh well another
onesided encounter Maxim rash Gro with
seven wins to nashi's one and 10 draws
between the pair so definitely a bit of
a kind of and this man is twice twice
Challenger to the world champion so goes
to show that mvl can uh bounce with the
best of them I have to say first of all
thank you Peter that was an incredible
Exposition about this opening and I just
I had this horrible image in my mind of
spending three
lifetimes trying to understand the
nuances and the subtle subtle
differences between having my Bishop on
B6 having my Bishop on C2 having my
Bishop on A7 for both sides and finally
they do reach a theoretical position
Peter and what's the outcome of uh this
discussion that the players are having
I'm not entirely sure I think what you
would like to do here with white and the
ideal setup if you can achieve it looks
something along these lines you want to
put the bishop on E3 because as I said
you can expect your Center to come under
very very direct fire let's say black
castles and you probably like in some
order you want to put the Knight on G2
and you want to play H2 H3 because you
really would like to stop both Bishop G4
and Knight G4 in because once once you
put the Knight on D2 the bishop on E3
kind of needs to survive so you you you
don't want to be even calculating the
you go h33 let's say you go H3 and a
big Point Knight takes Pawn not possible
because of Bishop D5 I fallen for those
traps I I promise you Vladimir pu nudy
of 1974 Washington state championship I
took the pawn on e4 he looked at me
young
man so something like this something
like this is a normal position and
returning to our discussion about
whether B6 or A7 is a better Square
I think I would still argue for B6 being
the more comfortable but one difference
I can definitely name is that let's say
we go Rook E1 Black Goes Bishop B7 now
if white goes
D5 uh and the Knight jumps away because
Bishop takes E3 actually loses material
the Excel CR reaches A8 and white
collects more pieces than black does
right uh so after 97 had the bishop been
on B6 you would have to somewhat spoil
your structure by taking away from the
center
a gotsky viswanathan andan the
candidates match where where that
happened please continue and here yes
The Rook will be a bit dis misplaced on
on A7 but generally speaking I think you
would much rather preserve the option of
undermining the White Center with C7 C6
so that the pawn is not on6 but you know
one time I had a very similar position
with the black pieces believe it or not
I played the Archangel and I found that
white just simply went A4 and then
there was a
s and exactly the bishop on B7 was such
a bad piece yeah and the pawn on B5
stands out yeah mhm but but specifically
here I think we will be in time to play
C7 C6 very much re Reviving The Bish on
B7 if it stays locked down like this you
will not enjoy it you're absolutely
correct but if you do get to play C6 and
trade away the pawn on D5 I think it
should be it should be manageable MH
there's still a lot of other options
available you can definitely think about
playing Bishop G5 uh you can probably
think about playing A4 as well mhm um
but um well I was going to ask and a
more on a practical question in terms of
the tournament situation tomorrow is a
free day no one wants to lose before the
free day do you think the players will
perhaps not take those risks and go for
something a little bit more comfortable
I think that's already Bey past them I
think the decision by Yan of playing
such a double-edge risky uh defense has
basically said I'm going to drag you
into a very sharp game whether you like
it or not and MBL is one of those people
who play ball and say okay if you're
going to force me to play very sharply
I'll gladly oblige um give me some
statistics uh tell me what's going on in
this opening how what are the outcomes
Joy who does well who does well here
it's quite balanced actually uh so I'm
just looking at the main line which is
actually A4 A4 is the main not not
unexpected
seems very logical there it actually
seems that black does better than white
there 60% draws but 27% victories for
black and um actually black is scoring
very well in this line which which uh
begs the question of black is scoring
very well Peter why isn't this the most
popular defense of all time it's hot
stuff you know I you got you you got got
my fingers trapped in the cookie jar
playing this and I put never again never
again have you gotten your fingers
trapped in the cookie jar I've I've lost
some games playing I I I at some point
recorded the course on the on the
Archangel and uh played it a bit
afterwards and I drew mvl with black but
then I lost a very painful gate of re in
the superf final did you get your money
back from the
course
author yeah I don't think authors get
money no refunds no no funds no uh it's
a very sharp line you need to remember a
lot of stuff and as usual uh again
somebody playing correctly from the wide
side it's uh not always as much fun as
it as it looks but it's very playable
and I was always very drawn to it
because I think in terms of somewhat
mainstream options black has in the R
Lopez uh this group of openings five
Bishop C5 six Bishop C5 all of these
lines they provide you with arguably
maybe the best Fighting Chance of
getting a position where white will not
have an easy way to get an absolutely
free Advantage with no risk uh and this
is you know this is what always
attracted me to grunfeld and this is
what always drew me to uh to these
positions but of course at the very very
top level you make one mistake here it
probably costs you more than it does in
let's say the Berlin yeah just going to
say that Yan appears to my eyes to have
won the opening battle because mvl uh
spending close to 25 minutes uh trying
to sift his way through these various uh
nuances that uh you see his uh thing is
can you see it there like a little
twitching going on twitching going on
it's almost like he's in full on
calculation mode right t
t uh D7 D6 and uh a stop uh let's go
back to our tournament leader uh we do
after all have a uh leader in the event
let's give Wesley so uh some credit uh
when we have left it they just got to
the ending and H2
H3 um I think of the old days Knight C3
was by far the most traditional move but
H2 H3 for various and subtle reasons uh
replaced it all and B7 B6 again it it's
one of those defenses that it just seems
to give uh black all kinds of options in
including the move A7 A5 as played by
Duda against Anish earlier I think H7
H5 uh a main line for gosh knows how
many years and now be I think leavon
aronian played this uh against gakamsky
in a game that just really was a
stunningly awesome game like a a poster
game for the black side of the Berlin
the two Bishops interesting Rook D1
Bishop B4 this this whole idea has
fallen out of fashion has it yeah I'm
just taking a look and you last game was
like
201 16 2018 2016 which feels like
yesterday to me but
really five years
ago and Rook G8 maybe this is a good and
we do have a move after Rook G8 is a
good time to stop Rook G8 uh I
understand prophylaxis and stopping your
opponent from doing something but
Rook G8 all standard Peter yeah I think
it's maybe even still Theory but even if
it isn't you it's very easy to explain
because you you would like at some point
to chase this Knight away and maybe even
more importantly it pretty much always
is aiming to land on a five clear and
you want to be able to immediately start
chasing it away go away right away
so since you you don't really want to be
playing G6 pretty much anywhere in these
types of positions because I would
create uh perfect Outpost for the black
real problems for you on dark squares uh
and Bishop C8 immediately isn't really
very playable because C6 is hanging so
you you do make this move just to make
sure that you're as equipped to deal
with the eventual Knight F5 as possible
and then you can continue developing
after Bishop F4 currently Rook d8 seems
to be completely fine E5 E6 doesn't
appear to scare the uh the black players
here all that much let's take a look as
to why why is the6 here not right so
good Bishop D6 this is a bit yeah this
is a bit surprising to me because it
just plays Bishop D6 and my point here
would be we were brought up with the
understanding that and it takes it takes
with the Rook as well that that I'm a
pawn up yes we basically we're basically
winning here right right because we have
three they have two and this doesn't
count right but uh this understanding
has been shifted
over the recent years and also after
bishop4 uh Wesley at Tempo goes G7 G5
which was the the other option the other
idea behind the move G8 is inviting
Bishop F4 G5 very
commital and this is of course a huge
game for Wesley in the ratings watch
because there we can see L Resa fua he
is so far in the lead
2761 but just Five Points behind him is
Wesley so and so a fantastic tournament
for Wesley will put him in contention
for that rating spot for the candidates
tournament any single Victory by any of
these players is wor five and uh they
could easily uh bounce on the trampoline
Bishop F4 G5 on the board Bishop G3 also
played already very quickly and uh just
not necessarily an alert but uh just
keeping an eye on the clocks Wesley has
more time than he started with a clear
indication that he had this in his prep
uh coming into today's game yeah
absolutely but I'm still a little bit
surprised by G5 I mean I've sat next to
grandm for so long now and that every
single one of them are very cautious
about pushing porns whereas I'm normally
quite gung-ho and they're steady Oni
exactly rain it in you leave weak
squares behind and here no running of
the balls for you Bishop to G3 okay so
uh if I'm channeling my uh inner uh
Wesley so there uh the line that um Rook
d8 seems very logical here uh Peter just
gave rook d8 and so I get in the the now
we no longer Play Bishop D6 though we
don't play Bishop there's a difference
I'm not entirely sure why we weren't
doing it with the pawn on G7 and the
bishop on F4 but in this position I
think Bishop C5 is stronger than Bishop
D6 okay just a second and then uh so
C7 uh not not KN B3 yeah Knight B3
though I guess maybe after Knight B3 we
finally will play Bishop D6 because we
did create a yeah we did create a
weakness on F5 for ourselves right so
driving the KN away from the F5 Square
makes perfect before we uh trade the
Bishops does seem does seem to make
sense and this is manageable I I would I
would assume and somehow the pawn on G5
gaining some space in these endings the
king might be perfectly happy on F6 uh
just impressive impressive just uh this
position Rook
d8 jeez am I going to get one of those
Bishops of opposite color position if I
play C3 it's possible yeah I think we
once again we go Bishop C5 we wait for
you to decide whether you want to allow
us to take on D4 if I go B4 yeah that's
the Bish of opposite color right I think
I am reasonably happy to taking on D4
there yeah that's that's what I think so
too uh question Knight F5 bishop f8 or
Bishop C8 Pardon Me Maybe take on D1
first and then Bishop C8 I don't know
which one is cleaner yeah yeah you can
decide it in a moment mhm let's just say
I'll I'll go Knight H6 and maybe I'm I'm
trying to head uh okay you can take on
D1 let's say in this case cuz F7 is also
hanging we attack the Knight and goes to
G4 right and then I think black has do
reasonably I'm not even sure we're doing
so poorly after Bishop takes G4 but I'm
a bit worried about that but I do have
Bishop E7 Bishop E7 covering yeah with
the intention of following it up with H5
and saying I'm going to F6 and we're
going to go into another one of those
Bishops of opposite color ending and the
Berlin Wall holds yet again but I'm
actually not convinced of what by the
opposite color bishop and that results
if the Knight were still on D4 Oh you
mean back here yeah so you we're going
to leave the Knight on D4 we're going to
do something something Rook D2 I wasn't
I wasn't thinking that I was thinking a
B4 and then a let's try before yeah
because it's stops to 65 as well so does
an additional job we'll we'll we'll fall
for whatever position you are just I'm
going to yep keep keep all the Rooks on
the board please okay Rook D5 I'll play
on the light squares A4 and I'll play
King D7 and I wanted to go A5 I wanted
you to take to feel
your yeah to feel the wrath you see you
see I haven't learned my lesson yet I'm
still pushing
for those Bishops of opposite color uh
round round one was it with round one
games uh weren't convincing I will say
that King D7 looks very natural but
there was an option of playing A5
ourselves with black after A4 I I wanted
to encourage her to invest some time in
the you know the advance uh so okay I do
have a dream I'll warn you in advance
that my dream is to play with d and you
did make it very
clear and here I I was thinking about
obviously I have to defend the weak
point so I have to go F3 you know I
don't know I felt like here this was are
you happy though Jo I'm very well C5 is
coming so probably I should have been a
bit more careful yeah you have to be a
little so maybe a A4 A5 is a little bit
appreciated the
passion I told you you want to kill
me like an idiot I Grand Master falling
into the whole trap of pushing porns
that but by the way that's the thing
that's so Insidious about the Berlin you
think you're chasing this initiative you
think you're pushing your pawns and then
at the end of these long variations you
suddenly have a weakness that you had to
deal with and it's sort of like where
did I go wrong it's very it it's it's a
very um I want to say spicy uh uh
defense and things can go wrong I mean
uh we see black winning these on those
occasions when white over presses Peter
absolutely Ely and uh
things could could actually get off the
rails here for foring year but I don't
think it's extremely likely from here I
think you do need to overpress hard hard
further down the line one thing that uh
interests me is why is Wesley thinking
because he clearly up to G5 he was very
much in book and Bishop G3 is by
definitely book by far the most natural
response to5 my feeling is he's trying
to choose between the immediate Bishop C
5 and then Rook d8 or Rook d8 followed
by Bishop C5 which are very similar in
uh in spirit right uh but yeah let's
let's leave this on simmer because okay
it's it's still a reasonably dry
position and we have and leave it on
simmer can we go and uh check out the
game between leonian and
Ali this was your yeah Special I'm
really curious what the modern engines
and guess what A7 A5 and G2 G3 so a kind
of a combination of a
Catalan uh mixed with a uh nimzo Queen
B3 A7 A5 I always try to get in the move
A2 A3 against uh these uh because like I
said I I enjoyed these positions where I
felt it was nice to lure my opponent
into putting his Pawn on A4 a completely
different approach by leavon I want to
emphasize
G3 Bishop B7 Bishop G2 D7 D6 uh when I
see that move I see that as a clear
intention of giving away the two Bishops
because you know the bishop is no longer
going back to E7 castles Knight D7
Queen C2 okay taking the square E4 under
control we can infer from this that Leon
probably disagrees with you about how
good it is to allow the a34 looking down
because you you already after 9 B7 have
a very clear-cut option of playing uh A3
forcing this trade right and the engine
does suggest that A5 A4 is by far the
best position honestly I'm a bit
surprised you're a very sound positional
player thank you very much and why why
are you so happy uh leaving yourself
with this structure on the queen side is
not IM immediately obvious to me I would
have thought this is not great to be
honest yeah well I was actually thinking
that in these positions where I have the
double pawns on on uh C3 and C4 so let's
say queen C2 Bishop C3 yeah uh bc3 I
mean in this case you could take you
could play Bishop E4 but yeah uh so A4
sorry you could throw a an A4 Queen C2
even if so you were aiming for this
structure I was aiming for this
structure where the pawn maybe would be
happier on a five yeah I can I can I can
see I can see the argument for that uh
sometimes my opponent's Castle long and
when you put your Pawn on A4 you're not
castling along anymore that is fair but
Leon clearly is intending to uh to
shuffle for now one thing that you need
to sort of consider for black I think is
I'm not sure it's a threat but you do
need to keep in mind that if you don't
take on C3 for long enough right the KN
might move away you know yeah you you
might have to start culating moves like
Knight A4 creating a threat of A2 and3
and just capturing that Bishop on B4 it
generally like if you play Queen E7 here
we go Knight A4 I'm pretty sure that uh
C5 although D5 C5 is is tricky
uh it plays Bishop E4 first and then
goes D5 and says this is completely fine
though right because now after C5 black
will have the option of playing C C5 C4
here and then rescuing retreating with
the bishop yeah but it's it's at least
something that you need to be uh on the
lookout for and also Leon perhaps is
intending to play B3
first and then he will play A3 because
the obviously the difference is uh we no
longer are running into A4 yeah yeah we
we don't have a struggler on B2 here and
this is a very pleasant structure on the
queen side many exactly I would name in
my mind this structure and white winning
is very much associated with the name of
legir kramnik but yes karpov also played
a number of very very nice games from
the white side but Kik beat carpa with
this structure with white which I think
gives him the the the
supremacy I beat karp off this this
structure with white as well in the
melody Amber uh tournaments back in the
day Queen C2 B3 A3 Bishop B2 very quiet
play by both sides actually Queen E7
already on the board and we'll see if
Leon agrees with this uh slow idea of B3
of if he perhaps has something else in
mind just a second ah Knight
B5 double threat of taking on C7 and A3
but
Bishop oh and then I guess we go D6 D5
and we say this is now a pretty decent
Catlin because you've been puffing about
and I've been developing pieces properly
I've been huffing and puffing but there
is Knight
C7 uh Rook goes Knight takes E6 and I
get to play A3 trapping your Bishop so
I've traed what have I traded I've
traded off my a pawn for your F Pawn mhm
I think uh I think if we had better
control of the central squares I would
like this quite a bit for white but the
way it is uh Bishop B4 is annoying D6 D5
is an annoying threat and it feels like
the problems we might have on the queen
side here where black has a massive
majority and also D6 D5 might increase
that majority even further I'll probably
give b a comfortable position here but
I'm Trading not quite ready with D5
right this this is this is a very cute
idea though so we I'm happy we've shown
it on screen it's kind of a Desperado
raid by follow followed by A2 A3 but I
was always under the opinion I'm trading
my a pawn for the F7 pawn it just so
happens that's one of those rare cases
where the open uh half open C file
further further justify your idea after
quein takes C6 A3 black is in trouble
it's very important to F tak6 because
here if you play C5 everything get first
got a dream yeah first of all Knight G5
wins on the spot but even if it didn't
yes loing this bishop down is is hugely
important yeah so it's very specifically
F takes C6 and then I think very very
specifically C5 and take with the c Pawn
that sort of refutes your idea otherwise
it would have been very interesting and
I bring you less than Glad Tidings from
our
archangels yeah I mean when we left it
we did leave nvl pondering and then wow
like what's happened here happened to
the pieces they just hit the vacuum
clean button and and Yan sighing
dejectedly there at the board because I
how did we get here let's was Bishop B3
it was D7 D6 and right here um Peter is
given us a very nice exposition of why
we want to play H3 why we want to play
Bishop E3 what kind of setups are ideal
for white uh one thing we didn't look at
is the most ing series of captures and
this is actually I've seen this in
multiple games exactly I didn't even
want to mention it because this entire
sequence is extremely welln and I think
it's extremely well known to give white
absolutely nothing and MV is one of the
more ambitious players I know exactly so
I was discounting this completely
completely I thought that no chance
almost no chance he ever does that right
but I guess he felt caught out enough in
the opening and he felt he burned enough
time n that he he is gone for this end
game which really is nothing at all and
once again if you look at the clocks
it's a a
Telltale I mean it's as big a red flag
as you could possibly imagine an hour 33
minutes for Yan meaning he's gained 3
minutes on his clock with the 30 second
increment for each movie he's made he
knows this backwards and forwards and
for mvl something you just kind of since
he spent 30 minutes on a double-edged
position he wasn't ready to play those
double that's how it feels and perhaps
this is also an opportunity for us to uh
show a yours the curse graphic of their
decisive result
percentages uh
because yeah that one's been lost I
think we tore it up threw it in the
rubbish we had enough of
jinxing well what happened for those of
you who haven't joined us throughout our
shows as we started our sinkfield cup
boy we came prepared we had all of these
marvelous stats explaining that what
were the most decisive rounds of the
nine rounds of the singfield cup in the
past well funny surprisingly for me it
was rounds one and two it was like
48% of uh rounds one round two was down
to 39 and then it got slowly got worse
and then at the end like round eight
which was our pick for the most decisive
round like perent he was way down and
the other stat which we found uh quite
intriguing and and here it is this P it
out from the bin this is uh this is what
we've been talking about JY this is cuz
we
said uh sight unseen we both pick round
eight as the most decisive round
absolutely and we were so
close as you can see here we got got it
completely wrong you know it's
23.7% but it's absolutely staggering
that in previous sinkfield cup editions
48.8% of Round One games have finished
decisively I mean that was just
absolutely draw dropping then the uh
other uh hand and glove with that was
that seven of the nine winners of the
sink pill cup won their first round game
so winning the first round so we were
all CH ready to go
you know Round One winners looks what
draw draw draw three rounds of draw one
thing that I wanted to bring up though
and you know
Insight here to for unavailable to to to
anyone anywhere as a kind of an excuse
for our tournament this year yeah we are
playing four games instead of five per
round that's true so percentages should
probably be lower right because there's
just a smaller smaller sample so we we
we have we have excuses ready for
players here outstanding we need those
excuses in the bin uh unfortunately as
we see mvl and Yan uh what I thought was
going to be a marquee matchup is turning
into uh a fizzle we can expect that game
to uh be drawn when the okay it's an a
game it looks drawn but it is you know
there is an imbalance the bishop against
the Knight right which should favor the
bishop y I mean can n Nashi play for
more um it's not
inconceivable niely thank you thank you
thank
you it just doesn't feel you understand
that
word it just doesn't feel like that one
slight imbalance is going to be enough
to make for uh something serious though
that's the problem you're still smiling
about the incon
just an in joke an Insider joke uh e E3
uh E4 well way in on it think let's take
let's take a look honestly I don't think
black is even better uh because uh I
think if we had the pawns on B6 and A5
you could maybe make a bit more of an
argument but with these two pawns being
uh occupying the squares uh the color of
your Bishop right some potential play
against them is possible of also after
E4
I think it's pretty much dead equal but
I I want to say that long term I think
it's easier for black to make a mistake
than it is to for for white because if
we make a number of like really really
inaccurate moves like we get here and
then we continue doing nothing okay and
we like let's continue doing nothing
yeah and and we get here and it and it
lands on C5 this is this is going to be
really really unpleasant I wouldn't say
l yeah I wouldn't say loss but it's
really really unpleasant for whereas uh
I would struggle in particular now that
MBL played E34 which I think is
completely correct because you want your
King on E3 you want the pawn on E5 to be
slightly targetable okay because the
bishop can't protect it so you have to
pay attention that you don't allow white
to attack it with two pieces obviously
Knight on F3 is easily balanced by the
King on E6 but if white somehow attacks
it with a rook that could be awkward
yeah so we've constructed this scenario
yes I made a bunch of really poor moves
for black but but still it's five moves
down the line and it shows what white
can Aspire towards whereas if I wanted
to construct a scenario like this but in
the other direction I am not sure where
do I start like I'm pretty sure first of
all the bishop goes along this diagonal
to be able to snap the Knight on B3 if
it lands there right so I guess if we
want to improve here we play A5 and
white doesn't play A4 so white once
again starts making really questionable
decisions more questionable decisions
and we get to play C5 and but but still
I'm not so sure it's not a b borderline
losing like the other one I'm not sure
how I'm losing this with white right I I
understand it might become a bit like A4
A3 becomes playable with the intention
of meeting ba with Rook A8 and you are
actually going to be struggling but you
are not obliged to take you can play B3
and yes the pawn on A2 is vulnerable but
Imagining the scenario where the black
Rook actually lands on the second rank
is quite difficult so I think we begin
by saying this is very very uh level but
we also say that it's it's sort of
easier to misplay with black but I'm not
expecting anyone to misplay anything
frankly here uh I think it's just going
to
be I like the fact that you pointed out
the Knight C5 the the
KN is a good Square for the night but I
mean the Target on E5 is something that
white can already start to do something
so for instance you went King E2 but
what happens if you were to go Knight F3
yeah we can play King F6 I don't think
it's that much of a deal we we're still
not in time for King E2 and Rook f i
thinking move the king move the king and
then
AI worse comes to worse Joy I mean Rook
of one Rook of one becomes a threat but
much much later on so
black uh has has the the luxury of even
spending to on A5 A4 because I think
critically after Rook F1 we aren't
actually threatening any particularly
strong
checks so you can even munch on A2 and
say do your worst you know yeah because
after Knight D4 the Knight can munch on
B5 but it comes at the cost of it's not
very much and another thing I will not
is that very often I I see how the
engine plays this position it does play
a for is white and very often in reply
it actually just ruins sort of quote
unquote ruins your own structure by
playing ba and A5 very important that we
have Rook f8 check here because
otherwise be very strong
but we have the unpinning check and then
takes before and the more pawns come off
the board the more we the closer we get
to Absolute equality right and the idea
of ba and A5 is very simply to play
either Bishop D7 followed by A5 A4 or
very simply Rook a B8 and trade this one
for this one once again reducing the
material on the queen side so not really
expecting fireworks here Bishop B6 K2 on
the board in the mean time I didn't want
to be a party pooper there with the uh
Pawn structure but with the King on F1
the last move E4 it even crossed my mind
that the move Bishop C4 check is
playable because if you take on C4 I
think I don't think we're touching it
exactly I mean because otherwise The
Rook goes to B8 and this Rook ending
doesn't feel uh dangerous either at this
point you pick up the King on F1 and
Abracadabra it to C1 The Rook comes to
D1 long
cast right would be illegal move in
Fisher exactly exactly uh thank you
Peter for that and we do have after King
e285 a move that you kind of just threw
out there flippantly you know Knight F3
King F6 and you go A5 and A4 we'll keep
an eye on that one I wanted to go back
to uh Wesley so for just a moment
because I was more than curious and he
did come up with that whole scheme uh of
rook d8 and Bishop
C5 uh but in this particular case Joy
you were trying to play with the Bishops
of opposite color laner did toss in
E6 um and playing for that one Bishop C5
indeed played I mean there is a lot of
danger actually for Lena in the sense
that if he doesn't do something now
concrete and for instance he plays like
some careless moves like Pon porn the
Knight on D4 could find itself not doing
a single thing on a bad circuit no posts
and the Bishops could just suddenly
spring to life and let's think about
this for just a second though okay
because I'm trying to upend Wesley's
strategy with his move G5 and the only
way I I don't think the Knight really
does anything on B3 Jo no I didn't think
it did it either so with the Knight
coming to F3 at least in this case um
Rook takes d8 and Knight takes G5 is a
conceivable threat and also Bishop takes
Pawn as you've highlighted the only way
to deal with all those is to play Bishop
D6 Bishop D6 yeah Bishop to D6 and he
here is where I was having you know a
conversation with myself about your
Bishops of opposite color 95 check yeah
if you're if you have a quest to play a
Bishop's of opposite color
position maybe this could be something
but I mean is black obliged to go Bishop
takes KN so for instance I could go King
I'm walking into it okay King F6 since
is not my pieces right very good very
well said I mean importantly uh chess
commentators we always get the right to
take our moves back not like the players
uh King King F6 is fine G7 I think is a
bit cleaner there's no real reason for
us to provide white
with Knight G4 check or something like
that King G7 followed by C6 C5 is I
think the first order of the day and
then yes optically maybe it looks a bit
better for white but the bishop bear
okay we have plenty of files for the
Rooks it doesn't doesn't really strike
me as something black will be very
worried about C let's have some f King
H2 C5 Knight goes away give me your
Bishop
pair if you take on G3 I was planning to
take with the King and like we said you
know those uh I'm a pawn up be be proud
of myself although I must admit Bishop
G3 King G3 isn't by any means terrible
or anything like that no I think it's
fine I'm looking for better wondering if
uh King
H2 ideas I still like I don't I don't
think Rook G8 Knight C4 improves my
situation a great deal so I do want the
bishop on B7 to be playing so let's go
C5 once again C5 uh Knight C4 I'm
wondering if Bishop F4 is anything I
should be happy about or not offering
the same trade but on sort of on my
terms yeah but is the F Pawn going to be
a weakness exactly this is what I
couldn't
decide
the moment yeah I did want to mention
that this the this option exists okay
um F3 let me just ask you what you're
doing and I I can take and play Knight
E5 on my next turn I'm hoping yeah King
F6 King F6 yeah I want to deny you as
many squares as possible and eventually
I will be playing Bishop D5 or perhaps
even Rook D4 yes asking you to UND
double more points and that's actually
is a very nice point that uh you're
trading on your terms uh bringing my
king into the G3 Square would seem like
a favorable Market transaction for
myself taking on F4 giving your Pawn a
little bit
more dynamism you're taking away the E3
Square from my knight and also I am very
much uh fixing the structure on the king
side so as long as I don't lose this
Pawn on the four you will you will
struggle to comfortably create a buer on
the king side this is quite far in but
can we go back to the game position okay
because what happens if white tries to
be incredibly forcing and actually plays
Pawn takes Pawn first uh has that okay
and now instead of Knight F3 I want to
go Knight F5 and I'm going for the very
simple Knight to H6 check fork and give
me your Rook give me the rook and I'm
also I think six okay I just wanted to
make that double check that that's the
you know it was a game uh yesterday I
think it was ali raz's uh game against
lanir where there was a knight on
H5 and nerves of Steel in the corner he
went King G6 King takes H5 and said you
know make my king and Peter Peter was
very very impressive King G6 was a is a
move that he will uh easily spot so long
as there's no Knight E7 check this
solves every single problem immediately
because the only real move here is
Knight E3 after which I will quite
happily start simplifying even though C7
is sometimes weak in these positions but
Bishops of opposite positions stes hang
on a second I have a past born in the
center don't be proud I am going to be
proud I take away the small things in
life the little things kill the dream
just go just go Rook G7 here C5 B B4 and
I I'm going to stop you I'm going to go
B4 B4 yeah I don't want you to play C5
you don't want me to play
C5 Okay so just because you announced it
I'm I'm not sure I would actually play4
in a real life I'm probably going to
reroute the bishop to D5
nonetheless uh with Bishop to a I
concur uh
spoken catch me if you can't it does
feel like white is well again the the
bishop yeah but the Bishops of you you
can give yourself Solace that you do
have a more morally speaking a better
structure but those Bishops of opposite
color I have seen black drawing
positions where you're two pawns up on
the king side and you just can't break a
blockade so uh this is the current
position we'll uh by the way uh lanir
okay lanir 51 minutes um when we had
left that I think Wesley actually gained
time on his clock uh that is to say he
was above 1 13 he's now 123 um as we get
ready for our very first break uh let's
remind our viewers of our standings and
uh y we're going to go on and uh let's
take a look at the standings of we have
a leader we do have a leader yesterday
Wesley so did defeat Richard report so
that means he's now in the lead with two
and a half points out of four but there
are a bunch of players there who have
drawn all their games so every
everything is completely even between
them all and uh just to make a point
that Yan Kristof Duda did withdraw after
round two so that is why there is an
imbalance of games and also uh today we
know that Bobby has a free day but just
because of that imbalance of the you you
have in a nine round tournament five
whites five uh four blacks but it
actually is turning out that Fabby who
is free today is going to be playing
playing three blacks in a row that's
quite a challenge when you have a field
like this it's like you're begging for a
white pieces after three blacks in a row
we reached that point in our broadcast
where we have to check in our our
friends at Q Boutique stl.com and we
want to stay warm on the holidays don't
we who doesn't well check it out 2023
sfil cup socks socks yes sir socks we
are proud to announce our new sfil cup
socks sock up and get yours now no
that's not what it says by the way I'm
GNA add living as we go stay on the move
with these custom logoed sinkfield cup
socks these full calf length polyester
blood socks are comfortable and sporty
great for the gym or the chessboard one
size fits
most fits
most holiday discounts as well it's
unbelievable I this is this is
unprecedented it's inconceivable that we
would offer 20% holiday shopping we are
20% discount which is available in store
and online so go to qti stl.com and uh
get shopping for all your chess shopping
needs we're going to see you on the
other side of this
sprak who's that who's
[Music]
that
L welcome back to Gras tour this time
you are with a wild card again for
single cup how does it feel to play in
such a strong tournament yeah it's
always nice I mean I'm I'm always uh
happy to to be part of such a strong
event uh especially the classical format
uh which is my favorite it's just allows
me to to think which is what I
like uh but but uh yeah it feels good to
be here even um if not as a uh main um
the participant but uh but to get the
wild card especially here in St Louis
which is where I live for several years
now it's it's uh definitely quite nice
last year you made actually eight draws
in the tournament all the games finished
in the draw and it was absolutely unique
result I think for you what do you think
will happen this year what are your
expectations yeah I'm hoping to have at
least one decision so uh but yeah let's
see how it goes I mean it's uh it's
super strong obviously and I consider my
last year result to be
good so uh yeah well in terms of the
games uh I try to fight always um uh
doesn't matter so much the the result
but uh I was happy that I was uh
fighting and playing long games uh um
yeah I hope this year it will it will be
kind of better who do you think will be
fighting for the top places in this
tournament who is in the good shape I
think you were also following this this
rapid and Blitz event I really hope it's
me I don't know that's a good C yes who
who who will be your compet competitors
yeah hard to say I mean um Fabiano
obviously uh came on top after the
rabbit and Blitz I mean he was playing
uh really strong um the last few months
uh but then he had a kind of like not
such a strong finish at the is of man of
course you could think that he was
playing lots of games and and maybe he
was a bit tired but um he came back so
you never know we have players like fuia
and Neo who are always um supposed to be
on the top so um yeah very hard I don't
like to predict such things I just like
to try to use my chances and and and
play my best for sure and actually
lately you show really good performance
in World Cup maybe could even show
better one but also second tied for
second place in US CH Championship are
you happy in with how your career is
developing at the moment yeah I'm pretty
happy I mean um of course you always
feel that you can do things better and
that uh and that you miss chances and so
on but um generally speaking I'm quite
happy that I'm still able to play at
this level uh at my age I'm not that
young anymore uh but I feel I feel good
and um happy that I can still compete I
feel as I said quite um quite good I'm
uh really hoping that I
can uh keep playing at this level for
for I mean for a long time that's um in
general my goal so uh let's see how it
goes yeah what about the preparation for
this event who is helping you these days
yeah well uh um I'm working with
Vladimir chelo for already long time uh
uh so he's helping me uh for this event
as well um we did quite well I think in
the last few tournaments I mean it was
helping me also in the in the world cup
and and the in the US Championship uh so
yeah I hope uh uh we can continue to and
even improve our our results uh you also
live not far away from St Louis chess
club as you mentioned before that you
live in St Louis do you think this
closeness to the chess club and also the
fact that you live in the capital of
American chess in now International even
chess I makes it I mean has some impact
on your chess life chess career do you
meet with people CH players here yeah
well it's definitely um uh nice to to be
here in St Louis in general because you
have a lot of um chess players U all
kind of things related to chess it's a
nice atmosphere for for a chess player
um so um the club has been very helpful
of course uh to have the support of uh
the club it's it's been quite important
in my career and uh and that's probably
one of the reasons that I was able to
keep myself playing at a decent level in
the last several years uh but yeah as I
said before it's also nice in general to
be here because you uh meet friends all
the time you get together play uh not
not only chess but maybe some other
sports that do some other things and uh
and in terms of playing here I think it
has some pluses and minuses obviously
like when you go away from home you're I
don't know kind of more Focus less
distractions when you play in your home
and uh town then it's of course uh you
can have your your friends and stuff uh
coming to cheer you up or uh just to
watch you play or give uh give some uh
some confidence but at the same time it
can be U an extra uh let's say weight on
your energy and and and and sometimes
not good but I have played well in St
Louis traditional
so um yeah I'm hoping that uh I can keep
doing I remember your son was visiting
the the plane Hall last year actually
how is he doing and he played also in
the simultaneous exhibition so how is he
doing is he still playing chess not so
much he kind of uh chose a different
path for the moment but he likes Sports
very much he's playing tennis and but he
follows
chess 100% I mean he knows all what's
going on uh he even uh tried to tries to
give me advice uh all the time so uh and
of course as he's uh uh older as he gets
older he he understands uh better and
better what's happening and and that's
also nice that's great thank you so much
for for the interview and all the best
of luck for you in the tournament thank
[Music]
you
hello I'm women's Grand Master V janova
I will be creating content for Grand
chest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world world's best players become a
member and enjoy perks such as free
classes and lectures weekly tournaments
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s l CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
flat M fact of its existence I think it
it it sends positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
we are back with all of the chess action
of round five in the sink fii cup and uh
well let's remind ourselves of the
standings so far after round four and we
do have a so leader Wesley so with his
victory over Richard report yesterday
now jumps into the lead with two and a
half points out of four but half a point
behind him while there are a cluster of
players and again for those viewers who'
just joined us let's remind ourselves of
the round five pairings Dominguez faces
off against Wesley so leevon ronian
plays fuja report giri and of course
back lra against Nan Nashi
and well it's uh always an action filled
round at the sinkfield cup of course and
we have talking by action even more uh
exciting news because I'm very pleased
to announce that we will be joined by
the one and only former world champion
Gary
Kasparov and and that will be absolutely
wonderful I'm still fighting over the
sinkfield socks here it's a it's a
battle for for equality onset and trust
me joy is a is a fierce competitor where
it's concerned let's jump into the chest
we haveing me of no no no I would never
never uh Venture that far uh Jump Right
In and tell us what where the action is
Peter uh everywhere everywhere excellent
this position
is differs from all the other positions
of the round in that no pieces have been
traed everything's on the board
yeah people are still fighting for uh
to determine what the structure will
look like this bishop probably will get
traded for this Knight sooner rather
than later I would assume because
eventually you do have to start worrying
about Knight B5 or Knight A4 followed by
A2 A3 um and this the more the more we
watch this game the more it reminds me
of all those old kumy games although I
think uh Vladimir his choice in the
structure I think very often was not G3
but E3 Bishop e so I think he played
them more often with the bishop develop
the wordss this square right
but the one we have right now uh is is a
very complicated position uh which I
think promises a a long fight our Berlin
is I just wanted to say if you don't
mind uh for the current position uh to
my way of thinking if if it was my move
as white I see D4 D5 as a serious threat
absolutely if you put D5 on the board
and if you take uh uh on D5 with the
pawn let's just say yeah I have Knight
H4 very common idea dangerous very
effective spin also it lands on A5 with
great force and this is why I think it's
important here for black to start with
Rook f8 well that was what my question
if my move d4 D5 is a threat is D6 D5 a
possible uh way of meeting I think it is
yeah I I think it's playable even though
this might not be the structure that you
necessarily uh so much in favor of
because you will have to also uh give up
this bishop yeah I want to recapture
with the pawn though yeah if you do this
you're opening yourself up potentially
to S shananigans to do with this bishop
I think we probably start with dc5 yeah
I'll take that with the hanging Pond if
I can get away with it Knight A4 Knight
a in particular KN A4 be very very
unpleasant because A2 A3 already is a my
Bishop a massive threat and you the
bishop
yeah I like my Visions I know yeah okay
very good and another thing to say about
this obviously Knight takes D5 is
completely unplayable because you do
lose your piece right but the more
interesting thing is Bishop takes E3
would perhaps be somewhat playable if
not for the fact that D5 D6 nice inter
also lures your queen to D6 which is not
the best Square in the world and I
wouldn't say this is so bad but it's
definitely a pleasant little Edge for
why these types of positions I think
lights great yeah they are almost the
absolute most you get very often the the
type of a structure where you have the
two Bishops you have a very solid
structure some potential Targets in the
end games on the queen side fair so you
were about to say instead of the move D5
I like Rook f8 specifically so that in
this position uh we will have Bishop
takes E3 followed by Queen takes C2 so
it gives us an additional source of play
R f8 is a very concealed idea it's not
necessarily the most easiest to spot not
at all and can we play that whole
variation with Knight B5 again and try
to suggest the bishop on B4 is about to
get tagged Queen yeah this is actually N
is a very serious move and I think uh
this might be a very valid reason not to
play Rook f8 because uh on my screen
here we force Queen C1 and then we just
go C5 takes D4 and we say you want this
exchange be my
guest I was going to say yes and then I
then I thought no and and and this is a
very very solid structure in the center
the bishop will quite safely drop back
to C5 and even visually it does look
like you have enough compensation here
and in the meantime yes sir yes you're
you're a mind reader uh
oh D6 D5 has been played by Ala
specifically for those Reasons I'm
pretty sure exactly the reasons Yer was
describing alza was worried about the
Knight A4 about the D4 G5 threat and he
didn't like all the other ways of me
Meeting those threats so he goes with D5
but after she takes D5 he has to answer
the question what's your intention here
by the way not that I'm proud of the
move D5 because yeser you know what I do
is after the show is I go over the games
with an engine just to see how close my
understanding was and yesterday there
was this game that was very compounded
game Wesley so versus Richie report it
was this Kings Indian defense where
there was a certain moment where both
players were going back and forth and
was saying the one thing Wesley
shouldn't do is play A4 to allow A5 B5
Knight B4 so of course I look at it with
an engine and the first move of the
engine was A4 the one move I said don't
play A4 the engine says top move very
good D5 but that move D7 D5 D6 pardon me
yeah that was really uh annoying uh it's
Queen takes C3 Knight takes D5 and
something like Queen D2 is also actually
a bit better for white but I think the6
is slightly more precise but the issue
for ala here is annoying as those
positions are they might by this point
be his best choice because if you go for
this whichever capture on C5 you choose
let's say you take on the bishop and
then E3 followed by Knight E2 F4 there's
also Knight H4 F5 ideas here this is I
think quite clearly uh not the best
version of this type of position because
uh uh White I think gets to
make all the comfortable moves here
unchallenged right and if you if you
take on C5 with the Knight you're also
opening yourself up to uh all kinds of
things Knight Knight H4 here is is quite
unpleasant and after Queen E6 I mean I'd
be looking at Knight F5 I would also be
wondering if maybe I can bring the other
one to G4 Contin to create the threat of
A3 seemingly once again uh the heartless
uh silicon suggest this is not entirely
unplayable but I would be very very
worried with black here uh
so maybe eventually you settle with
Bishop takes C3 but uh ala is a very
Dynamic uh aggressive player in general
and for him the idea of having having to
play this position will probably not
bring a smile right to his face tears of
joy all right well keep uh uh keep that
on the boil in the meanwhile I want to
go to MV versus Yan that was an ending
uh the players are actually still kind
of slow playing it in my mind I had
already resolved that this game was
going to be a draw when we left it we
included the move A5 for Jan A4 for mvl
takes takes and the players have reached
this position you had
shown uh nice idea for white to get a
knight to C5 why isn't black with his
Bishop happy I think he is uh I'm also a
bit interested in the decision to play
C7 C6 here because as I
mentioned this idea with with the
followup of A5 A4 and fixing the pawn on
B2 seemed like it would solve every
single even potential issue on the spot
and I'm pretty sure Yan is aware of this
so I'm wondering if he thinks he can be
better here that was I'm wondering if he
if he feels that uh this is alive enough
to actually try and ask some questions
because he feels that there's zero risk
and perhaps in this position in
particular after abcb you can play A5 A4
leaving white with this Pawn on B2 it's
very unclear how if ever we will be able
to attack attack with any piece that's a
different issue yeah but uh
yeah it seemed curious to me that he
didn't go ba4 here because I'm I'm I'm
absolutely certain he is aware that he
could have basically equalized on the
spot by playing B B4 Bishop D7 A4 B8 the
entire Queen side comes off and
everybody is sort of satisfied maybe not
happy but satisfied but uh seriously
speaking I grew up uh with the age of
Bobby fiser uh 1972 world champion a lot
of uh people got caught up in the whole
hoopla of Chess and this became known as
the Fisher ending literally rook and
Bishop versus rook and Knight probably
because of the mark timean off Match
where he famously won with the rook and
Bishop against T and coaches in America
probably for that matter around the
world have been set
for Generations that a rook and Knight
are better than a rook and Bishop when
all the pawns you know are on one side
of the board but when we have pawns on
both flanks the bishop is supposed to
out uh maneuver the Knight so after C6
after you get to this position yeah
according to the coaches of
America blacks for
Choice that's all you need to
know feel like why is the one that can
press right until you ask yourself the
question exactly where are you're
supposed to press here I think like in
in more general terms I absolutely agree
with you I I agree with with every word
wholeheartedly but um I think the wide
structure we are we are going to play 5
A4 because we need to free up The Rook
on A8 it needs to be doing something so
there will be this structure on the
board right it's only black who can
progress like for instance every if you
take it on a piece by piece kind of
thing the can find itself on C5 that's
keep keep the Rook sorry the Knight on
D2 at Bay Rook can also find itself on
an open Line Rook f8 or Rook to it feels
like we we are always going to have
enough uh enough coun to play here with
white I mean it plays A4 A3 here and
that does ask a question because I
managed to put my pieces on such squares
yeah that protecting C3 is might be
awkward more Awkward more Awkward than
it I would ideally wish and even this
position
uh and this is what I wanted to bring up
is that the weirdly the pawn on E5 I
think is more vulnerable than the pawn
on e4 with the bishop on E6 needing a
lot of time to attack it and the KN on
of3 occupying a very very good square
and even even a position like this uh
with the with the active pieces for
white uh seems to be seems to be fine so
I think a combination of it being very
very difficult for black to make
progress in general and plus the fact
that the Pawn on E5 I think is somewhat
more vulnerable than the pawn on
e4 I think you have to work here with
white to be worse it's not impossible
everything is possible in life but sure
I think you have to try hard for white
to go and by try hard you mean like do
nothing do nothing for because you know
I had a situation in my mind where if
the black king were allowed to get to C5
right you know you could actually
sacrifice the porn E5 as long as you're
coming in exactly yeah absolutely some
line like this you can you can very very
easily imagine you see winning for black
right just win but but yeah not not
going to not going to happen and is not
going to pass for five most
here no he's not again we haven't really
taken that
uh deeper look at let's jump to uh
Richie and Anish Gary because I'm just
seeing a move that I have to say um is
very confounding to my eyes when we left
it uh we left it in a position where D6
D5 was played remember back here early
and after Knight E2 D5 yeah so Richie
got in this move A5 which is coming up
right here and the whole purpose behind
this move A5 is literally to prevent B5
as well as B6 you never really want to
uh create a weakness so I kind of
mentally had put that aside like black
is not playing B6 and Knight Knight F6
is forced because Queen B3 was a big
idea yeah and Knight F6 as you're saying
uh another idea behind the move A5 is
not to allow Knight to C6 to A5 so as
you were saying Joy Queen B3 nice nice
press right a nice press so Knight here
takes takes Queen a and I'm thinking to
myself the one thing black isn't
supposed to do is to play the move B7 B6
because you know I I'm trading on B6 and
I'm opening up the a file for my rook
and woohoo look at me go and Peter no I
mean Anish one of the world's top grandm
saying I'm perfectly happy to to uh
allow the pond structure to change it's
it's interesting one
uh I my initial reaction was similar but
for more concrete reasons even because I
think if you allow black to play B6 B5
here yes there's a somewhat backward
Pawn on A6 but what B6 does is that it
it completely removes the question of
how are we going to for the rest of the
game because the queen B3 is probably
going to stay on B3 for a while and be
annoying yeah we we we no longer have to
worry about having the pawn on B7 which
we will have to dedicate a full piece to
protecting because I mean yes you can
probably protect it with tactical means
I'm assuming that after Queen D7 taking
on B7 although it does take on B7 I was
wondering if maybe we can play against
the queen here somehow with some ideas
of like removing removing all of our
pieces
attacking it with a jump but seems to be
working out for white but still this
very very deeply rooted idea that
trading towards the center is good yeah
trading away from the center bad right
very bad right uh but also on a very
very specific uh specific note I was
worried about D3 D4 right because the
current setup with the Rook on E6 being
vulnerable to uh uh The Rook on the and
the Queen on B3 I thought e takes D4 is
very obviously quite quite bad yeah
there's a lot of very vulnerable pieces
along the sixth rank we are threatening
D4
D5 and currently with the pawn still on
B6 not on B5 and the pawn on A6
constantly sorry that's not the move I
wanted to make and the pawn on A6 still
uh hanging vable we don't have very many
pieces that can move so without dropping
something on the queen side right and I
thought how are we meeting this with
black but both E5 E4 and even more
upsettingly a quiet move like Bishop D6
C7 appear to be entirely playable we've
side not sidestep but we've created
prented D4 D5 and covered Pawn on B6
covered the pawn on B6 we probably want
to play something like Queen D7 next and
then we will start threatening it e
takes D4 e 5v4 is something that is
always in the air uh there's no kind of
uh point to like putting the Knight on
F5 in these type of positions it gets it
gets eventually kicked away I think we
it's the Knight on F5 in Spanish Italian
positions needs to be supported by
having more pieces on the king side and
if your followup is something like
Knight H2 there's really nobody there we
can just kick it away quite comfortably
with the queen on F3 in the second
Knight on G3 we we will be very happy
here you know your Classics Jeffy but
but on its own it doesn't seem to be
generating enough of a enough of a
threat I'm also the the more this
position is on my screen the more I am
curious about the question of what is
the other option why hasn't TX B6 been
played played it's hanging with a I
think it has it has I think it will be
played just just just now okay and and
now since D4 isn't a point and you as
you highlighted that if you do go D4 and
then Knight F5 the Knight is just
hitting it
thinner what happens if you just jump in
now and you know I have my idea of going
Queen A4 swing the queen over to H4 it
once again kicks it away immediately but
I wonder what happens if I ah okay here
I blundered something BL with the
inclusion of B5 and D4 this is suddenly
very very dangerous for very specific
reasons though because E5 V4 now loses
the bishop takes H6 which is why we and
it's very beautiful because we sacrifice
one and then we pile on pile on the The
Pawn on F7 and this is very very
dangerous for black that was even even
more interestingly after Bishop C7
there's this fantastic tactical blow of
Bishop F4 once again using the fact that
there's a lot of pieces very loose on
the six uh and ef4 Rook H6 is withen
takes and taking on C6 to come is very
very bad so this is dangerous for black
but B5 is I'll pretend I saw all of that
when I suggested kn5 KN F5 is the Lynch
pin of the entire combination without it
never would have
work does does look a bit like black is
asleep on uh on the job there if you
play be 5 years so 97 is uh is better
and there's no Knight to D4
ideas the other one the other
one maybe we take on D4 that was a nice
move wasn't it it is it is take on D4
and take I know I know I just want it to
be flashy it is it is a very flashy idea
and if E7 I assume we have to take up
slightly awkwardly with the Rook oh no
maybe we don't I think we can may take
with the queen because Queen takes B6 I
can finally land my land my
tactic I can land my tactic with the
idea of Bishop H2 and Rook takes B6 so
you were waiting for that one very much
so so this seems playable for black my
having exhausted the immediate tactical
ideas I want to say that maybe my dream
transformation of this position for
white would involve something like Bish
B3 B5 and maybe Knight E4 and in this
dream world black is somehow obliged to
take right and then maybe eventually
I'll get the Knight over to D5 or at
least a rook and ab and then maybe I
will have some pressure even though uh
black probably gets starts first by
bringing the Knight over to C4 and it's
not very clear but another thing to say
here is that Knight tak4 is by no means
Force I think you can very easily just
ignore my night4 for quite some time
exactly uh quick question for you Peter
in that line where you went D4 Bishop C7
pause here for just a moment cuz we can
captures a couple of times on E5 and try
to make like say D4 takes E5 Knight
takes E5 Knight takes E5 just a KN D4 or
so Knight D4 and then the idea was isn't
isn't A6 and B6 a little bit vulnerable
in this ending not particularly you can
after Bishop days you can
always F4 let's get
Rook E1 is hanging go hated it yeah hat
it yeah but Bishop
E3 B5 simple chess and now A6 is doubly
protected this is a very nice Rook on A6
still now you can go Bishop D4 yeah I'm
obsessed with brick on E6 yes hunt it
down Joy you can do it the
huntress well okay but this is more or
less where I was aiming for The Rook on
a I'll throw in Bishop takes F2 and
claim that even this is maybe not very
much really but uh yeah I understand
where you're leading this TOS maybe B5
is a little bit less safe air I was
think the Rook on A1 gets into into play
much more rapidly than the Rook on A8
and then Knight F5 and uh who's cooking
uh on the king side but all right uh
this is a little bit maybe better for uh
Richie let's uh just jump around a
little bit more as we again we're going
to have very very special guest and oh
please we guessed it correctly we
guessed it correctly the whole line is
on the board now after between the after
Le Leon correctly played C takes D5 here
Bishop takes C3 was the choice I think A
wise choice bya but he will now have to
defend this position which is not bad by
any stret but is definitely much much
much more pleasant to play for white the
two Bishops after Bishop takes C3 and
and break that down for us a little bit
more because if I'm black and if I go
Bishop E4 and queen C6 I'm supposed to
have uh you know the light Square
diagonal you know shutting down the
bishop a little bit let's say I take I
have to take now because of this battery
I have to take with the queen it has to
drop back to E7 I assume right
and now I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
Vlad will play would play Bishop F1 here
right you you because honestly I have a
feeling I'm at least slightly better
even if I play Knight G4 but but I want
to play for more I want to play Bishop
F1 then I want to play Knight D4 then I
want to play F3 and E4 and if the bishop
returns to B7 it will be completely cut
off by that uh wall of Pawns and these
positions once again it's I'm not
claiming this is panic stations but this
is so pleasant to play for white and for
black and for black you are resigning
yourself to a long defense where you
really need to control all of the
squares you need to make sure that the
Knight Never Lands on C6 very much need
to be mindful of this idea of F3 and D4
once the comes from from the F3 Square
this is very very pleasant for what
absolutely so leavon is going to be
pleased with his uh seran attack yeah
and guess what he took with the queen
queen takes C3 not Bishop takes also
also playable I was wondering if uh if
that made any particular sense I think
you have it on move 14 I know but it's
currently refusing to click on
it's refusing it's refusing to pay
attention to us yes you called this the
Sahan attack yeah and uh well according
to this database don't damp damp yeah
the Marcel Duchamp the artist yes he
played it I should have studied his
games as a kid I knew I mean I just
studied his artwork I didn't games no I
I'm sure it is more commonly known as
this thank you that was very kind of you
to say uh we did have uh a bishops of
opposite color outing uh JY in the laner
Wesley game as uh We've caught up with
the players um I would pardon yeah you
know I you know something I once
attended a lecture by the Norwegian
Grandmaster yon Ludovic Hammer yes on
Rooks and opposite color Bishops yes and
he was entirely obsessed with them and
he kind of said one thing that's most
important is if you're trying to eek out
an advantage what you got to do is you
got to control the counterplay of your
opponent so for instance in this
particular position um you've got to
stop this bishop on B7 from activating
itself even at the cost of a a pawns or
something so for C6 C5 so C6 C5 is
Black's uh attempts yeah and if you're
on the side of the aggressor he was
saying that the most important thing is
first of all don't think about the
result but instead construct the end
game in terms of mini plants so he said
you know step one would be maybe improve
the king then improve the Rooks and then
bearing in mind you've always got to
lock down your opponent's activity and
then break
out so and ever since then I've always
been quite enthusiastic about Rooks and
opposite color Bishops in games manyi
plans and manyi plans and I I feel like
okay this is something that one can play
and when I look at this position I see A
Tail of Two Bishops yes the bishop on E5
fantastic piece and already like I'm
jumping ahead in my mind and I'm like
look at what could happen if white were
to get F4 and it was backed up by a rook
and you know would be the King on an
open exactly and if you manag to contain
Black's activity like Stop The Rook
coming to D D2 and stop the Bishop from
opening up then it's like it feels like
a serious Advantage no question about it
if uh Wesley just sits still and allows
the Rooks to to aggress and the bishop
on B7 to remain passive conversely much
to uh Yan's point if you Abracadabra
magically transfer the bishop to D5 and
then it's sort of like that Bishop has a
its own wonderful Vista of the board you
could imagine that equality isn't that
far away it's but it really is white
making something with his initiative
here and now if he doesn't do it really
like in the IM mediacy I think slowly
slowly they'll be uh equalizing I I just
have this uh great story with uh uh Yan
um I was doing a with chess.com we were
doing the commentary and Danny rench uh
shouts down so what is the Norwegian
public thinking about this match and and
look the aners well I'll tell you what
they thinking because I told them what
to think it was me
I've been telling the public and this is
what they think because they think
whatever I think and I thought it was
just brilliant the way he said I mean
not just an influencer the entire
Norwegian public was spoonfed
this this opinion of uh L and it just
tickled My Funny Bone I just thought it
was so funny I'll tell you what they
think Rook
E1 and well here he is um well well it's
my pleasure to introduce former world
champion Gary Kasparov to the
show hello Gary welcome hi hi what
what's up today yes yes I wanted to ask
you the same thing how are you Gary what
is up with you what have you been doing
I'm no I'm fine I'm just you know I'm
I'm counting Counting the size of games
in the tournament so you need one
hand try trying to reach high five yes
nice uh but Gary it's not through lack
of effort it's just that the play The
Players very important point you know
this is the this is what people very
often don't understand that it's you
know it's a it just shows that opponents
are just you know are um you know
deserve each other so that's the you
look at the at the computer score so
it's very often 98 99 so that's it's the
the Precision which means you know
that's they play good chess they a lot a
lot of actually a lot of it's it's it's
it's bad it's bad luck for for for um
for viewers for for the for the audience
right because it ends up with with with
drawers and and and no blood is spilled
but again you can't you can't blame them
for not trying yeah absolutely and I've
heard of the some people on Twitter
saying that it's it's to do with a risk
aversion that the top players these days
are just not inclined to take risks um
do you agree with that opinion
no now can you be more specific because
again Twitter audience you know often
you know just you
know uh it's comprised of Chess fans and
they're just looking for you know all
romantic chest you know there's fight
blood all over the board no but could be
a bit more specific what kind of risk so
yes you can probably blame them for not
you know playing them very sharp
openings uh okay the only decisive game
so far you know report play Kings India
that's by in in in a computer era that's
already decisive
mistake so um but otherwise again they
they try they're trying they're trying
um yeah I yeah how you can force players
to do moves that are not recommended by
the computer because they all prepare it
with machines and um it's you should
blame probably the of machines as much
as the players unwillingness to go
against machines advice right well today
for example to the point that you were
making uh Gary uh the game between mvl
and nepo nepo came and he played a very
challenging uh risky defense with Bishop
C5 Bishop A7 and tried to engage some
sharp lines with his opponent and the
mvl just shut it down on move nine takes
E5 yeah yeah yes sir yes sir yes sir
again I I'm I'm I'm out of professional
chess but I think I could recognize that
eventually with reverse moves order they
reached a famous theoretical position
what was Black Bishop on A7 yes that was
very interesting idea because I think it
just you know it neutralizes A4 White's
main idea it's the same position but he
he he he he changed the move order and
and he had a bishop on A7 instead of B6
right that's yeah and and I mvl couldn't
find any
any anything wrong with this new um
structure and he just took on E5 which
is totally you know it's uh it's it's
very innocuous so you don't do it with
Bishop on B6 right exactly so that's
that should we give credit and Napo you
know came up with a relatively simple
idea it's not that it's invented you
know in your bicycle but still playing
Bishop C5 and then Bishop I and then B5
right that's an interesting move
exactly and it's confused mvl Gary this
is the uh SN cup obviously it's the end
of the
2023 tour we'll be crowning a champion
it seems like one Fabiano Karan has
taken all of the mystery out of who's
going to be the grand chestor champion
your perspective as the organizer it's
your brainchild how do you see this year
where you satisfied with the grand chest
tour and uh what it has evolved into
look I'm very happy with with the fact
that we already here for so many years
yeah so when it started in 2015 it was
yes you know it's it's another try and
as we know many tries in the world of
chairs they just you know they show up a
lot of Promise uh and then just you know
lost lost all um all the excitement you
know all the Steam and run out right uh
um uh and uh um
as of today you know I think the
that's we we could see that this is the
most prestigious classical event in the
world so now we even chess.com is
covering
it yeah so and and um again it's it's
very important element now of the modern
Chess World because it's so easy to lose
the connection between professional
chess uh um professional chess players
and classical chess and I think uh
singfield Cup and the whole Grand Tour
keeps it keeps this connection where we
have classical rapid Blitz and and we
have huge interest so everybody wants to
play and um um okay Magnus doesn't play
the whole cycle but he plays rapid you
know and and and and and Blitz so it's a
it's a major event and it has it has
very two very strong sponsors on both
sides of Atlantic and and we will
continue and again I think it's very
promising even fed now recognize the
import because it's being included in in
in in their very very comple complex
system of qualification I still couldn't
figure it out but I
know but I know somehow this results are
being being being counted but as you
said you know it's it's unfortunate for
for chess fans but it's a it's very
natural development of this year events
because Fabiano was the he was the most
stable has most stable performance yeah
just every year very very solid just
it's very impressive because now it's so
easy to play one tournament well and
then just you know you you you lose your
interest or concentration and again he's
no longer that young so we know by by by
even by stent of this tournament so uh
but his performance is is quite
impressive and that's why I mean unless
something very dramatic and negative to
him happens in the next few days so we
know the outcome exactly and uh well
looking to the future I mean what do you
hope to see for the next Grand chest
tour in
2024 look I don't think we have to
invent you know just something something
brand new it's the model if if you know
if it's if if if the tap is ain't
leaking you know you should you
shouldn't fix it is this I think it's
it's it's it's a working model and um I
think that we will um um just you know
keep keep up with with what we already
you know developed uh um ideally would
like probably to add one more event so
one more uh rapid rapid event but just
to to increase number of players who
could who can participate the problem is
that the Fe the calendar is so messy and
there's so many events so that's why you
know you don't want to over um over to
make players overwork exactly so uh but
I would say that one more event rapid
you know it's event in somewhere in
Europe in Western Europe probably would
be a good idea because you see now we
have yeah we have kind of Gap because we
have Eastern Europe and and the United
States so it's amazing that you know
nothing happens you know between between
Wars and and London right uh I remember
we had a wonderful event in Africa I
think it was a rapid and Blitz event
there Gary that that extra event that
was a long long time ago yeah but it was
really really nice it was really nice if
you could revive that Gary uh yeah look
African continent is a little bit now
just you know it's um it's it's it's
it's a risky place for organizers
because and sponsors because it's let's
say politically unstable um I think it's
will be
difficult have to be honest but again my
first interest would be to do something
in in Western Europe still you know we
have you know this this huge um portion
of the wall of chess with so many
registered players probably one probably
the highest number of registered players
per
probably but per per per per capita so
it's not having any any grunes to rents
we had we had was a period we had events
in in Paris yes now it's it's no longer
there London Paris and now it's it's
it's a big empty spot on on on our map
exactly Peter join in the conversation I
know that you and Gary enjoy your Fisher
random chess uh games together well Gary
Den enjoy them more than I do I don't
think I've ever I've ever achieved 50%
in our training
so yeah what's happening today yes
exactly well we unfortunately mvl and
nepo they have a very balanced position
this balanced ending rook and Bishop I
think this one is about even end as we
speak yeah yeah in a in a repetition so
nothing's happening there we think Leon
oh pardon me let's just uh go to the
game of Richie versus
Anish again again pretty pretty balanced
I wanted to ask Gary because I think his
opinion will be the definitive one on on
this as a many other positions just how
much better does Gary think leevon is
yes this is uh that was also that that
that that wasn't uh the position it was
this one uh Gary uh Bishop the board
dark dark squar Bishop for leavon
against Ali raza's Knight on C5 the
problem is you know the problem is since
I'm watching it online so I'm I'm few
moves I'm I'm there's a delay for
you unless you're willing to to to
reveal the mystery I think it's a
problem sorry Gary we don't we're
talking fair play I'm on move 12 I'm
onve 12 you're some way behind then and
I'm behind I I I suspect I know what's
happened probably you know was this is
he took on his three eventually and it's
but but again I I I can hardly you know
give my um my uh my opinion because it's
um you definitely have position probably
at move 16 or 17 now okay so indeed
you're were right Bishop B2 for white on
move 12
D5 C takes D5 Bishop takes C3 C3 Bishop
takes C3 no D6 D6 D6 ah D6 yes inzo
Queen takes D6 Queen takes C3 Queen e 7
D takes C5 Knight takes C5 so it's two
Bishops but the bishop on B2 is is it's
it's very nice diagonal we like
white and and since you've played so
many matches with karpoff you would have
a a very good feel for the advantage for
white how big is it this advantage in
your in
your mind yeah but black black is very
solid and uh
um um I'm thinking specifically of game
24 in Spain the one you had to win yes
but it's yes but it's it was more about
psychology than about the call of the
position so this is not yeah keeping the
pieces alive keeping the position alive
I'm I'm thinking
now um maybe white should play something
Queen E5 me too so shockingly Leon's
Choice was Knight F3 to
E5 uh but I agree Queen E5 just keeping
Queen E5 was interesting because it
keeps you know just black Under Pressure
and potentially you have something like
Knight H4 and Knight F5 as I don't know
if it works or not right because for
after Queen E5 it's my move I saw
playing Knight H4 Bishop G2 Knight F5
probably winning and Knight takes G7 or
Knight H6 six Queen no Knight H6 Queen
takes F6
nice yeah Queen E5 let me just show uh
to our audience how we could how we
could lose this in Abracadabra in just a
few moves with the black side uh Bishop
knight5 Knight F5 Queen B7 defending the
bishop Knight Knight H6 check oh very
nice you know this one Joy you studied
this as a young lady whoop
and there you go so yeah Queen E5 a
little bit surprising for us was the
choice of leavon which was Knight
E5 it's probably still better for white
because you know it's the then
eventually Pawn comes on F3 and black is
under pressure but it's a it's
unpleasant but I think Queen E5 could be
even more more ambitious exactly exactly
more ambitious Gary uh I we we we talked
a little a little bit about the grand
chest tour the history the future but
more specifically your history I saw you
did a video series uh chess 24 with Gary
uh on the YouTube it it looks like a a
really marvelous interview that you had
with levitov what uh projects chess
projects are you working on look it's
it's you know we finished the recording
now so that's is I don't it's is the the
17 18s 18 series been
released um and it was very it was
memorable because I had to go throughout
my early years and uh and that's that
all his suggestion so we started it just
the idea came up early but eventually
it's it's it's you know it's happened
after my mother passed away so that's
it's for her memory so that's because
there so many yeah events there are
connected directly or indirectly to to
to to the role she played in my life um
and that's you know that's that took
almost two years of recording um uh
because he kept cutting it so that
otherwise it would be probably not 24
but it's just 100 hours and the Ser the
um and it's they they kept you know
growing and every time you know I
recorded something I thought I forgot
this I forgot that so this is It's if I
if I had to do it again now so it will
be probably again
quite different because it's the um
there was so many events that um that I
I I wanted to include but then just you
think about it after after Mass that you
already recorded this ah I just forgot
this one for me it's such a wonderful
personal Memoir and it's just sort of
like I would have loved every world
champion from Alexander alakin to
Emanuel Lasker to Bobby fiser to have
such uh a personal uh trip down your
memory L Lane as your career cuz
personally uh congratulations I I I
found it to be outstanding and uh no as
now I I'm doing much less CH than other
things you know these days so I um yeah
I wish I had more time uh but I it's
it's we have different war games now in
the world
yes Gary thank you so much for joining
us so I'll be back at the the last round
and of course I will be at the opening
ceremon at the closing ceremony oh very
good look forward to seeing you then and
thank you very much much Gary for
joining us thank you for those of you
again who uh just didn't understand the
in exchange I was having with Gary on
YouTube there's a marvelous marvelous
Series where Gary just talks in a very
per personal easy relaxed way about you
know his whole career and his
advancements and as he just explained
the role that his mother played in his
life and many many people and it's just
a it's such a personal accounting it's
just like an autobiography with video
and audio and pictures it's just
fantastic no I I love it when uh the top
players just easily just convey what
they're thinking and what they're
feeling at the time because often we
have this assumption that everything
comes easily to them but absolutely it's
not the case whatsoever and I'm glad
that you mentioned it because I didn't
know yeah it's marous do look it up it's
uh it's definitely worthwhile uh Peter
uh pick up the action if you don't mind
please well action for the forgiven
value of the word action when when this
game uh is concerned where uh we left it
somewhere here and after night of three
night King F6 Rook F1 Bishop C2 Rook F4
as we mentioned uh mvl is reminding that
the black that he also has his own
threats and eventually Yan did choose A4
A3 which is very logical but white has a
number of ways to make pretty much an
immediate draw here uh shockingly even
this is completely maybe not shockingly
but even this is completely fine giving
up the the pawn C3 with
check picking up picking up the E5 Pawn
next but what mvl did is even more
practical you play King G2 you say if
you want to give me an opportunity to
give a discovered check I'll put I'll
I'll put an I on a better Square
eventually or you can repeat and we can
uh a draw we can make a draw and for now
I think uh Yan is still thinking uh I
think the current position
is uh Rook a rook A2 King E3 and he is
wondering if maybe there's a better
Square on the a file which gives him
something something to just wait like
for instance just to move the you can't
really move so H6 H I'm just thinking H6
if the Rooks come off it's just
completely equal you without the and in
particular without the backward Pawn on
B2 you your plan of aband abandoning E5
and charging towards B2 there's there's
nothing to charge towards anymore so TI
yeah it's not there yeah in this
position nobody really is going anywhere
the the pieces will be tied to the
protection of the E4 and the Five Points
it's just completely completely equal so
Jan is doing sort of due diligence here
checking if maybe Rook A1 does something
but I think it's extremely unlikely that
it does
exactly but there is plenty of play
elsewhere uh Queen E5 is a very nice
variation there shown by Gary Queen E5
with this uh trick of Knight H4 Knight
F5 but Knight E5 is also extremely
logical as I said black will need to
control the C6 this is a very kind of
Catalan idea of just pushing for this
dream of Landing our night on C6
eventually or even C4 considering the
fact that the pawns are not on B6 and B7
and A7 they are on these squares if this
KN goes to C4 there's a lot of pressure
against the black structure and uh it's
it's actually quite if we ask the the I
would this is somewhere where I feel
very confident saying that I would
assess this position even without the
agent sort of correctly but it feels
that you have to play very very
precisely here not to be in trouble
after Queen B7 check which is probably
the most natural move in the position
there's even a comfortable choice
between King G1 and queen F3 Queen F3
would be ol Anderson's choice and uh he
he tortured many a grandm on the white
side of these this this really is quite
quite unpleasant let's say you go Knight
D5 we go Rook a C1 we follow it up with
Knight C4 eventually to E4 will start
becoming a threat and of course if you
uh if you take on F3 first yes this is a
very very big Target and Rook a C1
Knight C4 Knight C6 Bishop G4 will
become an issue you pretty much never
want to play A5 A4 because your knight
gets kicked away this is already
potentially winning a game winning
Advantage uh so Leon is enjoying himself
here clearly in our Italian game between
rard rort and Anish giri after the trade
on B6 Bishop E3 was replied to with B5
uh reard played rookie E1 which is a bit
of a kind of a slow move sof and Bishop
f8 is a very logical uh reply by Anish
and now he plays the move that I was
advocating for this move Knight
E4 as mentioned black is pretty much
never taking here you don't actually
have to react to this uh you might think
Knight C5 is a threat but I suspect that
trade is not in White's favor at all
right so to a degree I would maybe even
be welcoming it I can see on my screen
that the top move currently not by much
but the top move currently is Knight D7
but I think that's more to do with the
fact that you just want to uh you know
play something because black doesn't
have very many options but Queen C7 Que
Queen yeah Queen C7 Queen C8 but the
point I was kind of awkwardly trying to
make is that if you do play if you pass
if you if you completely pass I'm pretty
sure Knight C5 is just not a good move
because in this position suddenly this
Knight can come to D5 it can start
aiming at the F4 Square The Rook might
suddenly become an attacking piece so I
I would not be playing Knight C5 anyway
uh whatever whatever black chooses to do
here seems like a reasonably balanced
position but there's plenty of play Left
of course lots of pieces left on the
board very good I wanted to jump in uh
get your opinion if you don't mind on
the game between lir and Wesley actually
nothing's happened we left it am I wrong
it was a rookie one the rookies on A3
it's coming to F3 this is like the mini
plan in action the mini plan in action
it has you're right it there there is a
a rook lift and I guess Wesley has gone
into a deep tank okay if I consider the
move Rook F3 a threat then I have to say
to myself well how do I stop the threat
should I playing what I really really
want to play is The Rook on A1 is not
working I need to bring it into the game
so I would want to play be playing moves
like F4 first
yes and then there no subtlety with my
PL and then then Rook F1 and then charge
and hack hack attack if we will uh I was
looking I thought you're I thought
Lanier's idea might have been to play a
rook F3 check so where I would be
looking at as black is just to take away
that possibility now
here there's some little risks some risk
I'm taking by uh creating a weakness on
the C
file I don't really feel it though I I I
do see the move Rook D5 now shall we
take a look at your F4 okay let's let's
try let's try it although i' I've lost
my enthusiasm for it once you've
activated the bishop
because yeah because of that move Rook
D2 and it's sort of like you
know I'm kind of like it's an awward
question I was very specific to Bishop
being TR exactly exactly um again we
we're learning that Bishop endings
uh opposite color Bishops are are are
too balanced uh is this one those cases
Peter well you can go Rook C1 right Rook
C1 yeah yeah uh interestingly uh C5 is
currently machin's best choice because
it feels that if you don't do it
immediately you might actually start
running into some trouble on the king
side see see Rook Che is is
a and after after King G6 there's also
this very annoying idea of Rook G3
followed by F4 and you are considering
how poorly place the black pieces are
you can actually safely place it on G4
because the bishop cannot attack it
quickly enough to stop F4 from happening
and this is starting to enter territory
where you will be worried so C5 is the
suggestion but interestingly after you
takes C5 uh the engine says I'm sort of
better off not even creating those
weaknesses and accepting I will be a
pawn down and playing some position like
CB ab and now I want to play Rook G7 and
start trading everything down down the E
file and that seems manageable but that
already I think is an indication that
something has gone somewhat wrong
because if we go back if we go back back
here and we look at this position after
C3 uh Bishop takes EF King F7 C takes D4
I was sort of fully expecting uh Wesley
to no not not not not a draw as such but
that Wesley will not have any issues at
all equalizing uh but he probably missed
missed the boat somewhere because uh it
seems that the engine uh somewhere on
this position it plays much more
actively for the C c65 break for
instance it starts with Rook E8
immediately creating the idea of C6 C5
if you play Rook E1 as you've done in
the game I have the move Rook D5 once
again reestablishing the idea of 6 C5
prior to you being able to play F4 and
this seems completely fine for for for
black because there's really no good way
of stopping C5 from happening and Wesley
burned only one tempo on a move that
seems very logical improving a position
here a little bit you know connecting
you know getting your Pawn slightly
slightly more together but now justed
now you're not in time with your counter
playay and the bishop remains rooted to
the pawn on D4 for long enough for
Wesley now to have to play C5 and C5 dc5
is now on the board right in a in a way
that definitely gives white chances I
suspect draw is still massively favored
right but this is definitely no longer a
for gun conclusion can we play Rook D5
by the
way for for a second there I thought I
found a very good good version of this
but very importantly there's Rook F3
check my plan was to meet this with Rook
G2 and claim that I am immedi
immediately completely fine you can also
play Rook C1 in this one I want to no or
even or even Rook C5 Rook C2 frankly but
I liked immediately attacking stuff
right uh and uh if you go Rook A1 of
course I will take on C5 and I will be
instantly completely fine there's no
longer check is very serious but rook3
check is uh is a very very serious
possibility you have to go to G8 because
otherwise Rook F6 will also come in and
now the machine goes Bishop C3 and if
you take with the Rook it goes Rook F6
and this is what you want to avoid right
because your king is so unsafe here
compared to the very very snug King on
uh on G1 that you will have significant
problems equalizing this perhaps you
just don't equalize anymore yeah we have
a move he play C5 and he play King G6
interesting
somewhat similar if you're going to go
Rook C1 I may play Rook E6 and I just
stopping C6 and uh basically I'm playing
a pawn down but very much uh Wesley just
wants to trade the Rooks on the E file
and uh well your extra Pawn is Pawn on
F2 but is it so easy I
mean is coming not anymore Rook Shan is
a very decent move the Mach also goes
Rook A1 with the intention once again uh
Yan's favorite Bishop
which is very very strong here by the
way covering many many important things
uh so no this is now this will be a lot
of suffering it feels for Wesley because
I think ler is also exactly the person
to give this as suffering yeah out of
this field I think uh ler is one of the
least least Pleasant opponents in this
particular scenario I think the least
favorite favorite opponent if I had to
pick somebody I would absolutely not
want to play this with black against
that that would actually be Wesley
Wesley but he's playing
blacking so that's not available but uh
outside of Wesley specifically I think
ler is very near the top of the list so
our tournament leader suffering at the
moment upon pwn down and the Bishops of
opposite uh color U ending late middle
Game King G6 on the board and you were
about to say whoop I just went whoop
because I I went unturn my attention to
the game between Max V
Andi and I'm thinking
whoa whoa whoa somebody left a peski
hanging uh let's see we left it at King
D2 there was a an expectation of a
repetition with r continue either
checking or attacking the PA King E6 uh
Yan saying I'm sorry I would like to
continue the game and what is his idea
B4 and Rook D3 check King C5 B4 I think
sadly sadly for Yan I mean he's still
not risking anything whatsoever the same
repetition is very much still on Tap
White has no no way to avoid repeating
the moves if you go Rook A2 Rook A3
forever but I I don't see how you make
improvements I think uh like once again
an ideal scenario here if we want to
paint a picture we go King C5 why does
something completely irrelevant we go
before C4 King this is the picture yeah
this is the picture and we claim this is
made
but the yeah but the thing is as I now
realize this is the perfect defense
against Rook Bishop the second rank
defense we have the setup yes we have no
no no no no but wait one second we have
the technology hang on a second hang on
a second that defense is very much based
on a
stalemate and you ain't going to get
stalemate hit well that's cuz I got a
but I have more more people coming in
you know we have friends coming in to to
help out and the the def we're talking
about here is uh we we keep we keep our
pieces in this shape and it seems like
we're being driven to the back Rank and
then getting made to with something like
King E3 but in fact we're iMed we're
immediately attacking The Rook on A2 of
course black having sacrificed two pawns
cannot afford to trade Rooks so check
and we go back and once again the black
king cannot enter right and Knight F3 is
coming very quickly so seems like it's
time to take a Perpetual once again so I
think yanis sort of has to be applauded
for TR trying to you know scare mvl into
some indiscretions but this setup is so
sturdy that uh eventually he will just
no to himself and just go Rook a 2 Rook
a three and right and the point is that
MV himself cannot become too ambitious
after the move Knight takes
H7 Rook A2 check King
E3 A3 you can't be ambitious with white
by playing Rook C2 on Pawn up well
King D2
B3 this is
the no this is a very very dangerous
Pawn this uh passer on B3 so there's no
way mvl is going to uh push his luck in
Rook a check is on the board so perhaps
we could switch to that camera because I
think that that might to see a repe yeah
that might be an indication that the
game is coming to a
close and yep King D2 played without
hesitation what can I tell you guys my
my pick was a pawn up and he couldn't
win you were very fortunate with your
pick that P behind and yeah yan yan
saved this game by the skin of his yeah
absolutely by the skin of his teeth here
exactly only repeats once for now I
guess he well he's got 52 minutes he's
built up quite a margin and the blues I
don't think are playing today so there's
there's nowhere he needs to be exactly
although I mean this is college football
game in America I mean not necessarily
ice hockey no ice hockey is very big in
Russia but uh yeah this position looks
like it's heading for a draw I guess
we'll just keep uh a close watch on that
one because that will be our first
result of the day uh going to the game
of Richie raor and Anish Gary because it
just seems
sorry Richie is making some backwards
looking are we losing this game as well
that would be very un no I think we just
with the move KN F6 we've seen a draw
offer actually it is yeah and they've
already done this twice if he goes
Bishop B3 that will be a third uh Anish
can
claim and there really isn't a better
move than Bishop B3 in this position
sadly we might be losing we might be
losing another board yes and again uh
we're keeping a very careful eye on
Anish
Geri Wesley so and Ali Raza because
those three players are in a hotly
contested fight for the top rating spot
and let's just jump to the game of
leavon and Ali Risa for a moment because
we did have pretty much the queen B7
check Queen F3 variation you were
mentioning Peter but not yeah after
Queen F3 Al resum made a kind of a
optically uh aggressive move Knight of 6
C4 but I like I like the response of
Bishop D4 and now there are very serious
issues for black because I think there's
a it might sound strange but there is a
very strong positional threat of just
taking on C5 and taking on H6 show us
yeah let's say H6 we just I think we can
go in already okay Knight C5 Queen B7
Knight B7 and this is just a Catan end
game which I think is universally first
of all we're losing a pawn by force oop
but even if we weren't even if let's say
I make a slightly softer move here like
c one not bad people have won so many of
these and and wolf wolf Anderson
specifically the name that yasa has
already mentioned during this broadcast
he's won so many of these uh this is
just very very dangerous for black
because the weaknesses are uh very
vulnerable and you're losing control of
so many squares and the same applies
just just for relevance the same applies
even to this position and this is
obviously a much stronger move than H6
and still you can go Knight D7 here
provoke B5 go Rook A1 yeah if Rook C8 we
will uh Knight E5 immediately on 96 95
is the strongest here according to the
engine and you start losing control of
your queen side the Rooks the Rooks
start actually uh in penetrating into
the black position and this is very
often just completely UNH holdable by
the way sorry it interrupt it is a
repetition of moves in the NPI Max game
ah little Shak because he played King C5
there so I thought maybe he wasn't
repeating but he is repeating again I
think we might have a they're racing
they're racing to be the first game to
finish I think the the Rapport giri game
in this one it's close it is very close
it's going to be a photo
finish all right but uh specifically
what you're saying about the leavon
aronian game uh if you're telling me
this ending is you know all play on one
goal after Bishop D4 what on Earth is
Ali Raza going to do to
prevent uh what looks to be a disastrous
ending I'm not sure I think very very
disappointingly for for Al Resa and his
many many fans Rook fd8 is maybe the
best option here and it really isn't
very attractive at all I mean could you
be looking at doing after Rook to F to
d8 Bishop takes Knight rather than
stepping back with the night upon which
you said yeah I'm thinking you you
capture with the bee porn and at least
you have ideas of A5 A4 in the position
you know once
you've the small problem is this there's
this pin on this this often returns to
D3 this Rook lifts to C4 this is also
going to be I understand that but is
there any better than losing an ending
that's I mean I I mean I was just
looking at way to generate activity and
F5 on the board wow which uh might just
be might just be losing though because
after Bishop takes C5 you now absolutely
have to take with the pawn Knight C5
just straight up loses the pawn on B6
just as we were showing takes takes
takes takes on 97 and this is just over
it's only one Pawn but also white is
better everywhere it's not it's not
just
yeah and uh sorry to interrupt you but
there we do see the game finish in a
draw between Maxi Vash gra and yanomi so
both players now move on to the free day
yeah
uh so you you have to take the B Pawn
and then the r comes in and and this is
now absolutely terrifying you have to
probably play something like Queen B8 to
at least try and kick away the knight
from E5 it goes It goes to C4 and
then like if if white establishes The
Rook on if the Rook on D7 is not
immediately chased away you will
probably having played F7 F5 as well
you'll just get M on the king side
and I I don't know it looks hor looks
horrible like Rook A7 for instance uh we
can take and then play Queen E3 and the
threat of F2 F3 you've created so many
weaknesses in your position that
honestly this feels like white will have
a choice of which one to win exactly A5
is hanging in every single variation E6
is now a very very big uh weakness as
well C5 is constantly weak uh it's an
equal material position in which the
engine currently says plus 2.5 uh Rook
A7 is a mistake but comp like best move
is A4 but then we will double on the G
file and eventually I will start playing
Queen E3 and F3 and even though we've
you know traded off one weakness the
difference in King safety the difference
in peace activity the difference in just
about everything else makes this I would
assume an indefensible position against
good play ASA well as my trainer Nikolai
manev would say complete catr yeah I
mean love the queen E3 and the race was
closed
not too far behind was also a draw
between Richard RoR and Anish but this
is a disaster F5 Bishop T uh pardon me
Peter just to really put the mood in
Bishop takes C5 B takes E5 Rook to D7 as
we see the two players there uh kings
are in the center yes I just wanted to
yeah to sure the diagram is on the
screen yeah exactly and Rook B7 Queen C8
or what did you play play Queen B8 I
yeah that's that's fine Queen Knight C6
also pretty good but Queen E8 Rook D1 oh
que there Queen B5 and you forced to put
the Knight on that not the intention and
that's really not what you wanted I
think C is just such a beautiful Square
yeah that's not the harmony wanted I
mean Leon understandably is now pausing
because the position now looks so
beautiful that he's probably asking
himself to have better he will be aware
of Bishop C5 Rook D7 it's not really a
difficult idea to find but he's asking
himself
will black have an like a good thing to
do in response to Rook ac1 maybe I can
improve it but the thing is in the lines
we were discussing it really isn't going
to C1 anyway it goes to D1 so there's no
particular reason I don't think to give
black a temple to play something even
though I don't know what that something
is this is still very very good for
white and in terms of something that we
were discussing before we had all these
breaking news uh the rating spot yes are
reses ahead yes
notore but he is struggling but the
person person chasing him the closest is
also not having a particular good day
which means a Le the two remaining games
are uh both of our rating spot leaders
are in struggling with black pieces so
we we could have a really strange
situation where both of them actually
lose rating points and it becomes the
distance between them stays the same but
they both get a lot closer to an is so
it it it very much becomes a three horse
race in that case and if ler wins we
keep on not mentioning ler in that
context but if we imagine ler winning
this game and also L winning this game
lener gets very close to this group how
close is L he was around 46.5 I was told
46.5 so he'll be okay he needs to get to
the mid-50s though yeah but he'll be on
he'll be on 51 ala will be on 56 and
Wesley will drop back to 51 as well so
it will be alira and then L and Wesley
died or almost died on on third the plot
seconds and in the meanwhile let's just
take a look at the results thus far we
have had two games finished it was a
draw between Richard report Anish giri
and Maxim bashov against Yan nomachi and
just to remind everyone that because Yan
Kristof Duda well withdrew from the
event in round two Fabiana Carana does
get a buy but still
very much everything to play for in the
games between Dominguez and so and an
exercise and suffering I would say for
Ali Roa fua in his game against Leon
aronian exactly well uh again just
looking at the positions that we saw
with Ali razes uh F7 F5 uh trying to
understand what um precipitated that
decision it was just that he felt that
these endings must have been absolutely
Dreadful that must have that's the only
thing I can IM well sometimes you know
you consider all the Alternatives you
think you think and you just can't see
anything satisfactory and then you lash
out and play a random move and perhaps
this is F5 because it does seem very
weakening and indeed Leon does have a
forcing line at his disposal Bishop
takes Knight Bishop takes C5 again we're
talking about these endings and in this
particular case is simply a fork uh cost
you a pawn it's not just that you lose a
pawn it's that you get no compensation
for it and this loss of this Pawn on B6
gives white an extra Pawn as well as the
attack compensation so we been looking
at bakes Rook to D7 thank you for the
support of the Knight Rook to D7 Queen
B8 attacking the Knight I guess the one
trap in the position you don't want to
fall for is white defend the Knight and
allow G5 that not good but you play
Knight to C4 and this position is just
so bad on so many levels you've got
weaknesses Galore and whites play is so
simple Rook to D1 and just start
exploiting the weaknesses Queen E3 F3 I
was also going to ask the question I
mean how critical is Queen E3 and F3 to
wh's attack it's I think there's just
too many good ways of playing the
position in fact I think Queen E3 and F3
is probably uh the best way of playing
the position but if you want if you
wanted me to play Queen F4 and try to
trade Queens I wouldn't be averse to
that one either so so long as I keep a r
on I'm just trying to think of what Ali
RZA could have missed that's what I'm
trying to understand it came earlier it
came earlier this is terrible my guess
is A5 is is not a blunder such it's just
a decision of somebody who is
desperately unhappy with his position
and sort of flailing for something to
disbalance it for something to kind of
make Lev deviate from a very kind of a
straightforward conversion uh the
position
wasn't yet I think n N4 is really where
it started going wrong I think the
engine says after 95 yes it's still very
unpleasant but it's manageable to a
degree and N4 was a kind of a lure it it
looks optically like a more active move
it looks also like a good idea to
connect your Knights so that against
Bishop D4 you have things protected but
in fact the point that now you are
constantly having to calculate these end
games where Bishop C5 followed by Queen
B7 misplaces your very active Knight on
the4 completely on the B7 square that
well left didn't didn't do any of the
two things we were expecting he just
played Knight C4 here which is still
giving him a reasonably big Advantage
but
that's a shocking that's a yeah a not
Choice stunning as we mle it over yeah
definitely um let's go over to Anastasia
who's right by the playing Hall and
there with a special
guest yes I have Maxim with me welcome
Maxim you just finished your game in the
draw these days it's so difficult to win
a game to lose a game like how can you
explain what's happening five draws
right so far I mean yesterday I missed
an opportunity but basically an
opportunity that I didn't expect um okay
so Anish plays this powerful preparation
then I understand that he missed a first
move Knight F5 but later on he was
avoiding
draws and uh you know getting things
very crazy and I basically what he told
me after the game is that he missed one
move after another yeah show a little
bit this no it just at the critical
moment I mean it went in a second
because um I mean I still didn't expect
to have such such an attack so I thought
uh if he takes on A6 I take on B2 and
anyway Bishop D5 is my next move I
didn't see all this was F5 um yeah but
actually speaking about this game I
should have posed
but but before that it was very good
game that's why for me at least how
difficult it was to play this game for
you I mean you had to find so many
defensive moves like this Knight F5 the
only move in the position the thing is
uh here I was posing because Rook C8 is
the obvious move but I was very scared
of Rook C5 and at the end I thought okay
let's let him uh is a finder remembers
move Rook C5 and play Rook C8 and well
unfortunately he played the4 because he
s that it was part of his preparation
that's that's what happen because he had
F4 somewhere and he s here it's good he
brend Knight F5 uh and for today it's a
bit uh shameful but why no but basically
it comes down first of all I mean the
consquences of moves were this position
so of course I mean move order Yan just
wanted me to to think a bit more than I
should which he managed but so with a
bishop on A7 instead of B6
I was thinking for so much time uh try
to figure out the difference between the
bishop on B6 first of all after Bishop
E3 which I wanted I was not sure about
Bishop G4 already Knight D2 and Castle
but of course probably this is just
good um for me so probably it's what I
should have gone with and
also actually what I spent a lot of time
was Knight D2 King E7 Knight F3 Bishop
B7 and here some after Knight E5 Knight
E4 I was not even sure that I'm not
getting worse because I cannot take this
Pawn this is what I was and King E8 and
yeah I mean maybe it's still within
drawing margin but here maybe I should
have posed I I thought about Bishop C2
but I just assumed it's nothing which is
probably true but I thought it might be
um a bit of a difference compared to the
bishop on B6 and that's why I settled
for D C5 but in the end I was just
scared of this position for like somehow
you get scared for for no reason yeah
and yeah I just thought I was foring a
draw uh and you know come another day of
course yeah I should have gone A4 right
away um what do you think about the
sending there was a big discussion rook
and Bishop or night and oh sorry rook
and Bishop or night and Bishop what I
mean rook and Bishop of course is better
in general I mean uh here I was getting
a bit scared about G6 I thought G6 was
the the way to to try to keep the game
going and Rook A1 mhm um but of course
it shouldn't be anything but some ideas
with Rook C1 with Rook D1 mhm um yeah I
wanted I wanted Knight G5 actually and
King E7 this is where I wasn't sure
maybe I yeah I want to take actually and
probably this is all thing I mean it
takes a lot to lose this game with white
so I I I didn't manage but um but you
felt that it's I mean if I get something
it's easier to play Bishop E3 because A4
I didn't feel like I mean first of all
there's B4 but I thought even Castle now
with a rook still on A8 so I mean just a
Miss on my part like I mean probably I
checked this bishop A7 long time ago but
uh it was just uh Bishop B6 is such a
the automatic move so yeah Gary kaspar
was today in the studio I mean through
Zoom call and he said that this was
interesting consequences of moves which
NE nepo choose today so he was maybe
also puzzled with the difference where
Bishop so maybe bishop is move n maybe
maybe Knight D2 maybe because this is
what I spend the most time on so this
position maybe here there's uh no need
to panic uh like I did because of course
Bishop on i7 is very active but my king
is safer so I shouldn't be
worse um so yeah I mean this might have
been the way to to try to to keep
playing a bit but uh yeah and of course
I mean the thing is you bring nepo who
is obviously in his prep so you don't
know how far so what's going on so after
all I just decided to play it safe and
well made it a bit tricky for myself but
draw is okay okay so you finished the
day in the office today what is the plan
for tomorrow you have a rest day
finally yeah no it's good uh I'll be
looking to prepare a bit for my for my
last three games so you know um Al then
I will get immediately a second fre day
after my game with
Richard uh so I'll have some time to
prepare I'll have some time to rest of
course and uh maybe to enjoy some tennis
uh you know in for spark ah you will
play you mean I will try to find people
to do to do so I'm I'm not sure like I
think fa was also before the tournament
I was not very successful but uh in
finding Partners but maybe maybe this
time around it will work out okay good
luck with that Maxum as well with with
your games thank you and and we go back
to the studio thank you Anastasia mvl
some advice Ray Ray Robson is ready
willing and able he's a very good tennis
partner so uh check in with Ray Ray uh
I'm I'm listening to uh mvl there Peter
and it just seemed like he had an
fantastic awareness of the position just
knew everything it's it almost felt like
it's impossible to beat these guys they
just know everything we were listening
to different interviews on
really I thought he he knew the endings
very well honestly the ending yes but
the the thing the things he was
describing as the things he spent the
most time in the opening I was just
sitting there kind of perplex very
perplexed because he knows this line he
is very good at this line I played him
with black in this line and for him once
again the game has disappeared we can we
can by through the magic of Television
we can make the game
reappear by by by naming it Thrice by
calling for it thce uh the the fact that
he somehow thought that he needs to
start here and look for an advantage
from this position is just buffing to me
he knows it so
because yes I understand there's we
were explaining to our viewers that this
is a whole new position the bishop
should be on B6 and any top player will
be trying to work out what the
difference are how how to exploit it but
that his starting point seemed to be
this position and then the choice
between Bishop F7 which we all know is a
draw and he knows is a draw in it and
this choice of Knight G2 and then King
E7 Knight F3 which yes Bishop B7 is
playable also this is apparently
completely fine but just the whole point
of somebody who is extremely well
prepared who is very very ambitious one
of the strongest Spanish players from
the white side that I know right from
personal
experience just meeting a new idea and
then saying what I will do here is I
will is I will basically create a
symmetrical structure in the center and
trade quein and that is a starting point
for my calculations I honestly I I was
in slight disbelief there because it's
not the mvl that I know I was I was very
very puzzled by that yes I understand
that he doesn't exactly know what the
difference is and he might feel that you
know World Championship prep here from
from nepo might be something that he he
will struggle to deal with but still I'm
I'm very unused to mvl not not
trying all right thank you thank you
Peter for your thoughts and we're going
to go straight back to Anastasia who is
with Richard who is ready to share his
thoughts on his draw against Anish
Gary hello Richard Welcome to our studio
it's the first time that you're here
with us U first of all how do you feel I
mean I know that you played in buan that
you had to travel to come here how is
your jet like how are you um I don't
know I wish I could uh you know claim
jet legac an excuse for my poor play so
I'm obviously as as well as I I could be
considering the results but other than
that I'm doing very well of course the
playing call is very nice St Louis is
same as usual so everything is fine yes
so um I know I mean okay you you lost
this game against Wesley and but I think
you really tried to fight on on this
game and you decided to choose Kings um
Indian like um can you give some thought
about it like what did what went wrong
if you can I don't know I guess um I
mean it's not in this month I mean I
lost quite a few games so I guess uh you
know when you're when things are going
um f yeah you should probably try to you
know uh be cautious and not push too
much especially I mean against who is
super solid player so I kind of got
punished for that um yeah what to do I
mean but today was a different game and
you played against Anish uh do you think
you got Pleasant position out of the
openings you know always It's Tricky
with all the small moves like H6 A6 and
the and the consequences like can can
you tell us a little bit about this
opening battle yeah I don't U really
know much I mean about this it's to me
all these Italians are looking the same
thank you I don't know this is I feel
sometimes the same and I'm like now we
play six or later like what's What's
Happening Here there yeah it's very hard
to to say anything so symmetrical
position yeah and then yeah he decided
to go for this A6 plan and7 I'm not so
sure if I reacted so principled I mean I
think it was a normal game more or less
I felt like okay maybe here I could have
played before before and I didn't like
Bishop f8 which might not be such a such
an achievement for him after all and
after this next critical moment was okay
I think moves were normal more or less
until here and then I played here A5
which is um not probably one of my best
moves I wanted to play Queen B3 which I
ended up doing during the game but um I
thought that in this position or in
similar position after
B6 I can go for okay it takes is it
typical this B6 because I was a bit
surprised when I saw it on the board I
no I mean it's matter of taste I guess
no because black has this option to keep
the pawn on B7 where it's kind of a
small weakness or play B6 try to play
okay he he's going to play B5
basically play B5 and then try to have
this weird structure which is kind of
like no one is really moving and I think
this was critical moment like maybe I
could have played here D4 I was
calculating but E4 seemed like D5 mhm
takes
takes couldn't make this line work for
right I mean obviously I'm not worth but
I couldn't make it work for for the
advantage so yeah um you decided just to
I decided to to play bop3 and then after
this I mean um okay the position is
about equal I guess um yeah repetition
is kind of I mean strange a little bit
because but I don't think black is I
mean okay white I feel like it's kind of
normal but also for black I have this C4
counterplay every time the only question
was what he could go with before before
and before before here mhm in this
position but U like strategically
speaking but I feel like it's kind of
risky for him because I play C4 maybe
and I could end up with having just very
nice light squares so it's very kind of
normal I mean outcome I think the
critical moments were like kind of early
on in the game and I probably didn't um
yeah sees the moment so to speak so kind
of slipped yeah yeah I wonder how how
much time it takes to understand all
this consequences of this position I
mean how how many hours did you spend
understanding Italian and all the
structures in your life can see on this
game I don't really understand Italian
come
on you always say so ask my opponent
yeah like who knows all all the moves
okay next time we will ask also Anish
what he thinks about it and um thank you
so much Richard and all the best for you
tomorrow it's a rest day so recharge
your batteries come back and show your
always creative you know Spirit yeah
thanks thank you and we back thank you
Richard and thank you Anastasia and the
Richard at the end with a r smile and
we're coming close to our second break
of the day so let's take a look at the
round Five results so far two draws
between Richard report and Anish giri
Maxim V gra also finished in a draw
against Yan nomachi and we would like to
encourage the people in Central West End
to take a look at your jingle bar yes go
to the World Chess Hall of fame. org and
uh check out the uh jingle bar uh for uh
your holiday hot
chocolates right now though it is
running right now for some reason I
thought it was going after the event I'm
mistaken November 17th through December
30th check it out it's uh with your
friends it's sure to be a lot of fun and
uh we're going to take we're going to go
on our second break but in the meantime
we do have a feature lined up for you on
the community outreach program on CH in
St Louis so please enjoy that don't go
[Music]
anywhere
uh so today's Community Day all the
parti of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chest
whether that be critical thinking
decision-making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I played with my
auntie myom my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they be begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make bad decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytic Ally and moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
in check whether it's going to put put
your anything in danger whether it's
just a move that you make everything
counts in the long run I like um how it
makes me use my critical thinking makes
me look at the whole board I think it's
teaching them to be persistent you know
we have a lot of students who it takes
them like it may take a few weeks or
even months in chess club to master a
particular strategy or skill um and what
I think that teaches kids is even if
they don't get it the first time around
or even if it's difficult the first time
around um it's worth sticking to it well
one thing's for certain without the St
Louis chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
espe especially those in areas that are
not core content area and because of the
St Louis chess club collaboration we
have people who come in here working
with students who want to work with them
today with the experience of the grandm
community outreach day I came up and I'm
like well what's a grandm and they're
like oh you don't know what a grandmas
is and they were able to explain that
and they recognize the importance and
the seriousness I mean it's a sport it's
a profession and so they're able to see
things outside of the sports that we
typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know helping
my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's Grand Master
joha I will be creating content for GR
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the s's
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that S luia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it's sense a
hope that the the game of chess will
always stay AF flat by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org SL
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest tour follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chest Club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US champ
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
past sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure sure to
check out houti stl.com for a wide
variety of gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy welcome back to round five of the
sink Phi cup and as we actually inch
very close to the halfway mark well two
games have already finished it was it's
been a peaceful start to round five with
Richard report and Anish giri agreeing a
draw and also Maxim bash graph and Yan P
actually racing to an end game which
soon ended in a draw but two games still
remaining and well
both very good chances for the white
pieces yeah but the one that's really
confounding us Peter I mean it's just
terribly is the leavon uh versus because
Ali Ray a really bad L bungled it and
how um leavon didn't Embrace Bishop
takes C5 yeah is a question for the ages
I I spent the the vast majority of the
previous break ransing about how I don't
understand chess anymore because these
are players who do understand very very
good at chess and doing things I cannot
really explain starting with the move
Knight C4 it's a logical move the KN
sort of belongs there but considering
that the other option was planting a
rook on D7 while also creating a bunch
of weaknesses for black seems like
Bishop C5 was the more logical Choice
ala actually spent a couple of moves
making the absolutely best moves in the
position A4 was important to include to
move the uh weaknesses away from the
dark Square so that they are less
attacked by the uh White pieces and then
in this position uh ideas of B6 B5 often
are so useful for black that uh the
engine very often was actually spending
a Tempo on playing B4 B5 itself just to
make sure that we fix the weakness on B6
and also secure the position of kn C4 or
r a C1 which is also logical instead of
all that Leon played King G2 G1 which is
understandable because you do want to
play Queen E3 and F3 we discussed it
before the break and you cannot do that
while there are still discovered checks
available using the long diagonal right
but it's not very concrete specifically
here and Rook A8 I think a move Ali Resa
would have made in a Blitz
game gaining time on the clock right uh
with the idea of meing r C1 with B5
Knight A5 Rook takes C1 important
intermediate move forcing Rook takes C1
and then putting the queen on D5 what's
the problem you look at this position
and you think how did we get from there
to here this is just such an obvious
Improvement for black the pawns are now
in light Square so they're much less of
a target for White's pieces there's a
beautiful queen in the center of the
board the Knight on e4 is still not
chased away might never get chased away
there's no white Rook on the seven a A2
is hanging so actually now has to start
thinking about maybe defending things
which really wasn't a topic at all
instead of that quite quickly alza goes
Knight df6 allowing uh Bishop takes F6
uh other other moves were also very
strong but Bishop 6 is a very good
practical decision just Bishop F6 maybe
this capture was what eluded Ali Resa
because you know he's thinking Knight
df6 if the queen goes to E3 Knight G4
absolutely but also even something like
this which I assume was his intention
like you continue the variation for one
more move then you go Rook A1 this is
also very very
bad it's not like other options were not
giving white a massive advantage and
once again you can sort of I can you can
sell me on Knight gf6 being a move that
occurs to you but considering Rook A8
and B5 exists in the position how do you
end up playing KN D6 I I don't know
they're so forcing moves and by way add
to Fu's Wes right right the look at the
clock
situation 2 minutes and the players are
currently on move 26 so Queen E3 as
versus 25 for Leon and move 25 so as
Leon tees up for F3 but Rook C8 came
very quick C8 played and white AES white
is better if he does something like Rook
A1 but there's absolutely no reason not
to take on B6 here is that a peski I've
never heard of that expression in my
life but I like it I have to welcome him
the studio he's got to feel comfy my my
feeling is ala is pinning his hopes on
taking and playing Rook C2 but now after
Rook A1 I I had the feeling that this is
just made right if if if you take on E2
you run into Knight
D7 and you have to just leave it on F6
because is putting it putting it on any
any other square like here Knight E5 is
already basically basically made because
if Rook F6 back we can go Rook C8 rook
f8 and then en force it a little bit
with the other one to d8 and game
finishes yeah and if you have to trade
on C1 it's yeah you're going to Prett
much pretty much resigning yeah so if
he's intending to do that the game
probably ends more or less on the spot I
was wondering like if you play something
like H5 how bad is it but it is pretty
bad because the B Pawn will start
running we don't really even care about
the a a pawn very much because this one
just gets to be Seven Inc defend the F2
Pawn as well which could be another
source of counter yeah gf6 first of all
Rook C7 Rook C7 is probably made so you
can't you can't even do that so yeah no
running and hiding here so so we're once
again entering a situation where it
would appear that Lon is one precise
calculation away from what will be an
absolutely overwhelming Advantage I
can't imagine that alir is intending to
play something like Queen E7 which is
the best move in the position but you
know you're you aspire to this you know
you're losing this one exactly uh by the
way does Knight take B6 have a clear-cut
reputation I didn't see it C oh apparent
F4 with some Rook G6 threats and if
Queen D4 you get hit by you get hit by
Knight C3 turn around there and now that
I've taken the D5 Square under the
control creating this Fork threat after
Rook G2 I will play6 C5 and pick up this
Knight now that you no longer
have intermediate checks that that's a
funny move that move F4 because I was
really not looking in that
C1 and now after B6 B5 there are drawing
chances again I give up no don't give up
piz not quite not yet it's toward humans
playing yes right but I've played those
humans and they're really really good me
me they would be 10 10 10 out of 10 life
isn't it you know against you they play
like a god like a beast yeah Queen takes
B6 and Away you go
nervousness uh as well as I don't know
sometimes you're sitting at the board in
the
tensions you know you start seeing
ghosts what queen takes B6 is not a
difficult move for anybody in this this
entire line we've showed with 97 there
in the end in the end game I would back
Leon to find in a Blitz game of course
and maybe even a two-minute Blitz game
and he has he has 25 minutes and plenty
of time to think so it's it's all very
mystifying uh we're fogging uh a horse
here but what's happening in the laner
game because again as we've been talking
about uh the race to be
number one one by ELO uh to be invited
to the candidates by having the highest
rating it comes down to Wesley Anish Ali
Raza and laner trying to bring himself
into the mix we were when we left it we
looked at G4 and we were saying King H2
King G3 and the chances of wedding are
pretty
handsome it's I don't I don't think it's
trending upwards here for for West it's
still I I think manageable but yeah the
move G5 G4 very specifically creates
this very very safe haven for for the
King on G3 you can include hg4 hg4 and
bring it over you can also keep the
tension there trying to provoke black
eventually to take GH3 which would be a
very uh very useful thing for us because
we'll play F3 we'll limit the bishop on
D5 there's the pawn on H4 five becomes a
legitimate weakness right and yeah
Wesley clearly isn't isn't enjoying
things here very much yeah he's down to
13 minutes it's not a big deal in a
position like this because moves are
reasonably easy to come by but still uh
this will this will take some some
holding yeah what's Wesley's um maybe I
don't want to say Fortress I mean I'm
just thinking Mak trades yeah we we want
to get some pieces of the board I'm
pretty sure so we go king of five you
probably play either the immediate
Bishop D4 or Rook C1 followed by Bishop
D4 because you will have to shift the
bishop away from the e Square so we get
somewhere here so I might as well do it
immediately and keep my Rook on let's
say the active open C5 I I would
probably also choose this one yeah and
then we want to play King G3 perhaps you
know we hope to get the king all the way
over over to H4 also activating this
Rook like if we if we once again if we
make a couple of really stupid waiting
moves take on H right C h8 now now this
is good I was wondering if you can take
on
H3 uh where after the trades and I guess
King takes H3 and then F3 is coming and
yeah that's the IDE I would try not to
do that unless absolutely forced because
I think this is a massive Improvement
and what about if Rook to G7 here no no
in the previous l in prev line yeah that
that makes sense I think after HG
you're probably going to have to play H2
I'm actually a little bit surprised by
how much it prefers to play H3 H4 here
wow this is maybe not such a bad idea
because I want once again this will now
be a completely completely safe Square
for the king and if you imagine uh black
allowing it because it's very possible
the best move here is just to give up a
second Pawn to establish this very G6
mhm Rook G6 C6 C2 is a plan or just Rook
e 7 perhaps trying to Le it on on E2
this honestly despite this now being two
pawns down looks more holdable than the
previous one we were
discussing and we we actually headed
towards that way so let's take a look at
what the players Bishop D4 on the board
by laner and again that's like a very
nice pocket uh Rook G8 that line that
you just gave us I I was surprised by
your decision to play H4 there uh so you
would you would be taking yeah I'm I'm
taking and if you take with the Pawn
King G3 I'm hoping to play Rook H1 H5
Rook H1 H4 Rook D1 D4 or something like
this no this is still this is still very
very
loable can can you play like Rook h i
mean Rook h s I'm going to work my way
around the back getting from behind Rook
to D1 to D4 Rook C8 Rook f8 check is
also interesting one thing I wanted to
in more general terms to say that uh one
thing working perhaps in Black's favor
is that we can even we can even maybe
move away some pieces away from the G4
Pawn using the fact that if you pick it
up with the King you will lose the G2
Pawn so it's a it's less of a bind it's
black isn't as obliged as it might seem
to keep all of his forces protecting the
pawn on G4 uh but it's one of those
positions which uh once again I think
I'm pretty certain are completely
defendable with best play M but only one
side has any fun right and and that
actually at some point starts impacting
quality of play for very many people
defending
completely cheerless positions is
something that they don't do well it's a
it's a it's a skill that very few of us
have exactly I I know I was always
horrible at it and me too interestingly
enough I heard that optimists are better
Defenders makes sense yes yeah seems
pessimists are ready to throw in the
towel with the slightest marshmallow
attack okay and you can see that from
Pet's reaction that we should go to the
Leon aronian ala game he he has very
very little time so it's it's probably
completely unfair to criticize him for
for the way he's playing but ala is
making uh very uncharacteristic for him
his calculations once again doing this
just seemed correct we don't really have
to worry about Rook C8 because Rook F
covers everything correctly okay Knight
C6 creat some threats let's drop the
Rook back cover the E7 Square A2 is
hanging everywhere E4 Knight still alive
we and we want to play H6 King H7
eventually uh this still looks kind of
pleasant for white but it looks like
we've weathered the storm to a large
degree right instead of which he goes
rook ff8 and now after Rook takes
C8 uh Queen takes C8 queen queen B6
things just start falling apart because
that's not feeling very it's not even
the B5 Pawn I'm I'm thre Rook G7 and
attacking the E6 Pawn Yeah and my my my
feeling is that we shouldn't be so
sharply critical because I suspect Rook
takes C8 losing to one very specific
thing Rook D and it basically loses to
it Rook D7 Queen B8 and now this very
beautiful two-step Knight C6 lure The
Rook away from the back rank Queen D4
Queen D4 and there is no defense against
rook d8 and then your queen side
probably collapses and you lose uh
but if this is the only thing that
really wins here on two minutes you
never see that mhm but the thing is
you're also in a lot of trouble after
the very simple F3 Rook D6 no this is
this is easier understandable and the
advantage is absolutely clear uh uh to
and now and now we can go back to the
real
world in which yeah F3 was played he
will play Knight F6 very quickly I don't
think with with I don't think there is
much point in including Rook takes C1 I
don't expect it to be included I think
Rook Knight F6 is more logical okay but
we'll see Knight of six go ahead put
that on the board Peter how
big I mean time Advantage is huge we
understand but in terms of engin
Advantage it actually once again starts
hinging on very concrete things because
the way the engine goes here is it it
goes into this position and then it very
very specifically plays Queen
C5
oh Queen is not possible because because
that is that is made in one so black has
to play something like H6 and then we
have actually
landed the cond the cond has landed on C
and all kinds of tactics are important
because of Knight E7 because my first
reaction was why can't I take it's
because it loses to Knight E7 check nice
and E6 is hanging and then the whole
team side will start collapsing so it
goes Rook E8 and from here you can sort
of see that like Knight D4 is very
strong Knight d8 even is very strong
once again attacking the fabled base of
the chain gets attacked here uh but
having not really gone for the throat
previously yeah yeah you feel like Leon
might not even try to calculate all this
maybe he'll go for uh in the current
position after F3 and F6 like a move
like Knight D3 looks very very logical
trying to reposition it on C5 reminding
black that there's this Pawn on E6 which
needs protection white is much better
right that's never been an issue but but
black definitely has chances of holding
this after something like Rook f8 it's a
lot more manageable for black compared
to the very very concrete line with a
very beautiful queen C5 shot but um I
feel slightly fake pointing out these
engine lines because they've been passed
by so many times in this particular game
that particular ending with F3 what you
just played Knight D3 it feels like
white is trying to win it softly not
doing anything you know uh very
complicated like the whole Rook D7
Bishop takes C5 Rook D7 which I thought
was so conrete and
clear it's a very pleasant position uh
for leavon and and I guess he's just
being tempted by too many good choices
right but you know I have noticed in
this particular round that everyone has
gone for the more sophisticated subtle
approach I mean there were many
possibilities in all the games where
someone could have played in a very
direct way but everyone said no they
haven't gone for that and leevon just
seems to be following that Trend as well
because to me putting a rook on D6 is
just irresistible I mean I I would do it
without or with little let's give myself
some credit calulation yeah uh Rook C8
we may be heading towards C has been
played but just to address the point
Yanka was making I think it's sort of
completely fair but there is a very uh
important detail here that if you make
some kind of a normal move like queen4
you are allowing Queen E7 and then this
Rook gets chased away also the pawn on
B4 might fall so this is why Queen C5 is
so important it's that if if you make a
kind of an autopilot move and those
would be like Queen D4 perhaps Queen G5
5 all of those moves are being replied
to with Queen E7 and even let's say if
uh that Queen trade costs black a full
Pawn mhm this is now suddenly a position
you can very easily not win like A3 goes
for instance Knight Knight C3 and B1
takes on A3 this is a kind of a position
where it's very often like the entire
Queen side will disappear and you will
not win four against three so playing
Rook D6 actually does involve
calculation but once again we are being
dragged away from this because ala took
con C I do think that after Rook C8 Rook
D6 Queen C5 is very much findable
especially at this Elite level I it is
but Queen C8 has been preferred and and
now a slightly different situation is uh
in front of us are we just pausing for a
moment because it just the move Knight
D7 is visual until you
see whole point there as Peter's
indicating oops Rook F7 suddenly defends
everything doesn't doesn't quite work
no yeah the way the way to go here I
think the way you control the most
squares is first Rook C1 Drive the queen
away put the Rook on C6 and then start
attacking everything so uh and that's
what what Leon has done Rook C1 yeah
that that's a this is move 30 somewhat
relevantly this is move 30 Al is on 2
minutes he's been very very good keeping
himself around 2 minutes not allowing
himself to go down to let's say below a
minute where it does start getting a bit
nerve jangling right uh but the position
isn't really improving uh the position
will I think remain very very difficult
to to hold for the rest of the game
absolutely Rook C1 and Rook C6 coming I
noticed that uh Wesley has has led his
his army into battle his last move King
F5 to E4 that's that's a kind of a a fun
move to play uh we have a rook trade
King takes E4 we're anticipating Bishop
E3 and uh Peter was making this argument
you don't necessarily have to put all
your defensive forces uh over behind
that uh G4 Pawn because when you take it
G2 is hanging now the question my
suggestion would still be to uh watch
the other one to the completion of the
first time control because this one is
very defined and will go on forever I
just wanted to ask a quick question
about this one though by the way because
it's not usual that you would see the
king entering all the way into White's
camp with the move King D3 I don't hate
it but I I don't think it does very much
though because the King on G3 will still
be very very safe it's just there I just
brought it up as a visual King to D3 is
just very very nice it make his way all
the way to like E2 yeah right why not D3
let's go and I was just wondering if you
guys would felt did that happen no we do
we do have Bishop E3 and then Wesley to
think uh going back to the game because
I agree with you that uh time control uh
how
many I think the other game is the one
to watch yeah and now Al right it's not
that many they've got to make 10 moves
and it's and ala now under the minute oh
by the way Rook C1 was met by Knight D5
interesting yeah this does force pretty
much force the Queens off the board
because you really don't want to abandon
the very very nice diagonal but after
Rook C8 Knight E3 Rook C5 in particular
is just very very strong and we once
again re-enter this territory of you
know wol ferson end games Rook B8 is
more or less obligatory now you can
spend the tempo on a very very useful
move A2 A3 so that before before is not
hanging because very importantly for
white we are controlling both the C2 and
the C4 Square meaning that the Knight
will not be able to attack the pawn on
A3 right and then we go King F2 we drive
it away we go knight6 we go Knight D4
and we start collecting yes the har so
let's watch let's watch how Lon
approaches it Leon is a very very
accomplished Catland player by the way
so for him this should be very much
second nature for me I've always admired
his technical as well as endgame skills
so we now now we will see if the clinic
is working A2 A3 I like that move I I
like that move and I was just going to
say it's very much on point on how
modern CH day Chess at the top level is
it's all about protecting your pieces
and A3 Works a treat there also you know
black could be potentially threatening
A3 themselves absolutely and then to
jump back to D5 and ask questions about
the B4 Po and I would never want to see
any of that kind of count counterplay uh
therefore A3 king of two at once I am
not adverse but A2 A3 to my mind makes
the most sense just uh fixing and what
Peter said you know eventually this
Knight is going to come to C6 and then
it's going to come to D4 and ask a very
Salient question how are you defending
Pawn B5 as well as Pawn E6 it's not
going to be an easy answer to that uh
question A2 A3 15 minutes for leavon I
can see from his clock there at the
board and only two minutes less a minute
and a half for aliisa
not not an easy defensive job for I can
imagine a niche back at his hotel
room cheering lanir on cheering leavon
on come on guys uh help me out I need uh
I need to qualify for the candidates by
rating well Anish has two paths to
qualification he's at the top of the FED
circuits board and the person who
finishes at the top there will get a
circuit spot into the candid Cates and
of course he's in contention for the
rating well that's a question I would
ask of you I mean I'm sure Fay
regulations would do that let's say I'm
Ali Ray and I finish behind an Nish in
rating and then on
N that's what I wanted to ask I'm pretty
sure Al is that was my question who does
the but to who does the spot go to is it
going to be like gash who's in the
second well who's in third place of the
circuit no would would would on each
choose I will take the rating spot or I
will take PR spot or is is the choice
made for him I think the choice has dip
or something right I
think because by that
standard um uh Fabby is the Grand Pre
winner right he's ah head of a niche and
he qualified by the World Cup
like he's in by the world cut end the
story that I'm pretty sure there's a
ranking
between and it goes from from top to bot
and I think I think if probably the
feeder circuit stands above ratings so
if you if you if you take the feeder
circuit spot you're removed from the
rating consideration and the next one in
line for that right uh gets the spot
that would be my assumption but
obviously uh chess players famously
never read any
regulations contracts what what
what are are exactly exactly so I I
wouldn't know for sure but that would be
my assumption that circuit circuit
Trump's rating so if if I which is
probably actually why both Ali Resa and
and Wesley are desperately willing him
on to a degree because if he if he takes
the circuit spot it's much easier for
them to qualify by rating exactly um and
but having said that I was very confused
by the one rating list and not some
wonderful formula based on 12 different
rating lists and what have you um Peter
leavon versus Ali Raza I mean's think
he's fighting for his life as Ali Risa
what does Ali Risa have to do after A3 I
mean he's not going to resign it's very
unclear yeah the engine the engine
launches some kind of a desperate
counter playay with this move Rook d8 I
wanted to ask should I get desperate I'm
not I'm not sure we can even like I I
don't I don't know if Rook B5 is badly
wrong but the engine also for now goes
H2 H4 further pointing out the fact that
Rook D1 is really not a threat at all in
fact here it loses on the spot because
Rook C8 threat is threatened is made is
threatened and the Knight is hanging so
it includes H4 and G6 yeah just to
improve slightly on on the king side and
then cly takes on B5 black will be able
to trade A3 and A4 but the resulting
position remains frankly optically this
should not be defendable and just to
kind of verify I mean why was not taking
the porn immediately because to my as
irresistible because I saw it plays G5
and now there's a threat of Rook G1
followed by 5 F4 so you have to worry a
little bit more it's a similar position
you're still much much better but it it
just prefers adding an additional layer
of safety on the king side because this
is just not running away you can do it
Whatever Whenever you want so it's it's
really the only reason it's not
happening immediately which causes me to
think from the current position uh after
A3 I put I start with G5 just yeah but
then but then I'm not going to give you
the G5 at
all I'm just going to I'm just going to
do this immediately okay Rook B6 Knight
G4 will take on B5 next comes har things
will start collapsing yeah so yikes and
I think this is the reason why it
absolutely panics with have a move and
he hasn't played A3 instead G he's G six
immediately taking away the dile yeah
still still pretty good after Rook B6 uh
playing Knight D4 here Yanka actually
pointed out a very very important detail
allowing this would be mistake right
this actually gives black legitimate
drawing chances like for instance you
can pretty much blunder into a draw by
seemingly collecting everything but yeah
Knight C2 and then suddenly everything
everything does come off but not in even
Knight D5 actually KN C2 is very praic I
wanted to show this I wanted to show you
the position in which I actually also
give up on A3 and then collect both so
after Knight C6 Rook B6 uh you should
not be playing Knight D4 white is still
better after Knight D4 A3 but it becomes
trickier because now you and he has
played Knight D4 okay and he's done it
giving Ali Razer maybe his window Al has
a minute and a half and he should be
spotting A3 here I think he will be SP I
think he should be spotting A3 and there
he is instantly instantly very very
nicely done think he probably spent like
six seconds I mean he had it in the back
of his mind yeah he knew this was
potentially coming and he worked it out
he worked it out wow uh is Wesley losing
a second Pawn there hang going to say
what's going on uh some slippage here by
uh leavon as we allowed this
technique yes no ah no Wesley is doing
something very clever here by the way uh
and we we we'll switch back to the other
end game but just briefly if we can show
this on a big diagram uh some trades
have happened after King G3 here Wesley
played Rook G3 very very concrete
operation here started by him because it
seems like this is just a blunder Rook
C7 Rook B3 Rook A7 Rook B2 and now Rook
A6 and winning the pawn and we're
winning the pawn but the problem for for
white here is that you won the pawn in
this position yeah you've won the pawn
but you've drawn the game completely
right because the king will just go all
the way to A8 one day you play yeah
eventually white will play F3 we will
continue going into the corner we will
continue going to the corner and then we
will take on G4 that's and this is
obviously a very very basic draw with
the Aon being the wrong and yet I saw
your engine
engine doesn't understand but you can
win a lot of bets by saying that you can
Queen the pawn you can
win that's correct you can you can
actually win you can actually win two
separate Bets with the same with the
same vager you you know this right yeah
that in this position let me let me
scroll down all yeah that's a different
game because because Leon is thinking
yeah we can I can I can provide some
some hustlers with ideas we we we need
to be well armed get here we get here
and we uh vager that we can Queen this
Pawn right and the person who is you
know well equipped with theoretical
knowledge of basic end game says no no
no you're not queening this Pawn yeah
and there's there's a vager being made
and then what happens is we get
here and then we play King H3 very
proudly right and then we go A8 queen
queen I queening the pond and we claim
the victory in that Vision exactly and
then after
our opponent is done shouting at us and
then pays up eventually we say I will
give you a chance to win your money back
I am claiming that you will not in this
position Quin the pawn against me and he
says well be easy money I'm returning my
yeah you're giving well earned buck so
we get here and he very proudly plays
King H3 and you say I resign I
resign not allowing you to Queen the
pond Peter I didn't know you had that
dark side to you you I mean spoken like
a true Hustler I I really feel like he's
pulled that off these Capers a couple of
times I I told that story many a time
never should TR ping it into practice
but yeah and and returning returning
here king of two kind of needs to be
played you can go 9193 but the engine
doesn't like it very much it likes 95
much more which is the intention play
Knight C6 and then you play to E4 why is
still much better but it feels like this
is this is now a lot a lot less clean
than the conversion that was in front of
leev if he played A3 here
on3 this is now very easily not one by
one and Lev is getting down on clock to
I think when he entered this ending
somewhere closer to 20 minutes than 7
and uh the clock is ticking away way as
A4 A3 keeping the queen side so you know
it just felt so nice to have the
a knight
takes I I'm confused I am totally
confused here confused once again is
inviting Knight to D5 yeah I I guess he
actually preserves the pawn because
after Knight D5 he will take on A3 and
if you take with the Knight we have
Knight C4 if I take with the Knight
Knight C4 yeah but you take The Rook
here and your pieces are so active that
really this feels like this is probably
a a draw yeah this Knight is really
really nice I'm threatening actually
Rook here if we do play Knight C4 I
think I'm going to go
check King F yeah kn5 will be played
King F2 KN D5 on the board and I'll
start harassing the pawns Rook H1 yeah
you could also just play Rook A4 provoke
A3 and then claim that white pretty much
has no way to improve from there like
Rook A4 A3 King F7 King F6 and just keep
the yeah and say that those pieces are
so completely uh stuck on their squares
and the white king takes an age to get
to B3 and in the meantime we will find
something to and there's no checkmating
ideas or or like some kind of
uncomfortable uh in this position yeah
and I was I was thinking so we KN takes
A3 on the board Al has yeah of course R
he's not going to take with the Knight
here and we anticipate Knight C4 or Rook
C2 yeah I think only tmov really exist
in this position Rook C2
even but I have a feeling Rook C2 Rook
A4 we might be losing the A2 Pawn which
is not a particularly cheerful thought
not at
all that's the problem we are facing
Knight to B4 after Knight to C4 Knight
to B4 Forks perhaps Knight B5 here
perhaps we can still keep the game float
but all of this now looks like it should
just be holdable now before Rook C4 here
is probably a the issue a good position
for white but you can just once again
play King F7 King F6 I feel just improve
our one final piece and then just start
playing H5 and H4 and creating counter
play on the other side just wondering
whether there's any chance to kind of
INE the king like I'm thinking
H4 uh for white or for black H who whose
tomb is whose King is
on we we saw this ideas of you know
white throwing in age four yeah that was
when we were trapped the Knight on E5
you know somehow just caging in the
black king I was wondering whether you
could use those ideas so why not we can
put a pawn up up here on H4 okay I agree
I'm a pawn up but the uh Rook on A4
looks really uh safe four moves to time
control Rook takes C4 um is up to 2
minutes and his position improved
dramatically so it certainly
has um Rook to C2 was our try we also
tried Knight to C4 uh you Joy you were
talking about Knight C4 maybe trying to
set up some meting net with 95 right I
was thinking 95 sorry yes and and what
was our our Sol solution to this maybe
King F7 F6 yeah yeah then then I guess
you we can go Rook a 4 and after Knight
E5 we can play King f8 or H6 or Rook A4
Knight E5 H6 or G6 even King f8 because
you don't actually have a check from C
C7 you only have the check from C8 so
right the Knight does a good job I was
just thinking like Rook to B5 you know
try to hustle you that way hustle yeah I
think we're taking on A2 here reasonably
comfortably I don't think there is
enough now Rook to B8 yeah and no first
wanted to throw in the check first of
course I apologize I apologize that was
a mouth slip just checking to make sure
that you are on your to you uh Rook
check yeah and and if you go King F6 I'm
going to go
F4 even that position I'm not even 100%
sure of that but just uh clear the cop
whips how are you killing me
here I mean King F6 F4 maybe I feel a
little bit of panic uh welling up inside
I'm not killing anyone here four versus
four it does look a little doubtful as
time slipping away but so is the
advantage for leavon and leavon is is
going to be so angry with himself like
what have I
done I mean he could have grabbed that
Knight on C5 and very uncharacteristic
knighty to okay continue not guessing
anything in this game we're not doing
good
no but then again neither is leavon he's
not doing good with his uh with his
handywork Knight to C2 attacking The
Rook yeah and once again Rook B2 looks
very obvious but Rook A4 probably is
stronger uh because that's just a
fantastic Square pretty much every
single position here The Rook on A4 is
more or less unchallengeable there is no
way white can attack it it also controls
control E4 exactly and then we start
playing G5 H5 H4 and just like
minimizing the king side as much much as
we can gain some space okay I'm going to
bite I'm going to say A3 for okay G5 and
I'm going to say at this point I ignore
King F King King F2 King fair fair fair
H5 H5 and what would just trying to do
is secure the Knight and saying you're
Pawn up but literally you're going to
need to play King B3 I am going to get
my king to E1 oh yeah you're going to oh
yeah you King walks I am going to you
did a book on King walk I did and it was
just so much fun it's great okay so I'm
going to go H4 and I'm going to not
touch anything you're going to go King
D2 okay yeah now and again I realize I'm
playing with fire I might get my fingers
burnt not really but eventually maybe
maybe already here but we can also
include King F7 wait to play King C1
even King get it as far away as possible
King of7 King C1 and then and then we
play G4 leaving the H pawns on the board
correct and I'm thinking that I'm ready
to sacrifice a piece I'd like to see
your king even scadaddle itself to the
B2 Square so if you play F4 I start
thinking about Knight takes F4 and your
king is way and if I don't touch
anything I think the threat is HD3 H3
F4 actually creating a buer on the king
side show on the board yeah remember
those Pawn break Crews that we learned
as as uh as a as babies well I wanted to
say as experts those Pond breakthroughs
they were Charming so the idea is if you
take I want to play
G3 just something to keep in mind as
we're going to return to the current
position sorry I'm just going to uh
refresh my board to get updated by
keeping and we do have Rook A4 by the
way I think that that's an incredibly
instructive moment by Ali raisen not to
play Rook B2 where optically you're
thinking your your rook's active but
it's actually A4 is a a key Square A3 on
the board and I want to say this is just
such a strange game because portions of
it both players are playing really well
ala ala kind of combines sequences of
incredibly precise defense with really
inexplicable sleep ups and Leon also
outplay the L Resa very cleanly and then
we think pretty much didn't win the game
in three moves and then outplayed him
again right and then once again just
made a decision that uh you know for for
for as experienced a positional player
as he is I am very surprised mhm with
what he has done I once lost a game to
anat karpov in Brussels where I really
felt like literally I lost the game
three times I was losing the game and he
was playing magn ific he allowed me back
in I had equalized the game I played
badly and then you know he was back in
control and finally I lost but it took
like like three three turns of passing
the whole point back and forth between
before he claimed it on move 80 or
whatever it was those are the absolute
Wars those feel so bad and they were a
German that that game had a Germans
going for it as well I was losing it
over the course of 3 days or whatever it
was I have a very specific gain in mind
when when something brings up these
types of sequences like I I lost a game
to Boris gelfound in a hman Grand Prix
once and I generally don't do well in
Grand pris I played in a bunch of Cycles
I've never really been in contention and
that was the one year where I was on
like plus three out of the first I don't
know seven or eight games I was feeling
good about my game yeah and then I lost
two games in a row one to ler and one to
Boris and the one to Boris I actually
blundered something in a grunfeld which
was hit by notes I just forgot and that
I very seriously considered resigning on
move 20 the position was that bad I I'm
also very famous for resigning in all
kinds of weird spots but in that
particular case honestly Justified yeah
I think many people would have
considered resigning in that position I
decided to play on and then Boris let me
completely back in and by Mo 40 I
thought okay I'm actually not L losing
this one somehow and it kind of kept
going and going and going I lost it Mo
like 85 going you having completely
equalized at some point painful why why
didn't you finish me off by move 25 we
could have had a dinner you
know no it's just uh tell us about uh
lanir Wesley they're repeating they've
repeated repeating they've repeat it but
I guess this is only reaching 40 because
it's difficult for me to imagine that L
doesn't try for a little bit at least uh
because there's absolutely no risk so
why not shuffle for a little bit more
more but in general uh this now seems
very very defendable because it's
difficult to imagine how white
will untangle untangle themselves to
avoid trading A4 B6 or winning B6 with
the trade of Rooks which as we've
established is an even easier draw
exactly uh so yeah seems like the
advantage is more or less gone Wesley
has somehow defended very precisely and
maybe somewhere around here uh lineer
didn't need to go for that Force line
with Rook C7 Rook A7 maybe the there was
something more precise slightly earlier
but looks honestly just like
Wesley defended very very solidly didn't
make any mistakes didn't Panic at any
point around here just played very uh
very good very good chest although I'm
I'm I'm looking at this and I'm thinking
ah it's it's this once again the engine
actually very seriously prefers H4 and
if we consider
why uh the very simple like simplistic
maybe even reason you could say of
preserving as many pawns as possible to
begin with yeah because in this position
if in this position you put the king
back on G3 and imagine there are pawns
on H5 and H4 white might be winning by
by taking on B6 because it will not be
two against one it will be three against
two and I will probably be able to
create the passer without the entire
King side disappearing right and then
all of your theoretical knowledge of
this being a draw with King on A8 will
really not come into play at all M so I
think we can actually pinpoint more or
less the exact moment where winning
winning chances for falling year went
from significant to perhaps not
realistic anymore 32 h E4 and you know
the sad part is the way you've just
described it Peter uh makes it so
obvious to ourselves our viewers of
course preserve the pawns keep as many
pawns on the board as possible play H4
maybe you get rook h8 in on a good day
and uh snip the H Pawn once you played
HG HG The Contours of the draw become
very clear exactly actually I'm forcibly
reminded of the game six in the world
championship match between Magnus Carson
and aomi yes and there the draw
technique was actually for Nomi to
maintain the porns so that was something
that white could always um focus on uh
having he couldn't just Advance he had a
free hand to advance from if once the
pawns got exchanged but with those pawns
on the
board then it was definitely something
to
tie but okay and then I can see that uh
Peter is move 40 baffled by the moves
yeah the the the up to now everything
made sense move move 40 strikes again
here because uh very cleverly here Leon
specifically on the last move of the
time control moves The Rook from C5 to
B5 asking the question are you worried
about Knight B4 here or not I guess yes
because otherwise I don't really see why
that would change Black's plans
whatsoever I think King F7 just is a
very very logical move yeah versus three
and ala for some reason blinks and goes
Rook C4 and now after Knight B4 I mean I
would assume this Rook ending is drawn
but with the pawns as advanced as they
are they will become targets and this is
maybe not as not as clean as uh as you
would think and also this is a B Pawn
and this is exactly the pawn that you
want I think in this five against four
end games or four against threes with
the extra Pawn on the other side this is
exactly the one you you want because
it's not very close to the black king
and it does provide cover for our King
if we at some point initiate a race
right uh I still think this is probably
a draw with precise defense I shouldn't
be listened to about this topics I have
no idea but I'm betting this is a draw
right but this is a this platonic ideal
of a draw it might be might be a draw
theoretically but but is it is it to
draw in practice I'm probably misusing
platonic ideal horribly I should should
never do that
again so by the way I I'm just looking
at the clock check this out I'm seeing
31 seconds which means by definition cuz
he gets a 30-second bonus he made the
move with 1 second on his clock look at
this are you kidding me and two seconds
he should SPS spends a couple of seconds
calmly shrugging oh my that was very
close I that's
shocking look at three look at the three
he hasn't started making a move yet it's
amazing and then he kind of holds it a
little bit make sure he came very close
to losing on time there he certainly
did I mean and that was the last move I
mean
wow uh mind bobing stunning in fact I
mean but these guys are very
fast I I mean it absolutely I mean
they're the best BL best Blitz players
in the world so that was crazy though
just to leave yourself one second in a
position by the way the move Rook C4 was
probably not the best move King F7 or G7
frankly any Square H4 uh I'm thinking
that you know this was a kind of a con
man's trick you know like that
oh go ahead and attack my knight uh so
that I can play Knight B4 but if you for
example if you did play King F7 and you
did play Knight B4 then we were in
a no but also Knight C3 and take on A3
next oh that's even simpler that that's
end of story nothing to discuss I was
going to say The Rook ending yeah The
Rook ending is nothing uh but because of
Rook C4 Knight D5 you're actually giving
white a reasonable
chance of winning this if you take takes
ab and okay let's uh employ the rules
first the King has to come up you don't
want to let your king get cut off onto
the a okay and now I will uh and now C
oh hang on a second there's something
needs to be done with my no actually no
no I don't need to do anything about
that one Rook C2 all right if you like
um I'm pushing B uh five B2 Rooks belong
behind P I'm pushing them this actually
might be lost right yeah it start it
start because your king is going to end
up stuck on G7 and then we will round up
and win the pawn on the6 I'm pretty this
might be lost
yeah that's so for example let me just
make a move for you this is where this
is where I'm now threatening the skew y
so I have to put my king on Gap and then
the idea is my king is going to come for
this Pawn now probably I should start
with
E4 or I would't touch anything on the
king side you think just kingy want and
just go immediately I wouldn't touch
anything go immediately racing so this
is the position you want to avoid
Joy uh and probably even when you're
here um throw in H4 G4 or
maybe to give your king the E5 Square
when I play B7
eventually yep you know what I like H4
you know what I like just go ahead and
play H4 okay so B5 gets touched B5 let's
take this guy off the board take take
yeah go Rook B4 and chill that way and
chill this way and put our King on E5
yes mhm I like this is this is where we
go so we get our Pawn to B7 something
similar but in this case the king isn't
given a free hand uh to go uh and you've
got your own counterplay based on G4
something of this nature should be
drawing what has taken place by the way
leavon kilei the old veteran that he is
the Wy veteran has played night B4 and
is inviting this ending that uh we has
some
chances
yeah by the way yes uh if everyone at
home is who Miss
Happy Well you need not worry because we
do have him here on
[Music]
tape fa welcome back to St Louis your
home welcome back to grch St also we
started to speak about the candidates
about the the main tournament one of the
main tournaments of 2024 so what do you
think in general about the State of
Affairs in the Chess World on the top
let's say with Magnus who is like Dro
some points here there dingly ran who is
absent for absent for so long like
what's going on in the the last year are
your thought yeah for sure it's a very
unusual situation uh I think that Magnus
he achieved everything that he could
want in chess in general um so he
probably didn't see any more value in
terms of playe of course there's always
money but maybe he doesn't uh worry so
much about the money anymore and he was
more thinking I don't need this and I
don't really want to go through this
process which I can understand on some
level of course because the uh stress
and the pressure and all the everything
that comes with playing a world
championship match or candidates
tournament it it does of course take a a
lot of energy out of you so uh at some
point we have to make these personal
decisions do we want to pursue success
or do we want to take care of our
personal uh life more let's say so this
is just a personal decision decision it
seems like he uh has less interest in
classical chess as a whole I think this
is not a revelation he said it himself
that he wants to focus more on rapid
chess Blitz chess maybe some other forms
of chest like chest 960 or uh or other
things uh in terms of ding I I really
can't say so much because he's less
public than Magnus so we we don't know
his thoughts as much but he has been
remarkably absent I mean he hasn't
played anything or had like let's say a
meaningful sort of um role in the Chess
World since he became world champion he
played one event the grand chest T event
in Bucharest it was yeah it was very
unsuccessful for him and he didn't play
any other events he said that he will
come back next year that's what we can
kind of maybe for the world tip super
maybe for that but he said that he would
come back in January to play an event uh
if so that that'll be interesting to see
his return I'm also very interested to
see how he plays after a long
break um and yeah in terms of the next
match of course it'll be very
interesting whoever he faces um yeah I I
think that we we're seeing a little bit
of a transition maybe in terms of other
players who are getting more motivated
magna's taking more of a step back from
classical chess D being a little bit of
a wild card now actually speaking about
Magnus and the fact that he doesn't want
to play classical chess that much um do
you think it's a chance for you actually
to be on top and now you're second
player in the in the world and so do
this Gap is not so big anymore so would
you try to actually to be on the top I
I've always tried no I mean I I've I've
always tried um Magnus was always a a
huge obstacle let's say for every player
who was trying to become uh the best in
the world and at some point we were
close but he always had that bit of an
edge on me in terms of results and at
some point I was catching up a bit but
then uh also at some points falling
behind because I didn't have the
consistency that he has and I lost my
motivation during the co years
completely uh this was I think uh I
wasted a lot of time during those years
so maybe it was my own fault but also I
think the world situation was a little
bit difficult and confusing
and the Chess World as well it wasn't
exactly clear what would happen uh in
the Chess World to chess tournaments to
the future of Chess or the world in
general so um yeah definitely lost a bit
of time and I think what what about now
it's just 30 something points no to me
it's it's less about the rating because
I understand ratings go up and down and
um yeah maybe Magnus lost a bit of
rating recently but um I'm not thinking
too much about the rating for me me the
main goal is really the candidates
tournament and uh do performing well
there and Performing well in general so
um I think that Magnus has always taken
a pragmatic view of tournaments as in
he's he's trying to win the tournament
he's not trying to gain rating or
anything so uh I also feel like this is
the most important that um yeah it's
it's all about the tournaments and
playing well and uh and the results
usually come if you're in good shape yes
so this what I wish you I mean all the
best of luck in this in this tournament
thank you thank you
[Music]
thanks hello I'm women's Grand Master
Rim janova I will be creating content
for grandest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefit
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships as well as high-profile
tournaments that attract the world's
best players become a member and enjoy
perks such as free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments and so much more
visit St Louis chess club.org to claim
your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to Jova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest tour for
follow us on social media and don't miss
out on players interviews and more
content from the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chest piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events familyfriendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy
hello and welcome back and as the
players have made the time control well
we already have two results and uh let's
check them out was a draw between
Richard report against Anish giri
whereas it was also an iname draw
between Maxim Vash and Yan piai but in
the other other two remaining games it
does seem like the players are some of
the players are struggling and uh just
to remind everyone of the schedule so
round six will be played on Monday
November 27th tomorrow it is a FR day
for the players and for ourselves it's a
time for us to reenergize recuperate and
perhaps relax and the players will be
playing all the way through to November
the 30th and remember the
will there will be playoffs if they are
required absolutely thank you JY and in
the ending between leavon and aliisa
during our break uh we're making a
rather shocking Discovery uh
Peter leavon might just simply be
winning it does appear so and it's a
kind of an end game where I think I
would know that this is trickier than
normal right because very often uh these
types of end games where one side has
extra Pawn on the side and everything is
symmetrical on on the other side it's
normally three against three these three
without the without the e pawns right
the addition of the ewn pretty much
always makes it a more difficult end
game to defend for the but I don't think
for for for the weeker side of course
but I don't think I would be
instantly confident that we are winning
here with white but yes it does feel
like black is in trouble and the plan
that we were discussing before we went
on break very specifically very simple
plan of just trying to put the Rook on
B8 driving the pawn all the way to B7
which normally in three and three
against three end games just instantly
ends the game in a draw correct but
because there's there will be this
Target on E6 for the white king to to
inch towards this appears to just be a
winning threat so black cannot really
afford to uh just kind of Pass forever
as you would have done in in a normal
situation without the e playing
something like King G7 let's say B6 King
F7 B7 King G7 once again if you push
them a bit further up and remove the E
pawns this is a very very simple draw
owing to the fact that once the king
reaches the vicinity of the B7 Pawn we
start giving checks from from behind and
you can never actually stay close to the
pawn for long enough to vacate the the
B8 square with the Rook so this would be
just a very very simple technical draw
once again without these two but with
them on the board why just goes King D6
right and says give me right and if the
pawn wasn't in E6 you'd happily drop
back with your Rook to B1 and slightly
more difficult is
this but still we I mean here King C7 of
course in fact it's on B7 so I don't
even need to explain uh tangs which
could happen after King E7 I'm pretty
sure pretty sure King E7 is also winning
AB there's Absol there's absolutely no
reason for white to even do that because
King C7 kicks The Rook away and does
give us the time to play Rook anywhere
and just win a full Rook for for that
and ala I think is now coming to terms
after King E3 has been played onto the
board by Leon he's coming to terms with
the fact that he's desperately he needs
very very desperately to find some kind
of counterplay on the king side to stop
this incredibly straightforward plan
from landing on the board but it's
unclear how you could try Rook C1 Rook
H1 but that's just not fast enough
because after Rook B7 checking of 6 B5
if you actually try going after that
pawn you're just not in time to return
Rook B8 very important Rook H1 B6 sorry
B7 with the King on G7 if you played B1
here that probably is a draw because now
the H Pawn will be enough of a
destruction with the King on F6 there is
no defense against Rook f8 check so
black just resigns here and apart from
Rook C1 Rook B1 you are struggling
really to name a legitimate source of
countly you can remove a lot of Pawns
from from the King Side by playing
something like
H3 but uh for for some reason it's
important to play King D3 here once
again I'm struggling to explain this
even to myself that let's say Rook B8
here isn't winning anymore because H
takes H takes and G4 provides enough of
a cover right but if we start with King
D3 Rook C1 okay and now we play Rook B8
I guess the big difference is in this
position we will be taking on G4 so it
was important for us to kick away The
Rook from C4 and not allow Rook takes G
so so that we can fix this structure and
once again it seems like we're losing
the G3 Pawn with check no but it will
not be it will not be returning quickly
enough yeah with the with the and and
this mechanism we haven't shown yet so
let's show this very important mechanism
seems like black is fine but no no Rook
h8 followed by Rook H7 takes B7 right uh
feels
like even even the engine with its you
know Precision Power and everything
isn't isn't capable of holding this
against uh good play from white but in
practical terms we have seen so many
swings of the evaluation of this game
already that I wouldn't be very very
confident on betting that nothing else
will happen now that this will now
conclude exactly the way it's supposed
to conclude from here but leevon is very
much in control yeah Ali Ray's fans are
going to be disappointed because of the
race for the elos right exactly I mean
we are on ratings watch because the
highest rated person on January the 1st
will get that spot into the 2024
candidates and so far Ali R of fuja has
a live rating of
2761 where the so is not that far behind
2756 and Anish giri is also in
contention
2753 but if he loses the simplest way is
calculating a loss of five rating points
for the loss
and suddenly he would have a lower
rating than Wesley so it's actually
maybe even slightly more than five point
because he out rates Leon Leon has not
had the best last couple of years in 27
27 that we yeah so Leon is going to cost
six five and a half thereabouts yeah
honestly they're all as so closely
bunched together that that additional
half a point of might be the the very
very important in the final count and
we'll return to the Rook game which is
by far the more exciting of the two
remaining games but just to mention that
this is still running right ler is
trying to get somewhere here against
against Wesley but it seems like these
two are now coming off the board I can
play Bishop D7 and just threaten to take
it next move that's a simp and it seems
like there is just not going to be very
much uh here for for ler to uh to
continue fighting with uh wesle
understandably is trying to figure out
last move G2 G3 in particular seems like
MH a very committal move there's really
going to be no changes of structure on
the king side like this so he
understandably wants to make sure he
doesn't blunder something simple but it
seems like the queen side is
disappearing and if we're talking about
some position like this exactly best
case scenario seems to me that you
somehow manag to sacrifice this Rook for
the bishop and the pawn on G4 precisely
which I mean you can imagine this being
winning if the black king is on AA if
it's on any kind of a reasonable
squ I mean in front of Pawns is very
easily drawn but even let's say on D7 to
begin with should be a very very
comfortable draw so I I don't quite know
exactly how uh black is supposed to
misplay it badly enough so that Wesley
loses thank you Peter and again uh it's
all about uh the game between leavon and
Ali Raa again we've seen so many turns
in this game we thought that leavon
should have been winning more or less
out of the late middle game and we were
stunned by a number of decisions that
leavon made that appeared to give oi Ray
a a pretty um convenient draw it was
this moment move 40 that something
really extraordinary happened Joie that
I'm still reeling from we always say in
chess you know last move blunder the
last move of the time control is the
40th move is the blunder well this is a
classic case in point uh the last move
by leavon Rook C5 at this point a simple
move like King f s would have been fine
King G7 would have been H4 the one thing
he didn't need to do was move his Rook
his Rook is ideal actually on A4 and he
moved it with one second on his clock I
know I mean keeping us all entertain wow
but that was such a shock and he nearly
lost the game on the spot and after
moving The Rook he did invite this rook
in Pawn Ending game which we now
consider well as Peter just explained
probably lost probably lost and he's
he's finally made a move here leaving
himself once again 12 minutes for now
the rest of the game noral time
forthcoming for ala very clearly you
should not be going backwards here after
King D2 Rook B3 your conversion will
become difficult if not if not
impossible because the the very clever
plan of getting the king over to E5 so
just to illustrate once again if we we
can try achieving uh the same setup but
the King goes to E5 actually here the
loses so uh do we need to play H4 first
king E7 is the only move that makes a
draw I'm so confused by all of
this can we see why the computer wins on
King E5 King E5 it goes King C2 and it
says now we have enough Tempe okay this
position now after B6 is no longer a
draw because I'm guessing once it gets
to B7 we will be able to shake I think I
can maybe demonstrate let me H let let
me try and make a couple of waiting
moves and now I think we are probably
winning with
E4 cuz what I want to do is to play E4
and then play F4 check but here after
takes takes King D6 this is enough so I
guess I'm going to be doing this with
the King on C5 I think this is maybe the
right plan but I need to I need to
organize it in a more clever fashion the
king can take a Wonder right yeah go to
yeah yeah one more up up yeah we can go
to G7 as well provoke R B1 on and then
actually maybe go all the way around go
all the way around that way in 80 Days
76 and eventually the the king because
black is also completely stuck because
obviously it's very important for black
to be able to cover the king with with
pawns because the moment white gives a
check to this King the game ends I I'm
still confused Peter help me out here I
go H4 please okay okay and and the here
you can just g g f for che apparent yeah
for che is now winning because takes
takes King takes A4 King takes A6 and
eventually I will play E4 now I guess I
bring the king all the way back and I go
e to E4 is the winning plan so you do
this I do this you do this and I
actually because if I play for here I'm
worried black will make a draw Rook down
right so that was I want it back so I
bring it all the way back oh no yeah
beautiful isn't it oh this is too much
so we do this we get you to play Rook B6
and then we go
hello please allow me to give you a
check at some point in the words of
Shak on you can be even more cruel right
you can Mo your king to D2 and get it
that way in and then go E4 yeah you can
you can find tunit even further but this
is enough with the King on C2 there
there will never be enough counter play
wow so Rook C3 check played and once
again I just want to point out that in
in sort of purely human terms there
needs to be a very very specific reason
not to play King D4 and I don't think
let me just find my place there is so
much stuff on my
screen Rook C3 played you you you always
play King D4 the reason not to play King
G4 is you find out this immediately
blunders a pawn somewhere right okay so
and and if okay Rook C2 let's try for
something okay I'm being very I'm being
very uh uh put upon I think yeah cuz
once again judging by these evaluations
this is the only move that wins what uh
okay makes sense and uh yeah this is
another thing that sometimes converts
this position quite comfortly because
you just protect everything I will play
B5 I will maybe even play F3 F4 and then
black will never be able to attack
anything and I will start pushing and we
do have King D4 as a Prelude but I'm
sorry why
ising3 why isn't this winning but
apparently apparently now uh there is
enough maybe it's just not thinking
deeply enough this might still be
winning honestly because it's it's now
no specifically E5 Saves the Game why
and then and then G4 G4 and then black
actually generates enough on the king
side that we no longer can safely uh run
up the board because I guess gf3 F34 at
some point will become a topic this is
all very intricate and uh way above my
my understanding I'm I'm going to be
entirely honest with here
um but King D4 is on the board I assume
ala will play Rook C2 because if you
play Rook B3 these all of these
variations are now a full Tempo down
exactly which I assume now after Rook B2
even B6 and this is what I was seeing on
my
screen this starts being winning because
after Rook B8 yes this time you actually
uh get get your setup but you still lose
this position because this happens a lot
a lot quicker than black can react to
let's say E5 we go King C6 and if a
check we go King D5 and you have to come
back and then stuff starts falling apart
right uh so as you can see from this
variation uh the the the problem of the
black pawns not being Compact and not
being on their starting squares right is
such that we can even give up give up
stuff in stuff in the center and still
be much faster than whatever it is that
black is doing and very times I feel
like we get master classes in openings
and endings certain middle games and uh
this one yet again uh giving us a master
class Rook C2 yeah and this is a very
very important point in the game because
if if we are to trust what the what the
allseeing eye is telling us the
allseeing eye is saying that Rook E5
defending the pawn from E2 not the most
obvious move I think a a lot of humans
myself included would be reaching to
play King D3 here but Rook E5 the idea
is to get the Rook out of the way so
that when we push the pawn we can
support it with our King and we can
build a bridge yeah I was just going to
say though we do have certain rules in
rook and and porn endings so first of
all if you do have that extra Pawn your
the ideal place for your Rook is to be
behind your own pass porn right and then
if it's not behind then you want it on
the side yes and then finally it's in
front exactly so there is there is that
little saying to Aid leavon right in
this particular case too the reason why
I might suddenly go hang on a bit I do
have Rook E5 because if you play King F6
and I I don't see the move F4 I do see
the move Rook e Absolut and a very
stable setup wait a minute Rook would
pass pawns right so so now I want to
play B5 Rook B3 and then I'm absolutely
certain I'm winning then it's like if I
get that We're Off to the Races and it's
done so I think if he just stops uh
himself here at Rook E5 and he has
stopped which I think is a good sign for
for Leon here and I think what was
confusing me was specifically I want to
show one particular position after Rook
e 5 king of6 yes I could understand that
loses but I was wondering about this and
I asked myself what what exactly is the
threat here because with the King on6 it
feels like the black king is close
enough to the pawn to uh be able to
participate in the races but in fact
Rook B3 is a threat here because even
with the King on D6 let's make a passing
move of some sort yeah like this is a
queen oops if it was on D7 there would
be king C8 King B8 but it's on D6 right
and this is just a queen you struggle to
give up rook for it frankly right but we
put it on King D6 to stop King E5 as
well so there was exactly so if if you
if you play this I'm pretty sure I I win
on the spot by just playing King E5
coming in cleaning and then this whole
thing will collapse very very
comfortably so you get here and then you
suddenly realize exactly like H4 white
will just go like GH GH R B3 oops and
then after E5 check as as is describing
like just drop the king anywhere and you
you do know you will win this yes it
might take some work but you do know you
will win this yeah 100% and uh yeah I I
think rookie five is findable but uh
it's not the most intuitive and the most
obvious move and again uh did we rule
out king D3 King D3 is a draw King D3
seems to be leaning towards a draw for
very very specific reasons but once
again I think the position after King D3
Rook B2 Rook B8 will be desperate enough
for ala to start reaching for E5 and G4
because he will know that if he passes
for three more moves he might as well he
might as well resign here right so you
you play e65 immediately B5 G4 uh let's
say B6 right and you can even play F5 F4
and as you can see there is now
constantly a threat of a passer being
created on the king side which means
that our King marches are just much much
slower than they uh need to be and so
much stuff disappears on the king side
that I'm sorry Peter it's still not
intuitively obvious B7 King G King E4 oh
King C4 King C4 yeah isn't H4 the big
idea no it just goes Rook B1 even oh
King D5 it goes and now it goes takes
takes and H4 and it says this is your
password and it says now now I will and
you might be able to get uh F and H
after GH but like the the famous the
famous end game that people often
describe actually here you don't get it
because G3 is strictly the only move but
it does make a draw but even let's say I
mean this is losing but the point being
that how do I how do I organize it right
yeah yeah like sometimes maybe you will
be a able to achieve this but this is
suppos draw King King D3 plate King King
D3 on the board very human
move and this is where you have to find
E5 and G5 I think maybe even
specifically only in that order as well
so Rook B8 because if you if you start
with G4 I'm pretty sure you lose you
lose to F4 and you will never actually
be able to shake the structure exactly
so it has to be E5 first right instantly
and then G4
and then you start threatening all kinds
of breaks meaning that the white king is
very restrictive and can white delay
playing Rook to B8 I mean it looks the
most natural move on the board but just
bearing in mind you throw you can throw
in the check but it doesn't really
change very much because B5 E5 I'm once
again I'm going for for the exact same
but to to support support ji in her
question leave The Rook on B5 for a
moment because I we knowing what we know
H4 no H4 I think you just immediately
allow I no this not not with the Rook on
be five of course ah you see that's why
we love we trick Peter give ourselves
credit just a second H4 okay
um it says G4 is now not losing because
F4 runs into Rook B3 check okay and
after this you can even take this way
really because the threat of creating a
passer on the G file my word and I think
this is actually instinctively
understandable because it seems like
we've given white the second passer but
it's like in the context of these
positions the second passer is
completely irrelevant irrelevant because
the king will be staying on H7 anyway so
you can actually play H5 I mean i' I've
lost the game along the way for some
reason but I wanted to illustrate the
fact that this setup is very sturdy
you're still not not winning this
position so I'm still confused uh if I
go after the E Pawn now uh Peter with
the King D4 there's there's always a
four I I want to play E3 I I beg you
pardon okay oh then you're going to go
E5 I'm going to go E5 and then F4 I'm
going to go F5 and that's it that's it
okay I now have legitimate counterplay
because I've created a disbalance on the
on the king side allowing me to create a
passer in the meantime Le has played
Rook B7 check I don't know if there's
apparently a massive difference between
King G6 and King F6 but I don't think
anybody plays King G6 no they all play
King F6 just doesn't look doesn't look
normal to play King G6 this is an
incredibly complex rook and five versus
rook and four but I think Peter you
mentioned that the pawn on B4 that's the
legitimate when you have five versus for
C Pawn is a little bit too close to a
pawn you don't have the winning this in
game is very fascinating but just can
let's take a look at the other on the
other game between lener and Wesley
Wesley has done something which I would
have been reluctant to do but I guess it
just holds because we left it here he
did Play Bishop D7 and here played Rook
A7 King E6 Bishop F4 and he obviously
this was already a plan for Wesley
before he played King E6 he just took on
A4 here saying I don't believe this is a
problem either I would have been
reluctant to enter this because why but
right you put the King on F6 and then
event like white will struggle to
actually get the pawn to G4 and F5 the
setup with the bishop on D7 like we can
we can continue the line a little bit so
we get here white puts the bishop on
let's say end games here where Grand
Masters have lost this yes yeah I can
remember some where the bishop missed I
think this is a long enough diagonal
that the bishop stays on it so the the
trick here is of course we just chill
and eventually eventually you do this go
F3 and I can continue chilling and I B
D2 and King E5 and then I can't move
anywhere yeah so so this is one position
where everything is completely Frozen
and the other one would be you play King
G3 you play F4 and then you find
yourself completely unable to push A5
without giving up the the pawns for
exactly Bishop for the bishop
yeah okay well very good Wesley as he's
uh found his Fortress and for Wesley
again in that race for uh the rating
place in the candidates a
draw uh very very very very uh
meaningful uh exactly it's very
important for Wesley not to lose exactly
and uh let's bear in mind as well
tomorrow is a rest day no one wants to
go into a rest
day having lost I before we perhaps wait
for that game to conclude there is
something I wanted to sort of ask myself
and also you uh if we allow King G5 do
we lose let's say we go Bishop D7 here
uh okay please don't do that to me oh
okay well let me do it On myard Let's do
let's do it on your board uh G give me
the variation you'd like to take a look
at Peter Rook takes A4 yeah Bishop takes
A4 Bish A4 King G4 let's say bish G7
King King G5 so you allow for reasons
that aren't clear to us you allow my
king to be on G5 and then you're the
question that you want to ask is that
you're allowing me to play
F4 check yeah it gets it gets to the to
the squares which I generally would not
like to to allow it to get soon I
exactly I would be very worried uh to
allow the pawns
although the question is by the way
they're keeping their Rooks on the board
which I think makes it life even a lot
more simpler for um Wesley um I don't
know JY well I've got the table base
right in front of me and it's saying
draw draw draw but you have to know the
technique which is when you get to the
pawn on F5 yeah when you get to the pawn
on F5 it's very important to go with the
King up to E5 should the okay but my
Bishop my Bishop I was messing around
and I put my Bishop on C4 so that might
make a difference well that was fine I
can do that too uh so you want to go
after for example F4 Bishop E6 yeah well
I I have I have this position on my
board so okay I can I can match position
for just a moment okay Bishop C1 King
E6 and against F5 you want me to put my
king yeah that's the only drawing move
King E5 yeah that is actually very
important to know in these types of
position so it's a good thing that we
are putting it on the screen because
yeah my my feeling was if we if we go
back to F7 we have probably lost right
because eventually we will run out of
and this is why I was speaking about the
C8 H3 being a long diagonal and I can
probably finally do it do it on my
screen as well so we can we can use a
larger screen right we might need a
bigger screen uh we going to need a
bigger boat going to need a bigger
screen here so we're talking about this
position in which uh we're doing
everything wrong yeah so let's show what
I was afraid
of this is now no longer a draw because
you're drawing technique here is to uh
control with the king and the bishop the
G6 Square now correct so white wants to
play G5 and G6 once they reach the sixth
rank it pretty much is always winning
right so you want to try and prevent
this but this diagonal is just not long
enough for the bishop to stay on it
convincingly so you like you play Bishop
B8 I go King F4 you go King G7 I give a
check you go King H say King H7 G5 and
this is just like after Bishop E5 the
king will the king will enter and you
have to stop King F6 but you don't have
enough squares it gets to F6 you play G5
G6 and eventually uh squares run out and
you resign and this is why it was so
important to uh keep them on G4 and F4
where there's plenty of squares on this
diagonal but what has happened is the
Rooks have stayed on the board and and
Wesley's actually managed to maintain
his Pawn on G4 which means that his life
is so much easier the worst he could Pro
possibly get is rook and Bishop versus
Rook I guess no I I think what the
reason lineer continues playing here is
first of all why not here's a pawn up no
risk but secondly I think the plan here
would be to try and somehow surprise
Wesley into some kind of a not mating
neck exactly so it's an empty board but
to drive the king I don't know far far
away and continue attacking the king
because yeah uh hoping to win the game
by trading F2 for G4 and then somehow
winning the bishop for the G Pawn is
just not very realistic no no and I
think we should probably return to the
Kings and to to The Rook ending because
it's just much more uh complic ated to
to defend King F6 has been found in the
meantime unsurprisingly because as we
said it's just a much more natural
Square for the king and Leon is now back
to thinking but having played Rook B7
check he kind of I think he commit
commits himself to going B5 B6 and so on
and ala will have to uh play the plan
that we were describing with uh E5 and
G4 but he also will not have very much
Choice mhm I don't think which to my
eyes feels like he probably it just out
of Sher necessity exactly well Leon does
have another plan which is just to
secure the king side before pushing the
porn but that's the problem we don't
have a a good way of doing that uh the
desirable H4 ran into G4 I guess you
could go H3 and
G4 H3 I guess uh G4 is now supposedly a
draw I wonder if E5 is also a draw E5
also seems to be holding mhm uh the big
question I was was going to ask myself
after H4 do we absolutely have to go for
this really strange idea of giving white
an additional passer and it says no it
says you can also do this and now King
E5 and even like wasting a Tempo with
Rook with Rook B1 apparently is enough
but this is a mid point because B5 has
been played Von has gone for the most
direct yeah and here it once again
appears to be an absolutely only move to
make E6 E5 E5 followed by G4 keeping
those Pawn break patterns in uh Your
Arsenal E6 E5 King E5 yeah I was going
to say King E5 is no yeah King E5 played
I was going to ask that question and
after B6 you're just not
faster well your engine seems to be
having a manic depressive adjusting
they're going up and down and the
problem is yes you can control the B
Pawn but eventually like white goes B7
and then trades it the pawn innings are
all lost so you have to give white a
Tempo to collect something and white is
just threatening Rook E8 trading the B
Pawn for the E Pawn and those end games
pretty much all of them will be will be
lost or Rook G8 takes G5 as well it's
very very strong so B6 blitzed out by
left
yeah happy to have that
opportunity yeah further reinforcing the
the idea that these in games really are
difficult to play even for the very best
players
truly King E5 but I think you made a
very good point seriously Peter this
idea that you would have seen King E5 B6
you would have analyze and realize
you're losing so you start to think
about
E5 just because King E5 leads you to a
dead
end this is where you also have to
discuss the fact that there was a bunch
of decisions to be taken since move 41
so alz actually got there with like 7
minutes on the clock and you get to this
position you don't actually have like an
internal alarm system that tells you
only move alert please think here right
You've Got 7 Minutes King E5 seems
logical E5 seems like it's slow it's not
doing very much it's only like moving
your own weaknesses closer to the white
king so that it has a more convenient
time collecting them later right uh so
you just make a move which which looks
the most natural and now oops you've
lost G it's it's it's all
very I have this image of um Peter and I
playing as a team but we can talk with
one another and then Peter is giving me
this most depressing news you know like
look we're going to lose it this way
we're going to lose it that way we might
as well make it as easy as possible for
our phon and and move our weaknesses
closer to the white
king like okay I'm wondering how we lose
if we give this check and apparently
yeah I was kind of curious if we can
take on E to here but I think we
discussed this right oh no no we didn't
have we didn't have that position this
is not the same position we didn't
discuss this is not and and and this
position is only lost for one very
specific reason oh this is just a study
this is just a
study and Rook check and Rook B5 and if
Rook B2 you lose very specifically to
Rook A5
B5 and if Rook C2 check we go King B3
Rook C6 is not winning actually you have
to go
forward King B5 Rook B2 King C6 Rook C2
check we go into D7 and if Rook B2 Rook
a rook A5 check and then we return to C6
and we have the the bridge the bridge
built yeah and does black have any
salvation in perhaps sacrificing The
Rook for the pawn and trying to run with
his own the question is where exactly
yes you very much King D4 before we
switched to
this you're suppos
to I know I'm kind of cheating here but
no now we're winning but just collecting
the entire King side yeah nice uh Joy is
actually pretty ironic uh prior to the
US Championship uh Sam
Shanklin had come to me at the opening
ceremony and said yes sir three years of
work and giving me this massively thick
book on Rook ending
so what did Sam do in the first five
rounds is get Rook ending after Rook
ending after Rook ending which he
proceeded at various times to misplay it
wasn't the greatest advertisement for
his book but uh people who have gotten
the book have just gone you know
ballistic they said this is marvelous
great stuff and we're seeing how
complicated Rook andon can be I think
honestly no Blame A touches I I want to
say that oh of course no this is I mean
it's so easy despite despite invest in
time and energy and I've also heard
Brave reviews about the Sams book
they're so varied and the intricacies
and the small differences between
something you may have even studied in
the position on your on your board so
important in every single case that yeah
people make a lot of mistakes in in Rook
endings and well just that irony where
you went King takes F5 and you changed
Direction you were supposed to go take
the rook and you didn't I'm thinking of
ways that what can go wrong
so okay so B6 black has to make a move
and say I try to go G4 or something yeah
time to play for chick nothing else wins
apparently for some reason only move
that would that surprises me that that's
the only winning move and once again the
main line here is is going to force me
to switch because the main line here
goes King D6 I go R B8 King
C6 and now after B7 Rook B3 check King
G4 Rook B4 King E5 Rook e 4 King F6 Rook
e 2 and this is this is still
winning wow even though we lose the H2
Pawn this is still winning your king is
so far away from the action how is how
is this winning we play rookie three
yeah we play rookie three and we have
and we have King takes G4 King takes G4
and the king is so far away that all of
these even with an extra Tempo this Pawn
ending is still winning you still lose
to after H4 King takes G4 you're still
you're still way too far away and can
the king kind of that's a at if I were
to to take my chances I think it would
be
here yeah King D6 Rook B8 played so far
so this has already been sort of passed
up King D6 Rook B8 and now if you play
G4 I suspect F4 is still the only move
the only move by the way you still
cannot afford to give black gf3 e F3 E5
because that will create enough of a
problem you're still you're still
supposed to play F4 and F4 only here wow
because the move
B7 I personally would find that very
attractive yeah B7 I can even throw this
in and then go King C6 yeah and now and
now enough disappeared off the other
side that uh your switches to let's say
you go8 here enough has been moved moved
from the board like H2 is hanging like
rookie 8 I can take with the King and
then take on H2 and then play H5
H4 you can still lose even this I assume
but it's harder harder yeah uh King C6
played harder for some yeah King C6
played and now there are choices now B7
is winning uh you can also repeat maybe
you can even play like Rook C8 check is
a kind of a cute little trick in these
types of position so we drive the king
away from the B file because let's have
the king B7 uh we can give an additional
check like this is the dream what we
want is to just give away the B Pawn
collect this one once this one Falls
everything else will also fall so that's
one way of doing things and if it goes
to the defile now we can actually even
switch to no actually no this is too
early I think honestly just just play B7
yeah just play B7 we don't need to fool
around here play B7 create basically an
Unstoppable threat of Rook E8 right and
just to show it on the board once this
is very obviously completely lost King
F6 G4 and pretty much any move the
simplest is just to go after the pawns
exactly
and also in the position after B7 if you
don't mind Peter Rook to B6 if you go
Rook E8 can I take the pawn in that case
sure but I can for now I can include
King D4 good point and if you play King
C7 I can I can go after the the the king
side like something like rook h8 and you
can take on B7 I'll take on H5 I'm a
pawn up other pawns are hanging my king
is just so much better than yours no
from here from here I think uh you you
take you take left to to convert this
yeah it feels like it should be in safe
hands with the S on the board now and
he's just done
it
wow incredibly complicated Brook and P
iname absolutely and I I've loved like
the possible defenses for ala fuja but
also the way that leavon has to win it
as well it's also very instructive and
whilst we are okay Ali Resa just uh
approaching the 2 and a half minute
Mark and yeah I
think has to play no more time control
or maybe throw in
aook B6 I mean what is the move which
has the greatest resistance guess the
most resistance I think it's pretty much
always G4 but by this point F4 is no
longer the only winning move there was
there was a I think on on the two
previous moves G4 would absolutely Force
leevon to find F4 or the win or the win
is once again gone but now after G4 F4
is still winning but also King E3 three
is now winning so there's a much more
much more leeway G inde most resilient
and you just said something that's
really confounding to me I mean I
thought we were going you know King C3
and driving The Rook away and King D4 or
I thought we were going to go Rook E8
you said to me that after G4 I also have
the additional move King E3 to win the
game
mhm well with the King
they struggling understand I because you
inviting black to play E5 you
know the move I thought were trying to
then we then we will finally play rookie
eight and collect that ah I got it so
okay that that's absolutely okay let's
let's ask a human question here does
Rook E8
win no no that's the one that doesn't
win and this is maybe why we want an
additional Tempo so in this position
black actually black actually gets
enough count to play with Rook B3 being
a very annoying threat so maybe this is
why King E3 is winning because let's say
just to just just to recheck pass to
illustrate this was a draw with the King
on D3 no longer a draw because we have
the F4 Square against the we go Rook H6
and start collecting got all of this is
I mean but honestly at this point at
this point I would be reasonably
confident in understanding what's going
on and in fact I thinking E3 is an
easier move to understand because once
again just to restate this maybe pretty
much forces us to collect correctly
assess this position as winning after
Rook E8 right which on 10 minutes 12
minutes which is what Leon has to
suddenly calculation yeah to to
liquidate into an equal Rook ending in
terms of material right we're giving up
our proud passer on B7 and we're
entering this which does look promising
but you you don't know you're not nobody
nobody knows you don't know uh so I
think if if we're now choosing between
F4 and King E3 Maybe King E3 is more
understandable just reestablishing the
threat of Rook E8 we just want to play
Rook E8 next move
exactly let's see what Leon does I can
finally buy into a variation I feeling
confident about King E3 that that that
feels like a really good move to me and
uh again rookie eight is what we want in
the position to just simply trade that
B7 Pawn for The Rook uh for the E6 Pawn
Yeah but just to remind everyone the
immediate rookie eight would be a big
mistake throw away the win so leavon
still has to be careful so we're
expecting either F4 that would require a
lot of accurate calculation or King E3
right King E3 I'm not sure about King E3
I'm not sure I would reach for that move
I I like it because I like this idea
very much of just sneaking my king in
but I do understand that in this
particular case after Rook
E6 uh King takes no Rook takes very it
was Rook takes B7 Rook Rook takes E6
King
G5 uh that I have this very annoying
check on B3 if my king were on E3 on the
other hand I mean I think this one is
the easiest to calculate and you're
you're you're ready to take twice on F3
right you get you get here you calculate
rookie eight you get to this position
you realize King C2 GF exists right and
you think to myself how would I improve
this position because I have more or
less unlimited time black isn't
threatening to take on B7 right how do I
improve my chances in this particular
end game and yeah you go King E3 yeah
exactly I think it's quite a difficult
move to spot I think it's much more
instinctive to pick throw in the fact
that you're exhausted after 6 hours of
play yeah exactly and you're still
calculating some incredibly treacherous
endings
uh all of the players this is really the
confounding thing about this game is
that they over the course of the the 50
moves that they made they are sort of
alternating between God level play and
mistakes they would never make in the
Blitz game right and it's just so
strange to to to watch these are these
are very very strong players and they
have demonstrated it multiple times
during this game they have also made
Moves which I think they will themselves
struggle to explain if you ask
afterwards G4 takes F3 was you have to
take with the King yeah EF Rook takes H2
very understandably is not something we
want we know that would be a way of
losing two pawns but King takes F3 Y and
now and now again the threat is Rook to
E8 uh and our desire once again is to
trade what happens if you go E5 I
guessing you go Rook
f8 because I want to be clever right f8
or even h shate as many but I like the
Rook f8 that makes sense to me you want
to collect this pawn and then after
you've collected that pawn another one
but do you have to calculate though
Joie E4 check or not King E3 King E3
yeah so nice oh that's just so nice no
it's it's very very controlled from here
no I I really very controll very much I
think that that's actually a very clean
win and Time 1 minute 40 seconds again
we think it's a losing
position
check is's reaching to play a
check no B6 Rook B6 is clever trying to
protect the E play King C7 and take with
the King on B7 protecting the E6 Pawn
Yeah but
know King
F4 King F4 to
G5 this might be the only win by the way
I saw it on my screen and I was kind of
aha the way to the way to go here uh
because really the other evaluations are
not filling me with particular
confidence we go King F4 right and after
King C7 we say your biggest problem is
your King sir it's very far away so I
will just do this right I will secure
the king side I will make sure my king
side cannot be touched and then I will
collect everything very very calmly your
your your king is very far from the
action so once again King F4 ideal is
King G5 King C the only way to win I'm
not entirely sure because you need to
let it run uh some other moves here
given an evaluation which might be
winning but considering how low how
little material is left you're sort of
less confident sometimes plus two in a
position like this might not be enough
CU I was looking at moves like Rook h8
yeah Rook h8 I I I wouldn't yeah this is
now now in the drawing territory very
very comfortable draw just got King D6
this is not not even a problem and this
is
why Rook C
keeping the king cut off on the B file
is
so horrifying for the defender your king
is just so far and he pretty much always
include moves like
E4 also draw specifically because there
is
this otherwise it would have been
winning but this creates an issue
okay nice motives to
know yeah still not very easy for leonne
and also after King for you kind of have
to calculate Rook before before check
because King G5 Rook E4 and you have to
give up some but once again it's the
same it's the same thing yeah check we
can we can still we can still do the
exact same thing here and the king is
just cut off so far away from that one
looks very clean mhm does it H4 yeah but
no it's ppon yes sir what and you
actually have to go after after the king
H5 throws it away King H5 throws it away
but this is winning
oh my goodness I4 we go King F5 and you
cannot actually defend against the
threat of King
G5 and but that's actually something
that's very relevant that's what I'm
saying we were chalking up the victory
as if okay it's really secured and now
I'm looking by way I think I've seen
this in in in theory books because now
the question is how do we we will win if
we play E4 but how do we play E4 with
this pin and black just runs out of
square you go King F3 Rook H2 and you go
King G3 here and you finally start
pushing and also let me let me let me
ask the machine something if I play King
B6 here and I don't immediately play
King G3 and D4 and like I spend a Tempo
somewhere is this still winning the
reason I'm asking the engine about this
is I thought I thought the way to win is
eventually after all the frontal
checks eventually
uh I but here obviously we go King F6
but sometimes the way to win is to do
this and then yeah and without King B5
you're you're losing but of course
nobody nobody goes King H5 here you go
closer and closer and closer King f4 on
the board in the meantime king of four
on the board but like you say uh the
players are intermittently playing
incredibly good chest with a howler
mixed in and that's really throwing his
off
by the way that that that variation with
Rook B4
check and Rook E4 and he's played Rook
before check I think we should be
watching the board and perhaps we should
be using exactly we should be using your
your analysis we've got before check on
the board I think that this is
uh I mean it still requires some very
good play King
G5 uh essentially box right I think so
yeah 7 Minutes 7:21 for uh leavon I can
see it nicely on my screen now King G5
on the
board so
Rook yeah we're expecting Rook
E4 and is it something to
play no h yeah I was thinking H4 and
then RI I was trying to trick the king
to to H5 but okay that's not possible
this was the takes and Rook G5 check and
like you say tricking me to H5 yeah but
uh yeah rookie 4 played and the big
question is whether Rook C8 C2 now is
the only thing that wins I I'm not 100%
certain there might be other things as
well for instance maybe King takes H5
Rook takes E2 and immediately starting
to push is fast enough but he really
don't want to be involved with that sure
about that one Peter you really don't
want to be involved with that rookie to
H for and are you sure I mean would you
be like you know sign me up I'll I'll
bet my
house on this on this one I've got this
in the bag I'm not comfy about that it
actually says it's winning but I would I
as long as you see Rook C8 Rook C2 I
think you always play Rook C8 Rook C2 I
do
too but this idea of returning The Rook
to secure the king side especially the
E2 Pawn but even far more important to
just to make sure that this King remains
in purgatory for the rest of the game
while your king is making a
harvest you sign me up for that one and
what happens if you just uh move your
king king and give me the pawn yeah and
then Rook to G you want to go Rook G4
okay because maybe I am threatening H3
G4 so Rook G4
but uh do I have time now do I have time
for this or maybe I just go E3 I think I
think we might have to go back to that
race well E3 with the idea of Rook F2
Rook F4 or yes okay I was thinking uh
that I was going to smoke The Rook out
of G4 uh but if we get this position
because I was going to suggest having
studied what what the engine is telling
me I think in this position what what
does win is Rook C3 okay M creating a
very strong threat of Rook E3 has to be
resp responded to with Rook E4 okay and
now we can play King G5 rookie to H4 and
I have a feeling that with the King cut
off as far as it is it's not even the H
Pawn exactly it's just that once you
vacate the E file and you will
eventually have to vacate the E file
I'll play Rook E3 and I will collect
everything that is a good point so at a
certain moment the pawn will be
threatening to go to H7 The Rook will go
to H2 and that will always be met by
Rook e
3 I think if if you look at this
position for for a little bit you
realize the pawns on E6 and F5 are
completely immobile they really are
never going to start moving right and it
does look winning but it's not a very
comfortable uh
solution yeah rookie four on the board
and big moment here uh five minutes on
the clock for leavon rookie 8 again
we're sitting in our wonderful uh
studios here enjoying you know our
commentary the commentary of the chess
engine we know Rook C8 check and Rook T
C2 uh is a winning method
but Leon's not 100% sure and he's gone
for it though he did play Rook C8 Rook
C2 and just to keep you all posted on
the game between lenier Dominguez and
Wesley so it does look like Wesley has a
very comfortable Fortress
that is about the most comfortable I
mean I remember this uh bod vinck uh is
your Bishop anchored I remember yeah
yeah yes it is then it's a draw and
Wesley uh looking very very very comfy
in this one I'm going to go back to the
Rook ending we've just seen Rook C2 uh
do you breathe the sigh of relief here
is leavon I I think he know is winning
from here I I
suspect okay well there's still one more
hurdle right because what's the hurdle H
Al ala can play H4 and check and then
rck G4 check and it's very important you
don't go King
H5 okay one last
test one last hurdle you don't go King
to H5
because I guess it's just kind of
impossible to make any progress you're
you're stuck do we play E5 do we play
King
I don't
know yeah he goes H that's the hurdle
that's the question we are heading
towards that very very G takes H4 King
H5 only move makes a draw and that's the
move Rook G4 G2 pinning The Rook on C2
creating the idea of like E5
four
nice so if King H5 by the way Rook G2
not intuitively obvious but then again I
think findable yeah you you start to say
well wait a minute F4
F3 uh yeah that's serious counterplay
what did I do with my king I feel like
an idiot uh putting my king on the H
file in that position so GH Rook G4
check on the board and this is
that did you say you saw it in the study
Peter no it's not exactly that position
but uh I was wondering if maybe my
specific question there once we get to
uh exactly this position King takes a no
I think a four or even this yeah uh my
question was is it important that the
king is on B7 and does it change
anything if it gets to B5 but it just
doesn't uh and the point is we can
continue this line for a bit King G3 on
your board Rook h8 E4 you give me all
the checks in the world I get to uh say
E3 no I think I actually go forward I
think I go to like
G6 and then you can no longer give me
checks because that will lead to King F7
right so like yeah so King F5 Rook f8
King G6 and here you have to play Rook
E8 right and I think I'm just in time to
play Rook E2 yeah y yeah this is this is
a solution I play Rook E2 here and if
you play uh King
C4 it might be the only way to win but
King F7 does
win wow hang on uh yeah correct yeah
King F7 Rook e 5 king F6 King G4 I give
a check exactly so I'm just in time
to uh to either put the pawn on E5 or
win The Rook in this in this very uh
famous
construction wow um again we've been
chalking up the victory for some time
and it again it comes down to a single
Tempo that decides the outcome of the
game Joy this is this these are 20 move
variations and these players are
calculating like Matt trying to find a
way out is Ali Raza one thing I wanted
to say about end game is that you don't
necessarily need to calculate absolutely
everything you don't you can you know
one thing that one should do when one
studies end games is you should just
collect significant positions so for
instance the one that one position that
we do see is that Peter's highlighting
right now is being cut off two lines
and yeah I just wanted to check of the
thing about king of s no E5 of course E5
is also winning here I don't know why I
played King of7 here E5 is you can play
E5 King King D5 King king6 and this is
still I have a rule once the pawn has
crossed I call it the river the river I
don't know why but I call it the river
then it's a winning I've always called
it the equator oh you know I have my
side of the globe my my space my 32
squares you have your 32 squares there's
an equator between us W great minds
River think somewhat alike you were
raised in London with the
Temps
I was actually I was in Hawaii
with with the equator um what if the
players done what have they King F6 has
been has been achieved on the board in
the me let me just refresh my board and
uh uh King
F6 minute 30 seconds for Oli and uh
three minutes for leavon y he has to
take because otherwise he will lose the
same two well okay very interesting
G2 so he he's realized that and his idea
is King takes E6
F4 oh that's a
nice only move wins here only one move
wins here okay and that's a move that we
will not be able to guess I mean I I
know but I there's not very many legal
moves so maybe I would have got gotten
it on fif Tri right King E5 no
H3 be serious H3
this is a very very good practical
practical shot by lza by the way this is
incredibly impressive spotting the this
exist why idea is F4 I think after F4 I
think we go Rook C4 yeah yeah we go we
go Rook C4 here and this ends up winning
after Rook takes E2 Rook takes F4
because the king is so far away and we
now have two so black will take even
longer than usual to actually fight
against the H Pawn advancing yeah have
to bring his4 E4 we just start pushing
E5 E3 Rook E4 and it's very very useful
for us that the H3 Pawn survives in all
of these variations but this is a bit
unfair to be honest like truly this is a
bit unfair but
H3 well I am a pong grubber so I might
have fallen come around to it just out
of necessity and they're equal on the
clock as well now now this is this is
still very
intriguing and again the subplots of the
highest rating and can Ali Raza actually
save this game save his five rating
points seen more impressive H3 H3 played
Le is good oh he awesome and if we go
and if we go Rook H2
here uh among other things we can even
win with Rook C3 apparently H we we can
even give up E2 with both of black pawns
surviving once again hugely important
that this is alive so this is becoming a
queen so quickly so wait a minute F4 H6
rookie 3 H H7 yeah and this position
although black of course will continue
from here you know you're not saving it
you know you're not saving wow wow but
I'm still I you know I just have to tip
my hat big Applause H2 H3 the first two
times I've done this uh accidentally and
I want to apologize to the production
team but now I can you know exit stage
left because Peter we lost Peter come
back why did we lose you H3 exit St H3
F4 look at leavon he just played that
last move like okay he's calculated this
out Peter yeah he I think he's actually
figured this out and he is wow now once
again pretty much nailed on to to win
this game
because Rook takes E2 Rook takes F4 even
though I have a pass
Pawn these two very scraggly ugly
doubled H pawns okay they carry the day
they carry the let's go please a little
bit further with the variation and E3
maybe here
yes okay makes a lot of sense you want
to capture a pawn are you just simply
going to go H5 Rook H3 King G5 H5 and
we're just fast
enough we are just fast enough here Rook
takes H3 King
G5 some ideas of even Rook yeah if I
Rook H4 exactly if I Rook H4 Rook G3
check Rook G4 the king is so far that we
have the luxury of actually doing this
Rook G3 Rook G4 that's just nasty Rook
takes E2 played by Ala Rook takes f4 on
Bo I'm just going to go back this is
actually the the position that the
players have achieve less than a minute
we're expecting Rook E3
uh the king is terrible the king is
terrible but the problem is the
desirable King C6
H5 King D5 H6 of course if this H Pawn
was missing it would be very simple Rook
H2 I would give up my Rook for the H
Pawn and I would make a draw the doubled
Pawn makes all the difference in the
world well E5 played E5 play play
now at least a couple of moves are
winning the simplest is just to play
Rook G4 we don't need
to uh anything fancy yeah we don't need
to think about too much we're just
pushing the H Pawn controlling the E
Pawn once it reaches E3 we will play
Rook E4 and is Rook B4 one step in the
wrong direction so the whole idea with
that is then okay I know it's actively
encouraging the king and then I want to
go H five so win so you've got Rook H4
if if you if black changes ships and
goes for the H Pawn you've got it Rook
H4 I'm not adverse to uh Rook B4 check
either I did like honestly if we want to
send that Rook on mission towards
towards the left side of the board I
like Rook C4 yes that was the other one
I wanted to say was thinking Rook
E3 but once again H5 Rook H3 King G5 is
winning we we we know that position
we're we're right back into our and
there's no way to kind of jet Us in the
pawn with it's still too too far you're
not you're not getting close enough to
the H Pawn quickly enough I was think E4
Rook E4 King C6 but Rook H6 Rook H4 will
still win very very comfortably there
because it's just way too far Peter you
are a human chess
calculator actually there are some
drawing variations okay they don't make
any sense though Rook F1 would be draw
what what what I just uh suddenly the
table base came up on my screen and it
shows you R F3 also a draw yeah but
nobody nobody plays Rook F3 the fact
that Rook one isn't winning isn't
immediately obvious to me but Cent so
we're expecting Rook B4 Rook e Rook C4
Rook G4 all win correct but Rook F1
Tails Rook f one fails yeah okay and how
why tragically it fails because of E4
okay but of course Rook C4 by the way he
kind of played that with okay 58 seconds
not not one second on his clock but 58
seconds leavon has played Rook C4 uh
that's kind of twisting the knife a
little bit a little bit but it's a
goodie it's a good it's a good move but
it does feel like he's taunting his
opponent a little bit with his end game
technique here yeah just keeping and the
variation to show here would be E4
H5 E3
yes and we probably actually invest a
Tempo in Rook e four in this position
immediately returning and yeah you can
and after Rook F2 check King G5 Rook G2
check uh King G5 yeah let's go King G5
Rook G2 Check Yes I think the simplest
actually is King H4 just nestling
yourself another reason why we love the
doubled H bonds nestling yourself
between the two H pawns and E2
H6 I think this is actually cruel this
is oh
keeping us on our tones toes but he did
play Rook E3 I have played a lot of rook
and pawn end games in my life I I I
think this is unusual in the sense that
I've never seen a rook and pawn end game
where doubled H pawns have been this
strong I mean doubled H pawns is a
reason for fail epic fail absolutely
yeah but this and in this case it's just
so unfair half a minute by by the way 20
26 he doesn't really have much choice so
I think he will play H5 King G5 it's
just I I don't know what else do you
play in this position yeah you just you
just start pushing ex start pushing and
you trust that the King on B7 is just so
far off
that oh it will carry you I have to tip
my hat to Ali Raza to that whole line
with Rook G2 and forcing the move
H3 yeah Al has gone E4 he also knows is
losing uh
and does H6 make a draw now H6 is a draw
now but nobody plays H6 here there's
play H4 I think H4 is more logical very
logical whoa he played King G that's
still fine yeah that's still that's
still in the table Ah that's the Rook G3
King H4 nestling between the Double H
Palms that is still completely
fine that is just cruel King G5
yeah in the meantime Wesley is kind of
out playing line in that position who's
playing for a win you're
asking he's going to go to G2 with the
King and then ask ask lar exactly how
are you planning to make draw no there
is a draw yeah well I'll sacrifice my
Rook on F2 and geniusly uh win uh so
King's not a big factor there uh by the
way uh lanir often times does have a a
clock issue that doesn't seem to be the
CL
here so after King B6 the cleanest is
once again this really really strange
looking go back to yeah H3 H4 chosen by
leevon which is still completely
fine um pretty much every single move
was winning there but yeah him wanting
to preserve both of his why not passers
for for the longest possible time is
very understandable yeah and I have the
table base right in front of me telling
me that it is completely winning for
leavon I mean that's the beauty of the
table base that chess you know when
there's not so many pieces has been so
worked out that the these table bases
can just indicate that's a draw right
that's a win yeah I was going to say you
could play H6 King takes C4 H7 there but
once again nobody does that because you
don't want to involve yourself with this
queen versus Rook certainly not but uh
Rook
C4 uh Rook C Rook C4 C8 uh was played by
leavon mhm
and uh the I don't think it was the
first time I became familiar with the uh
table base but it was in
1995 in Philadelphia the first Gary
Kasparov versus deep blue match they the
two sides were negotiating the rules of
the match and the idea was was ever a
position came into a table based
position
the the two sides accepted the result of
the game in other words rook and Bishop
versus Rook Gary would not Gary's the
defender Gary would not have to defend
it because the computer has access to
the table base so the idea was table
base decides end of story and it was
sort of like well how many endings were
there and it was something
unbelievable there on your screen you
30,000 endings and we do have a victory
exactly and leavon aronian wins against
Ali Resa fuja so leavon now joins Wesley
so in being tournament leader but what a
game by I don't want to use the word
epic but in some ways it really was this
was an incredible game I mean to the
very end and this the
tricks so so many tricks and and once
again starting from move 40 Leon played
almost the perfect game he didn't find
Rook E5 and if we want to be extremely
strict with him we will say that this
actually threw away the win right but I
don't think the the reason King D3 isn't
winning is entirely obvious at all right
and apart from that one misstep I think
he converted very very cleanly but yeah
there were some events between move I
don't know 20 and 30 which were quite
difficult to as commentators explain
oh maybe this game is also soon ending
in a draw I mean I love the king black
king on G2 are you safe yeah it was are
you sitting comfortably the only way to
give the only way to give check to that
King is just a blunder and okay the
position has been repeated three times
and this game also finishes in a draw uh
are you familiar with the novel as well
as the movie with Dustin Hoffman
Marathon Man Marathon Man oh it was a
scene in the in is it safe is it safe
and and I'm looking at this King on
G2 yes it is pretty safe it is safe it
is is one of the safest Kings I've seen
in my entire
life that's what I wanted to say you're
not smoking that King out yeah that is
that is a very very nicely positioned
Monarch wow
wow I mean that that that game just kind
of really just took it out of me what an
incredible game just before the free day
you were saying Joy you don't want to
lose the day before the free day for oi
Raza that was a that was a huge blow it
it could potentially knock him out of
the candidates as well potentially I
mean that game had a lot of consequences
you know he's in the running for winning
this tournament but also as you
mentioned that rating spot in the
candidates and now the Gap has narrowed
how things changed there was an
mvl uh Victory here at the sinkfield cup
where it was the American team that was
the welcoming committee MBL defeated
hearu Wesley and
leavon he came he saw he accepted the
American gifts it's actually two
Americans sharing first place Wesley and
leavon thanks to this believe uh Wesley
is probably like half a rating Point
ahead in the race now I think this was
our calculation right he was something
yeah we we don't know exactly the
fractions of the the one rating point
that are in play here but it feels like
Wesley is now in the lead with uh three
rounds effectively three rounds to go
for them to play because I don't think
either of them have no Wesley did play
against no I I will check fa but
tomorrow is the rest day though I mean
what would you recommend to to the
players to do get a lot of rest get a
lot of rest do nothing yeah tennis
tennis tennis relax just take your mind
off of Chess maybe prepare for the very
next opponent but don't don't don't
overdo it no just take a rest come to
the board with vim and bigger
MH and here's what uh the results are uh
Joy do the honors look at this and uh we
can see that Wesley so Still Remains on
top of the table with a score of three
points out of five
Lon is there with two and a half points
on out of four and there is a game
imbalance and that is due to Young
Kristoff duda's withdrawal after round
two and so his games have been voided
and uh let's go over to Anastasia who's
in the playing Hall and uh she's there
with a special
guest yeah and I have hero of the day
today Leon congratulations such a big
fight and finally you managed to win
this game what happened at the very
beginning and what you think were the
critical moments I think you got nice
position yeah I I think uh I looked at
something like that with my second uh
Aram hopan uh but I didn't really
remember what I had intended but I think
this all makes perfect sense you know
I'm just
developing and uh yeah I felt C5 is very
strange I I thought C5 is um is not the
move because after that somehow you
know um I mean if he has to play D5 then
it's not going to be good for yeah
probably he can take on C3 and then just
but uh I think uh maybe it's more
precise to take one move before mhm so I
think was let's go for some critical
moments I think there were so many in
this game so you push this D6 I think it
was really important yes to get rid of
this pawn and to on I very surprised by
Queen E7 I thought Rook fc8 or Rook A8
some sort of you know it's tiny bit
better for me but it's not the end of
the world because after this it felt
really comfortable for me you know
because Queen comes to F3 and I felt it
should be a very nice position for me
yeah and then 94 of course was
surprising I I mainly looked at Knight
D5 and I thought you know it's a tiny
bit better Pleasant position you know
you can play
Forever and after knight4 I think this
is a very nice position for white yes
yes everybody agrees with you but but I
think it was actually this moment when
he played F5 which made his position
even worse yes no I saw that I can take
and play Rook D7 but Queen B8 I wasn't
so sure I I can immediately benefit from
it you know I felt that this is a kind
of a critical thing if either I take or
but Knight C4 felt kind of a move that
should be unpleasant in time trouble for
my opponent yeah you had many choices at
this position actually when it's good
it's hard actually to make the choice
yes no because I felt A4 is such a risky
move you know strategically you know
this always is hanging I have this queen
D3 F3 ideas maybe concretely I I
blundered something it's quite possible
but uh did you feel at any moment that
you know wind was slippering or say
which was this
moment yeah I think somewhere here
somehow uh I underestimated this Rook B8
and I felt uh you know um it's it's a
very good position but it's not that
easy after Knight C6 but still I was cuz
I was in time trouble I felt you know if
I play Slowly I might not get the chance
so here I felt but it's you know it's
not type of a position that is very
pleasant for black to play exactly I
mean you have a pawn up I mean it's you
can play forever and of course I should
ask about this moment when he he made
the movies one second on CL did you
notice what did you feel at this no I
didn't notice because you notice I left
ah you were not there no I was not there
but when you came back and saw 31
seconds did you notice that you didn't
yes he made it like Rook C4 and it was
move number 40 and we know that this is
the move where you do normally mistakes
right yeah I think Rook C4 was probably
a mistake but Rook B5 generally is an
unpleasant move that I made you know
just to make him come up with the
decision this I'm not sure if this is if
what what this position is because I
really don't know okay Peter you played
actually very well Peter showed us many
many lines and I think you played really
really good from this point and finding
the more or less the only lines and
maybe you just can show a couple of
moments where you it was very surprising
you know that this is actually is
winning I felt that here
here uh
wait yes uh that here I somehow started
remembering and I couldn't remember it
fully because I thought I think the Rook
is on the short side so maybe this is
losing let's say King B5 doesn't matter
King G3 Rook h8 I mean it's of course
embarrassing not to remember I mean this
a basic position but I somehow
remembered something like this and here
King C6 King F6 I think no this is a
draw yeah Rook E4 I mean oh no
wait Rook
E2 and uh King C6 ah E5 yeah Rook is on
the Short Line yeah Rook is on the short
file so itn't I mean after five hours of
play I mean you you're you can forget
anything you want you know King F7 King
F6 so but if if the if the king is here
and The Rook is there it's a dead draw
it's a draw yes okay yeah but because of
the Rook here but it's uh I I was kind
of shocked that I have to Reserve to
this and here of course I think H3 is
the only move I felt mhm maybe something
else is winning too but I felt I need to
play this in order to have this uh Rook
C4 business but here you know I I was
very
shaky yeah I can imagine but I mean to
win such a game which actually now you
have plus one it's complicated with the
standings but do you feel as a leader
now of the
tournament co-leader well it's hard to
tell but uh
you know winning a a classical game is
always a Wonder as my friend bis gin
said and I I agree with him even more so
nowadays so you need to make a little
Wonder to win and uh yeah I'm very happy
I manag exactly this is what happened
thank you so much Leon have a good rest
tomorrow we have a free day all the best
in the next games very much thank you
Anastasia thank you for leavon and
indeed that move H2 h three I felt it
was necessary it absolutely was it was
it was the only uh winning move and
here's our remaining schedule yes and
it's important to note that tomorrow is
a rest day for the players so the games
will be resuming on Monday November 27th
and then from then on the players will
be playing every day until November the
30th and of course playoffs will be
played if necessary thank you Joy and I
tell you Peter uh that Rook ending
really uh I feel like I need to rest
after that Rook ending final thoughts of
this was a day and a half yeah in
particular that game that game featured
so many twists and turns and then
eventually study like conversion by by
leevon who figured out the very very
intricate end game at the at the end I
think he made from move 40 until the end
of the game he made one I will call it
an inaccuracy I don't even dare call it
a mistake and that was a very very clean
conversion after the somewhat shaky play
earlier we've doubled the tally we have
we're on T now yes fantastic fantastic
stuff and uh tomorrow uh tennis uh
potentially for some of us it's on the
schedule yes are are you saying yes we
can see you on the tennis cour oh yes oh
yes oh yeah I've got my racket I've got
my uh shoes I'm ready to go and then
four decisive uh rounds starting from
from Monday everything to look forward
to the rating uh sport race has
tightened up beautifully for the last
four rounds wow um let's let's just
enjoy it while while it lasts what can I
say absolutely and we've officially
passed the halfway mark and now entering
into the second stage of the tournament
but tomorrow it is a rest day and for
now we are going to say goodbye and
thank you everyone for watching and see
you on Monday same time same place good
night
everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited but